hey everyone welcome to simply learn's
youtube channel today we will learn a
full course on how to become a java
developer but before we begin make sure
that you have subscribed to our youtube
channel and don't forget to hit that
bell icon to never miss an update from
simply learn
now without further ado let's get
started with the agenda for today's
discussion
before we begin with the actual course
on how to become a java developer let us
understand the importance of java
through its brief introduction where we
will understand how do java spread its
roots in the current id industry
followed by that we will understand the
skill set required to become a java
developer and the current salary trends
in the it industry
next we will learn the current job
trends of java developer in the id
industry so followed by understanding a
briefing about java and java developer
skill set and salary trends we will
begin with the course first we will
start away by understanding the
fundamentals in java that is the
operators in java so we will understand
the automatic operators in java next the
unary operators in java so followed by
the operators in java we will get
started with the conditional loops in
java so we will discuss the do while
loop while loop for loop next we will
start with enhanced for loop nested for
loop in java so once we are done with
the conditional statements in java we
will start away with access modifiers in
java followed by that we will enter the
object oriented programming segments in
java that is the encapsulation
abstraction inheritance interface and
polymorphism and in polymorphism we will
discuss about method overloading and
method overriding in java once we are
done with the oops concepts in java we
will start with exception handling in
java
followed by the exception handling in
java we will begin with collections in
java so we will be discussing array list
in java linked list in java hash set in
java tree set map hash map and tree maps
in java so once we are done with the
java collections we will start with
enterprise edition of java and java
servlets followed by that we will enter
into the java advanced concepts and
finally to make things interesting we
will wind up this session with some
frequently asked java interview
questions to keep you always on the
safer side and crack the most important
career opportunities in today's era the
internet and smartphones have become an
integral part of our lives we use our
phones for almost all of our day-to-day
tasks earlier we used to shop at malls
queue up in front of banks and make our
travel bookings at travel agencies but
now we can do all this in the comfort of
our homes using smartphones all of this
is possible because of a high level
programming language called java hi guys
welcome to this video that will tell you
everything you need to know about the
class-based object-oriented programming
language java
java is an object-oriented programming
language that is used in a distributed
environment on the internet it is a
high-level language that is easy to read
and understand
java is popularly used in console
graphical user interface web and mobile
applications game development and also
to make embedded systems apart from
these java is also used to develop
software for devices
it is used not only in computers and
mobiles but even an electronic devices
like televisions washing machines air
conditioners and so on online forms
banking and shopping are possible
because of java
java is a computer-based programming
language invented by james gosling and
sun microsystems in 1991. he had a
single motto while creating the language
it was right once run anywhere this
meant that the code would have to be
written only once but it could be used
anywhere they named this language oak
because of the oak tree outside
gosling's office later it was named to
green then to java coffee which was
named after the coffee from indonesia
and finally to java in 1995.
there are three editions of java each
programmer can learn any of these
editions based on the application they
want to make firstly we have java
standard edition this edition contains
core libraries like java.lang java.util
etc secondly we have java enterprise
edition this edition has apis like jms
ejb jsp servlets etc and lastly we have
java micro edition which is used to
program java in cell phones set of boxes
handhelds and so on
java is an object-oriented programming
language based on c and c plus however
it is improved and simplified to solve
the errors in programming java files are
converted to bit code format using a
compiler and then executed by the java
interpreter the whole java code is run
on the java virtual machine which
provides a runtime environment now the
main concepts in java are its methods
and classes a method is a block of code
that performs a task only when it is
called consider this example while
watching tv you use the tv remote to
change channels each button on the
remote performs a different task methods
in java are the same we can have methods
to add two numbers or email a person or
to convert kilometers to meters a group
of methods make a class classes are used
to organize code just like how fruits
vegetables and clinical products are
divided into different sections in a
supermarket
there are a lot of features in java
let's start by looking at them one by
one it has a simple syntax and is very
easy to understand and learn java
language is robust it eliminates errors
that occur in the c and c plus languages
java also has features like garbage
collectors and exception handling this
makes java very unique the most popular
feature of java is that it is platform
independent here compilation happens in
byte code and because of this java can
run on any machine it is a very secure
language as it contains no virus
java has a feature of multi-threading
the feature of multi-threading helps
java do multitasking java is a portable
language as it can run on any platform
and data type sizes are set permanently
so java program has a fixed size of the
code the last of all java is not as fast
as c and c plus plus but provides higher
performance than any other language now
let's see oops concepts in java java has
four concepts abstraction encapsulation
inheritance and polymorphism in java we
use objects and classes related to the
real world that makes the code easier to
make and understand abstraction means
showing the relevant information that is
needed for a task encapsulation makes
the java code secure
data is stored within the classes and it
is not easy to access the data the next
feature is inheritance as the name
suggests the attributes and
characteristics of one class can be
inherited by another class because of
this coders take less time to create the
code lastly we have polymorphism which
means using the same method for
different tasks in java we can use the
same object or variable in two different
places where their tasks will differ
java programming language is one of the
most sought programming languages in the
current iit industry unlike the older
times java isn't the same the latest
updates and the inclusion of new
libraries and apis have brought down the
learning curve of java shallower and
made it much simpler than ever before
this is the reason many beginners and
professionals are now looking for a
major career change through java
if you ask me then it is the perfect
time to switch to java now everyone has
the same query what does it take to
become one the skill set the roles
responsibilities etc etc don't worry
about that that's what we are here for
so sit back relax and make a note of
everything we discuss or take a
screenshot of the skills that i specify
and kick start your journey not just to
learn but master java programming
language
so this is our agenda for today
first we will start by having a good
briefing of who exactly is a java
developer
followed by that we will directly dive
into the skill set that we need
according to the current standards to
become a successful java developer and
next after skills we have the crucial
roles and responsibilities and finally
we will discuss the salary package and
the companies which are hiring java
developers currently
in india usa and the uk
so without further ado let's get started
our first question who is a java
developer
so java developer basically is a
professional computer software developer
who uses java programming language to
build the software
now java developer mainly uses java to
build software for desktops mobile
phones and also develop software for
similar electronic devices such as a
smartphone tablet etc now to become a
java developer we need to have at least
a bachelor's degree in relevant stream
preferably computer science later you
might want to join an internship or a
training exercise that involves a
project awesome highly recognized
certification like oracle certified java
developer then your dream job in your
dream company so this was a simple
walkthrough or roadmap to become a java
developer now moving ahead we have a
main topic for today's discussion that
is the skills required to become a java
developer
now we shall categorize this into two
stages one is the beginner and the other
is the professional we shall discuss
each one of them separately so first we
will start with a beginner so these will
be the basic skills that any interviewer
will be expecting out from a pure
beginner
so in the beginner's section the first
skill that we will be discussing is
related to the object-oriented
programming concepts in java so for a
beginner the concepts of object-oriented
programming in java play a very
important and vital role for an
interview
so he or she should be having a strong
grip over the object-oriented
programming concepts in java
so followed by object-oriented
programming concepts in java we have the
next important concept in java which is
the file input and output operations and
serialization
so serialization is another way of
executing your code from a different
place for example if you write a code
and you wanted to execute the same code
in a different place in a different
computer all you can do is just
serialize your code to that particular
system and
there the same code will be executed so
followed by the second point the third
important skill we need to have is the
good understanding of data structures in
java
data structures or java collections are
the most crucial parts of programming so
for a beginner it's really important
that you have a good grip over all the
java collections so followed by that the
next important skill you require is
to learn how to handle exceptions
so exception handling plays a vital role
in real-time programming
so you better have that next after
exception handling we have the good
understanding of jvm and memory
management
so jvm basically is the java virtual
machine so what happens in java is you
write a code and that particular code is
compiled and converted into byte code so
this byte code will be transferred to
jbm and then jvm executes your bytecode
and results in an output so you need to
have the good understanding of jvm and
the memory management concepts in java
for a beginner level so followed by that
the next important thing is
multi-threading and synchronization in
java so all those were the basic and
important crucial skills required by a
beginner if you're attending for an
interview because these are the basic
skills that every interviewer will be
looking at in a beginner so let's have a
quick overview of the skill set again so
for a beginner level the major skill
sets that you require are to have a good
understanding of object oriented
concepts in java
next
the file input and operations and
serialization concepts in java
good understanding of data structures or
collections in java
exception handling jvm or java virtual
machine and memory management and
finally multi-threading and
synchronization
so these were the major skills that are
required by a beginner now followed by
the skill set
we will have another slide that depicts
about the ids that you must be
comfortable with
so for a beginner these are the basic
ides that you should be comfortable with
which are intellij eclipse and netbeans
and also these are the mainly used ids
in real-time programming as well so if
you are comfortable with these three
ides then it will be an added way to
resume so followed by the beginner we
enter into the next level which is the
experience level so this is really
important so we have multiple skills
required by an experienced level
candidate
so the first one amongst the important
skills required by an experienced level
candidate are a good knowledge of big
data and artificial intelligence yes you
heard me right artificial intelligence
there is a major misconception that
r and python are the only languages that
are built for artificial intelligence
and data science but in reality even
java can perform the artificial
intelligence data science and machine
learning jobs using the new libraries
which are dedicatedly written for the
purpose now for an advanced or
experienced level candidate the
knowledge of these libraries and the
workflow is really important so followed
by that the next important skill
required by an experienced level
candidate is a good understanding of
blockchain
next after the blockchain there are
multiple big data frameworks out there
which you need to learn
next after that we have microservices
spring boot and scripting languages such
as angularjs react.js and javascript so
let's have a quick overview of the skill
set required by an experienced level
candidate so those are ai and ml
libraries in java good understanding of
blockchain how to open big data
frameworks spring boot microservices and
finally advanced scripting programming
languages like angularjs javascript and
react.js
now these skill sets might look big
complex complicated and hard to digest
but java developers are categorized into
multiple streams of development just for
example we can see java developers
working over web development android
development full stack big data machine
learning artificial intelligence and
many more now let us consider three most
popular streams where we find java
developers which are the web development
areas android development areas and
finally the full stack development areas
so first we will discuss the skill set
required by a web developer
so for a web developer these are the
major skill sets required which are the
good knowledge of java servlet pages or
jsp
popular markup languages such as xml
html and next after that we have model
view controller so one should have a
good understanding of model view
controller or mvc architecture followed
by that we have good knowledge of web
technologies like css and javascript and
finally java applets so the important
frameworks for a web developer to be
well versed with are apache struts play
google web toolkit and finally grails so
these are the popular frameworks that
are currently in trend and used by java
web developers so followed by the web
developer next we have is the android
developer so an android developer is a
software developer who specializes in
designing applications for android
marketplace the android marketplace is a
direct competitor to apple's app store
this means most of the android
developers job revolves around creating
apps that we use on our smartphones and
tablets now the skillsets required by
android developer are good grip over the
android sdk or software development kit
next the android testing followed by
that a better understanding of android
api and database database connectors
like jdbc and android security and
finally get version control now get
version control will be really helpful
to keep your code updated now followed
by the skills required by an android
developer we will go through some
important frameworks and user interface
development software tools required by
an android developer in real time first
let us discuss the user interface
development tools like flutter and
react.js which are the most popular ones
amongst the others
so react.js is an open source front-end
javascript library for building user
interfaces or ui components it is
maintained by facebook and a community
of individual developers and companies
react can be used as a base in the
development of single page or mobile
applications so next after react.js we
have the flutter flutter is an open
source user interface software
development kit created by google it is
used to develop applications for android
ios linux mac windows google and many
more from a single code base
so next we have the solar 2d solar 2d is
a free and open source cross-platform
software development kit and then we
have the android studio that is another
popular development kit just for android
now next in the docket is the java full
stack developer a full stack web
developer is a person who can develop
both client and server software in
addition to mastering html and css he or
she also knows how to program a browser
like using javascript jquery angular and
view so now the major skill sets
required by a full stack developer are
having a good understanding of software
design and architecture understanding of
devops knowledge of microservices apis
and libraries design patents in java
react and angular scripting languages
and finally should be capable to work on
front-end and back-end so these were the
major skills required by a full-stack
developer so followed by this we shall
also discuss the major frameworks
required by a full stack developer
so these are the major tools frameworks
and scripting languages that are
supposed to be known by a full stack
developer we have the integration tools
such as jenkin and devops related tools
like kubernetes and docker and scripting
languages like angular and react and
frameworks like spring and testing tools
like junit
so with this we will move ahead into our
next important topic that is the roles
and responsibilities of a java developer
so first we will discuss the rules and
responsibilities of a java developer at
beginner level
so the important roles and
responsibilities for a beginner are
to be able to define the objectives by
analyzing the requirements of the
clients followed by that to be capable
enough to complete the assigned job
before the deadlines design and test
basic codes resolve the reported issues
in time
and troubleshoot the code improvise the
existing code quality and finally
support the user with proper
documentation of the code so these were
the important responsibilities of a java
developer at beginner level now let us
advance to the next level where we will
discuss the rules and responsibilities
of experienced level candidates
so the rules and responsibilities of an
advanced level or experience level
candidate are
all the basic responsibilities of a
beginner so followed by the basic
responsibilities an advanced level java
programmer should be having a thorough
knowledge of system functionality and
features followed by that the experience
level java programmer should be able to
design and develop user interface
enhance the reputation of the company
recommend updates based on the
performance ensure the best possible
responsiveness and finally explore and
add value to the achievements of fellow
co-workers
so these were the important roles and
responsibilities of a java developer
both at beginner level and experience
level now let us check out the companies
which are looking for
java developers there are many companies
that are looking for java developers in
the current iit industry
some of the major mncs looking out for
java developers in the current iit
industry are cognizant in forces oracle
capgemini dell amazon web pro emphasis
and accenture now that we have discussed
the companies hiring java developers let
us take a step further and discuss the
salary trends of the java developers in
the current iit industries
now let us discuss the salary trends of
java developers in india first so the
salary trends for a java developer who
is going through the beginner level or
an internship level start from 2 lakh to
4 lakh rupees per annum similarly for an
experienced level java developer the
salary trends start from 5 lakh and go
up to 10 lakhs and above based on your
experience level and skill set
now let us go ahead and discuss the next
country which is the united states of
america so for a java developer at
beginner level
america offers fifty five thousand
dollars to eighty thousand dollars per
annum similarly for an experienced level
candidate america offers 85 000 us
dollars to 1 lakh 25 000 us dollars per
annum based on the experience and skill
set now finally we have the united
kingdom the united kingdom offers 45 000
pounds to 60 000 pounds for a java
developer at a beginner level and
similarly for an experienced level java
developer united kingdom offers 65 000
pounds to 85 000 pounds per annum so
these were the salary trends of java
developers in multiple countries so if
you wish to join the right training
exercise that covers the complete skill
set according to the standards of top
mncs curated and explained in a detailed
manner by real-time industry experts
then simply learn would be the right
choice if you visit the simply learn
official website for java related
training then you can find the simply
learn has beautifully organized all the
major topics of java in a result
oriented manner that will be helpful for
both beginners and professionals
so the key features of java training
offered by simply learn will have 70
hours of blended training hands-on
coding and implementation of two
web-based projects it also includes
hibernate and spring frameworks 35
coding related exercises on core java
and lifetime access of self-paced
training and finally the flexibility to
choose your own classes
so the benefits of java certification
training offered by simply learn will
have the following you can achieve your
designation of becoming an java
architect java developer database
administrator or web developer with the
certification from simply learn on java
so the average salaries for a java
developer with certification will be
varying from
16 lakhs as minimum and will also reach
up to the maximum of 27 lakhs per annum
the java certification from simply learn
has been recognized by multiple
multinational companies and some of the
major mnc companies that are hiring java
developers with the certification of
java are wells fargo oracle accenture
citibank and many more now we have the
three varieties of training options
which are self-paced learning online
bootcamp and corporate training it's
hard for someone who's even remotely
interacted with the idea industry to not
have heard of java so let's ask what is
java
with the whopping 9 million users and
counting java which was initially known
as oak is something that is taking the
world of software development by storm
java which was based on c or c plus plus
is a programming language that is class
based concurrent and based on the
principles of object-oriented
programming with the slew of new
features that java 8 and 9 brought out
the language was significantly changed
enough so that most multinational
corporations like amazon flipkart and
goldman sachs use java for their large
scale projects but why should someone
consider using java in the first place
here's why
it's a stable language with proven track
record and established best practices
backward compatibility
code that was written in a much earlier
version can still be worked on in the
latest version
ability to work in large teams static
typing interfaces and design patterns
make it very easy to use java in
engineering teams versus python ruby and
javascript
immediate hiring there will be more
number of jobs in java
quality jobs large number of jobs
requiring to design complex systems use
java few areas where java has been
successfully implemented are
android applications web applications
trading applications big data
technologies payments e-commerce and so
much more
so who's a java developer
this term is interchanged with java
programmer from one organization to the
other
a java developer is a programmer who is
specialized in integrating java in
software's websites and business
applications
a developer must be able to understand
the client's vision about a particular
project and devise an appropriate course
of action to follow
to determine whether the finished
product satisfies the customer's
requirements and if any issues exist to
solve them quickly to deploy the product
or code into a live environment
what do you need to make your resume
stand out from the several others vying
for the same position
this is what gives you the upper hand
being up to date with new features that
each progressive update to java brings
did you know that java 9 brings features
like the j shell process api and micro
benchmarks ensuring more versatility and
further customization
being well versed in intellij or eclipse
knowledge in these concepts increases
productivity dramatically
also having skills in the following is a
huge plus
spring framework
using its portfolio projects several of
the modern business requirements can be
satisfied springboard helps simplify the
bootstrapping and development of a new
spring application
test driven development to repeat a very
short development cycle to help increase
productivity and quality
system design
java is frequently used to design
large-scale complex systems
the ability to design systems well is
very critical for employability as a
java software development engineer
especially for more senior roles object
oriented analysis and design a method
where the logical components form the
basis on which an application is
analyzed and designed relational
databases sql and object relational
mapping
relational databases
it is a unified set of various sets
coordinated as records tables and
columns
sql it is a language that can be used to
communicate with a database
object relational mapping it is a
technique that uses object oriented
program languages to convert data
between systems that are incompatible
with each other other areas that can be
focused on are ejb which is enterprise
java beans java based web services j2ee
framework and xml xquery and xsl so what
does a java developer do
assist in activities that involve the
software and architecture
design implement and maintain the many
faces of a java application
analyze the software perform programming
testing and debugging
determine application issues in regards
with production and otherwise
develop test and maintain the software
recommend changes in the already
established java application process
develop code for applications
lack the required skills don't worry
we've got you covered
with an emphasis on everything about
java the course is core java training
and advanced java training at
simplylearn.com is a great starting
point for students who have some
understanding of the core java concepts
over professionals who seek to gain more
exposure and understanding into the
world of java
we help students and professionals
understand concepts such as scope of
variables operators arrays loops methods
constructors spring frameworks hibernate
and so on the course also helps in
gaining hands-on experience in jdbc and
junit framework helping you get the
upper hand in a world of competition
let's get started with operators in java
when we talk about operators in java
there are multiple types of operators
like assignment operators arithmetic
operators unary operators then we have
conditional operators and logical
operators and we also have bitwise
operators and we will cover all of these
operators one by one we will understand
what how what these operators are and
how they work and we will also look at a
demonstration of it so let's get started
the first operators we are going to
discuss is about arithmetic operators
and assignment operators and we will
also see if we can cover unary operators
so when we talk about assignment
operators i have again opened the
official java docs here if we understand
assignment operators we have been using
this operators all the while in all of
the demos so far and the basic idea is
very simple whenever you assign a value
to a variable you use the assignment
operator which is nothing but the equal
sign we have already covered this in
multiple demos so i will not cover this
as part of the demo but what i am going
to cover in detail is about these
arithmetic operators so arithmetic
operators are basically used to perform
any kind of arithmetic operation on a
java program it can be an addition
operation it can be a subtraction
operation it can be a multiplication
operation a division operation or an
operation by which you can find the
remainder of the division so we will
look at each of these
with an example and as you can see the
symbols are expectedly what you
generally use in mathematics so
you see the plus sign here which is for
addition you see the minus sign which is
for subtraction you see the star sign
which is for multiplication you see the
slash sign which is for division and you
see the percentage sign which is for
finding the remainder of our division so
let's see an example of each of these
and how we can use them in a java
program so for the arithmetic operations
i have prepared a demonstration of it in
the eclipse ide again i am using the
same java project which i have shown you
we created in our previous lectures so i
will for all the demonstrations i will
just continue on the same project so
again the way to create a class remains
the same exactly the same as how i
covered in the previous lecture in the
hello world program where we created a
class so here also i created a class i
named the class as arithmetic demo and i
have a public static void main method
inside this particular class
and i have basically tried to
demonstrate each of the operation so
let's start with the addition operation
first
so i create an integer variable here
named as result and then i try to use
the addition operator to make this
variable store the result of this
addition so it's a simple one plus two
you can also create two different
variables for 1 and 2 let's say x equal
to 1 and y equal to 2 and you can also
do end result equal to x plus y it will
have the same effect but just for
simplicity i have put the literal
numbers here so result is storing the
the expression value of 1 plus 2 and
then i'm printing this value here you
can see i'm printing the result variable
here with using
system.out.println then i'm storing this
result into a variable into a new
variable original result with using the
assignment operator and then i'm trying
to subtract something from it so now i
am saying result equal to result minus 1
it means whatever the current value of
result is subtract minus 1 from that
value so the value was 3 here and here 3
minus 1 becomes 2 so the new value of
result becomes 2 the original result
still holds 3 because it is storing the
old value the new value of result has
now become 2 so i'm printing the
original result and
then what i'm doing that i'm again
assigning the new result which is 2 to
the original result so now original
result and result both are at 2 then i
move ahead and i try to demonstrate the
multiplication operation so i take the
same variable result and i say multiply
it by 2 so whatever the value of result
was which at this place should be 2
multiply that value by 2. so 2 into 2
the new value of result should become 4
after this multiplication operation and
again i'm assigning the value of
original result to this particular
variable and then i'm showcasing the
fourth mathematical arithmetic operation
which is division so you can see result
by 2 here so basically whatever the
current value of result is i'm dividing
that value by 2 so 4 divided by 2 should
become 2 so again the new value of the
result variable should become 2
then i'm printing the value and again
storing the value back into the original
result
then the next operation is again an
addition operation where i whatever the
value of result is at this particular
point which is 2
add 8 to that particular value so the
new result value becomes 10
and then i'm printing that particular
value again assigning the original
result to the result and then to
showcase the remainder operation i'm
doing result
we call this particular operator as mod
or modulus so result modulus 7 so the
current value here is
in this case would be 10 so i'm saying
10 mod 7 so 10 mod 7 would become 3
because if we divide 10 by 7 the
remainder should be 3 and this modulus
operator is used to calculate the
remainder of a division operation so
that 3 will be stored in this result
variable and then we print that
particular variable so that is what i am
doing
if i take you back up there i will just
minimize this window and this window as
well so if i take you back to the
starting
i'm doing an addition first here at line
seven then i am doing a subtraction at
line 12
then i am doing a multiplication at line
and a division at line 22
and then again an addition at line 27
and then a modulus at line 32 and i'm
printing the respective values so let us
run this program and see what results do
we get so i right click i go to run as i
go to java application there is also a
shortcut for it if you want to use the
shortcut you can use that so i click on
this and the output is displayed here so
you can see let me bring this output
back to its original position yeah i
just dragged it here to the top to the
bottom so if we start from the top and
see what all results did we get printed
so line 9 says 1 plus 2 equal to the
value of result so 1 plus 2 equal to at
this particular point the result value
was 3 because 1 plus 2 equal to 3.
moving on the next variable here is
minus so the current value was 3 we said
3 minus 1 which becomes 2 and we store
the value of result or 3 into this
result variable and we print that value
at line 14. so original result plus
original result is 3
then a string here minus 1 equal to so
this is just a string
and then the actual current result value
which is 2. so far so good we move ahead
and then at line 19 we are multiplying
the current value of result by 2 and
again displaying the original result and
the current value so
2 is the original result here because
here 3 minus 1 had become 2 so original
result value was 2 multiply that by 2
becomes 4
then moving on to the line 24 2 by 4 by
2 should become 2 so 4 by 2 equals 2 the
current value of result then again
moving on to the next variable
at line 29 now the result value should
become 10 because 2 plus 8 is 10 and
again we are printing the original
result and then the current result value
so the original result was 2 then we
added 8 to it and the new result value
had become 10 which is coming from this
particular variable
moving on to line 34 we are again
printing the original result which was
10 here and then we are saying this
particular string which is modulus 7 and
the current value of result is coming
from this expression which is 10 modulus
7 and like i said modulus or mod
operation is basically used to calculate
the remainder of a division operation
which so 10 divided by 7 remainder is 3
so that becomes 3 and that's why you see
the value 3 so this is a demonstration
to show you how we can use the addition
multiplication
subtraction division and modulus
operators which are all the arithmetic
operators let's get started with unary
operators so when we talk about unary
operators technically they are also
arithmetic operators but they provide us
a shorthand or they have a more advanced
meaning so if you see on the screen
these are the unary operators
we call them as junary plus unary minus
increment operator
decrement operator and logical
complement operator so when we talk
about the unity plus operator basically
it is used to indicate a positive value
so whatever value you are having it will
just make that number as positive number
you might be wondering that this plus
has an addition meaning as well right
which we saw in the previous example yes
that's correct but when we use that
addition symbol we use that between two
variables but when we talk about unary
operators they are used with a single
variable that is why the name unary
because they are used with a single
variable they require only one operand
so
unary plus basically makes any number
positive generally minus negates an
expression and makes that number
negative
increment operator increments the value
by plus 1
decrement operator decreases the value
by -1 and logical complement operator
inverse the value of the expression from
true to false or false to true let's
understand this with the help of an
example so i have created a class here
called unary demo and i have a static
void main method here and i have created
a variable called result and the first
example is about using unity plus so i'm
creating a variable called as result
assigning the value as 1 and just
putting one plus in front of it which
makes this as positive value though we
can argue that
this also has the same effect as this
and yes that is true but in case if this
value was written as
something like minus 1 instead of plus
then we could basically make that number
positive by just putting plus in front
of it so that's basically the power of
unary operators and that's how you
generally use unary operators so i just
put it back to plus one the next example
is about decrement operators so the
current value of result was one because
we did this now we are saying result
minus minus which means whatever the
value of result is
just decrement it by one so the current
value was one so now the new value of
result after this evaluation becomes
zero
so at line 14 we print the current value
of result which is zero moving on at
line 16 we are using the increment plus
plus operator here which means whatever
the current value of result is just
increment it by 1. so the current value
of result was 0 till this line so it
becomes 1 because this means increment
by 1 so line 18 will basically print
that value 1 and then at line 20 i'm
using the unary minus operator which
means whatever the value of result is
just negate it just put a negative in
front of it just make that number
negative so if i just say minus the
result the current value of result was 1
so it became -1 and then to showcase the
negation operation i created a boolean
variable
named it as success assigned the value
of this variable as false and printed
the value of
success variable as is first
and then printed the value of success
with a negation in front of it with an
exclamation mark which will basically
flip the value or invert the value of a
boolean variable so if this was false
line 28 should print true if this was
true
line 28 should print false in this case
this is false so the line 28 should
print true so let's right click on this
and run this program and see if we get
the expected output and yes we see the
output here so let's try to interpret
the output now the line 10 should print
yes
then line 14 should print 0 we see 0
here
line 18 should print 1 because we use
the increment plus plus so 0 plus 1
became 1
then we use the unary minus operator so
the value should become -1 yes we see
minus 1 here and then for boolean
variable we should see first the false
because the value is printed as is and
then we are printing a negated value so
we should flip the value from false to
true and yes it is printing the value as
true so this was about unary operators
now when we talk about this increment
and decrement operators what if i put
this particular value in front of result
what effect is that going to happen
let's analyze that part as well so for
that i have prepared a separate demo
again i've created a class called pre
post demo and it has a public static
void main method i'm declaring an
integer variable i with the value as 3
so the i becomes 3 here and then i'm
saying i plus plus as we have already
seen in the unary demo example this
should increment the value of 3 to 4
so it will print 4 expected right then
at line number 9 i am putting this plus
plus in front of i
now what will happen now it is going to
increment the value of i
and then basically assigning the value
of i so the whole difference between i
plus plus and plus plus i is that
in this case
the value of i is assigned first and
increment later
in this case
the value of i is incremented first and
assigned later so here the value from 4
becomes 5
so at line 11 if you see if we print i
it will print 5 because we have we are
saying that first increment the value
and then update the value of i so
increment happens on i equal to 4 and i
becomes 5
at line number 13 it it becomes more
interesting because here inside the
system.out.println statement itself i'm
saying plus plus i now what will happen
like i explained first the value will be
incremented and then the value will be
assigned so before printing the value is
getting incremented so the value from 5
becomes 6 here at line 13 but if i try
to do this
now i am saying
first assign the value of i
and then increment it so i at this line
is still 6
because i has already been assigned 6
and as the post increment says
if you put this plus plus after the
variable it means that you are first
assigning the value and then
incrementing the value so
anything which happens after line 15
the value of i will become 7 but at line
15 the value of i is still 6 because we
are using a post increment operator so
the value is still assigned to i as is
and then incremented and when we do
system.out.println
the assigned value is printed not the
incremented value so like i said after
line 15 the value of i will become
incremented by 1 and it will become 7.
so hope you understood this example or
and the difference between the
pre-increment and post increment
remember the thumb rule that if we put
plus plus before a variable like at line
number 9 the value will be incremented
first and then assigned so at line 13
the updated value will be printed
because the first we are doing the
increment and then we are printing the
value for assigning the value similarly
at line 15 we are first printing the
value and then incrementing the value so
when the value is printed at line 15 the
old value of i will be printed but after
line 15 the new value of i will be
accessible to the program so let's right
click on this and run this program
and now if we see the values we assigned
i to 3 we did a post increment here so i
becomes 4 we print the value of i so
here the value of i is 4 we see 4 here
then at line line
9 we are saying plus plus i
so 4 plus 1 becomes 5 though this is a
pre-increment but since we are not
printing this plus plus i as is
it does not have any any change so the
value of 4 becomes 5 at line 11 we print
5 then at line 13 we are saying plus
plus i which means increment the value
of i first and then assign it so the
value of 5 becomes 6 and then i gets
updated and printed similarly at line 15
first the value of i is assigned and
printed and then incremented so at line
15 the value is still 6
you see this 6 here and then the value
is incremented so after line 15 the
value becomes 7 so that's how we are
basically using the unary operators and
this is where i would like to end this
particular session let's get started
with equality and relational operators
when we talk about relational operators
they are sometimes also called
comparison operators and the basic idea
behind using these operators is to
compare things or compare the values of
variables or compare the objects in java
so in java if you need to compare
anything for example if you want to
compare if something is less than the
other thing or something is greater than
the other thing or something is equal to
the other thing then you need to use the
comparison operators which are provided
by java here you can see i have opened
the official java docs and you can see a
bunch of comparison or relational
operators both of the terms are used
interchangeably some people call them
comparison operators and some people
call them relational operators
so you can see if i want to compare if
an object or a value is equal to another
value then i use the double equal sign
if i want to compare for non-equality i
will use exclamation with an equal to
which means not equal to if i want to do
a greater than comparison then i will
use the mathematics greater than symbol
if i want to do the greater than equal
to or less than or less than equal to
they again follow the same kind of
terminology as we see in mathematics so
this is all we have in terms of the
relational operators so let's understand
the usage of these operators with the
help of some examples so as you can see
i have created a class here which is
called comparison operator there is a
public static void main method inside
this class and this method has two
variables of integer type called value
one and value two value one has the
value one and value two has the value
two and then i am trying to compare the
value one and value two variables using
the different relational operators we
just covered for doing that i need to
use a conditional operator as well we
will be covering conditional operators
in much much detail in the upcoming
lectures but for now you can understand
that when we talk about conditional
operators we talk about if an else
statement so if is again a keyword in
java which can be used to compare things
and the syntax is very straightforward
you write the if keyword and then you
write the actual comparison syntax or
the actual comparison expression so in
the first example we can see that i am
writing a condition which says evaluate
if value 1 is equal to value 2. i should
put a curly braces around here you can
see there are no curly braces here but
that is for a case when you have only
one statement under it but again i will
cover this in detail and i don't want to
confuse the audience here so i will just
put curly braces around all of these if
statements so that it becomes easy to
interpret what is actually going on in
these code blocks as we know that these
curly braces are used to define a code
block so the first if block says compare
if the value 1 is equal to the value 2.
if yes then this condition will become 2
and the control of the program will go
at line number 10. if this condition is
not true then the control will not go
inside 10 because this condition is
false so it will never go to line 10 and
it will move to line 11 or 12 instead
similarly the next condition is we are
comparing the value 1 is not equal to
value 2. so this condition will only be
true if these two values are not equal
or unequal and if that is the case then
line 14 will execute it otherwise line
14 will not be executed similarly in
this condition i'm saying compare if
value 1 is greater than value 2 or not
so if the actual value holded by value 1
variable is greater than the value 2
variable then this condition will become
true and the line 18 will be executed
otherwise it will be skipped then
similarly at line 20 i am doing the
reverse i'm comparing if value 1 is less
than equal less than value 2. if that is
the case then line 22 will be executed
otherwise it will be skipped and at last
i'm also showcasing an example of less
than equal to operator that you put less
than and equal to together and again you
compare the two variables similarly you
can also use greater than equal to
variable comparison operator as well in
this example so we have an example of
equality not equal to greater than
less than and less than equal to let's
run this example to understand so for
running the example i will just right
click here go to run as and click on
java application and we can see the
output here so as the value 1 holds the
value 1 and value 2 variable holds the
value 2 obviously 1 is not equal to 2 so
the first condition is not going to be
evaluated to true so line 10 will never
be executed because 1 is not equal to 2.
similarly if i talk about the next
condition which was if value 1 is not
equal to value 2 then execute statement
14 and yes 1 is not equal to 2 that's
why we see this particular
system.out.println here you see this
printed moving on is value 1 greater
than value 2 so is 1 greater than 2 no
it's not so line 18 will never be
executed then the next one is is value 1
less than value 2 so yes 1 is less than
2 so line 22 will be executed and we see
the line 22 output here system dot out
dot printer and output moving on is 1
less than equal to 2 yes 1 is less than
equal to 2 so this particular condition
is also true and line 26 will be
executed and that's why we see this here
and that's all so we can see that we are
able to use these comparison or
relational operators to evaluate
different conditions and we write those
conditions using the if block and again
if you do not understand the if block
fully don't worry we will be covering
the if blocks in detail but the focus
here is in using the operators the not
equal to operators the greater than
equal to operators less than equal to
operators etc so i hope these operators
give you a better understanding of how
to use them now moving on to the next
section of this uh comparison operators
sometimes we also use some logical terms
to do the comparison for example if i
just move down here and i show you these
conditions here we call them conditional
operators conditional operators are used
to evaluate the conditions like and or
or and we use them in two two ways
either we can use it as ampersand or
double ampersand or we can use them as
pipe or double pipes so the idea is
basically to evaluate if one condition
is true and other condition is also true
or one condition is true or other
condition is true so whenever you want
to combine two conditions together
that's where you're going to use these
logical operators or conditional
operators you can also use the simple
english keywords like and or or or you
can use the logical representation of
these keywords for example ampersand
ampersand or double ampersand is
equivalent to and similarly double pipe
is equivalent to or so we can use these
as well interchangeably you can use
either of these
operator representations to run a
conditional check in composition meaning
you can compare two conditions saying
okay if one is true and second is true
or one is true or second is true so the
whole focus is here in and and or
comparisons so let's switch back to the
ide and let's look at an example of this
to understand this in detail so i will
again take the similar kind of example
again i have created two variables here
value one and value two value one has
value as one and second variable value
two has value as two and then i am
writing two conditions this time in the
same if block you can see i am writing
first condition saying is value 1 equal
to equal to 1 and is value 2 also equal
to equal to 2 so this whole if condition
is only going to be true only if both of
the conditions are true that's the
property of and and will force that both
the conditions on the left hand side of
it and the right hand side of it hold
true and then only the whole expression
is going to hold true even if one of the
conditions evaluate to false the whole
if expression will evaluate to false
similarly for or conditions we again
write a left hand condition and a right
hand condition and in between we write
this double pipe we can also write or or
in english that will also have the same
effect and this will evaluate in a way
that this whole expression this whole
expression will evaluate to true if even
a single condition either on left side
or right side of it becomes true so r
will just need one expression to be true
to make the whole if condition true
whereas and will force both of the
conditions to be true to make the whole
expression as true so and will require
two truths to actually become true but
our condition will require only one true
to become true so if we try to do
understand this logic here i am saying
that if value 1 is equal to equal to 1
which is correct and value 2 is equal to
equal to 2 then make this condition as
true so yes in this case this condition
will evaluate to true because value 1
has value 1 1 and value 2 has value as 2
so it will print the line 10 whereas in
the next condition i am saying evaluate
if value 1 is equal to equal to 1 or
value 2 is equal to equal to 1 so either
of the expression if becomes true
either the left side this expression or
the right side this expression either of
the expression becomes true this whole
condition will become true and line 14
will be executed line 14 will not be
executed only in a case when both of the
conditions here become false for example
if i write it like this then we know
that value 1 is not equal to 4 because
it's 1 and value 2 is not equal to 5
because it's true in that case both of
the expression will become false and
then line 14 will not be executed if i
write it like this then the left hand
expression is evaluated to true because
value 1 is 1 but the right hand
expression is false but it's fine the
line 14 will still be executed because
either of these side is true so the
whole expression becomes true similarly
here and will require both of the
expressions to be true and if either of
them becomes false the whole expression
becomes false so in the current state
line 10 will be executed but if i change
this to this then the left hand side of
this ampersand will evaluate to false
and the whole expression will evaluate
to false in that case and line 10 will
never be executed let's try to run all
of these scenarios to make a better
understanding of this so in this case
both of the conditions should work fine
so i will just right click and run as
java application and yes we see this
line 10 being printed and we also see
this line 13 being printed so both of
the lines are printed correctly both of
the conditions are evaluating to true
now let's try to play around with it let
me change this value to 4 so now value 1
this left hand side expression is false
which should make the whole expression
as false and it should not print the
line 10 which is this statement so let's
run this program and see if that works
yes we see that this particular line is
not printed now because this whole
expression became false because the left
hand side of this expression became
false similarly in the r case either of
them have to have to be true you can see
currently value 2 equal to equal to 5
condition will actually result in a
false condition because this is not a
true value 2 is actually 2 not 5 and
still we see this particular expression
because either of them have to be true
if i make both of them as not true now
both of the conditions on the left hand
side of pipe and right hand side of pipe
are false conditions what will happen
now nothing will be printed the reason
for that is that value 1 is also that
this condition is also false and value 2
condition is also false so the whole
expression become false and this was
already false let's get started with
bitwise operators now bitwise operators
are very less commonly used in the java
programming world generally we don't use
them and generally we don't need to use
them you would generally use them when
you are doing really complex bitwise
calculation where you need to manipulate
the bits now what are actually bits so
if you remember when we talked about the
integer type variables we talked about
how much memory each of the variable
type or data type was going to consume
we said that this will take one byte and
this will take two bytes etc one byte is
basically made up of eight bits and bits
are nothing but positions where either a
zero is stored or one is stored actually
the whole machine will convert your
whole program ultimately in zeros and
ones which are nothing but bits so if
you want to do the manipulation at that
level so now you can understand you are
you are actually working at right at the
machine level understanding so if you
want to manipulate the bits which are
going to be understood by the machine at
that level then you can use bitwise
operators but like i said generally we
don't need to use them now when we talk
about bitwise operators there are
multiple ways in which we can use them
we can use them with the standard and or
or operations if you remember we covered
this and or or operations in the
previous lecture you see a difference
here that in case of and we are using a
single ampersand or and not double
ampersand this is one of the concept
which we did not covered in the previous
lecture and i would just like to brief
you about this concept that if you use
double ampersand that is also called a
short circuit operator and if you use a
single ampersand that is called a
standard operator to build an
understanding about this i will just
quickly recap of what we covered in the
last lecture and we'll try to explain
these concepts as well so let's go to
the logical operator demo and here if
you remember there were two ampersands
and two pipes
this is also a valid expression a single
ampersand is also a valid expression the
only change is
in this case
even if the left hand condition
evaluates to false
still the right hand condition will be
evaluated although we know that in case
of and either of the expression needs to
be false and the whole expression
becomes false so java provides an
advantage or with that if you use double
ampersand and if the left hand operation
becomes false
then it will not cover the right hand
operation it will not even evaluate the
right hand operation because it doesn't
matter if the left hand operation has
already returned to false or evaluated
to false then no matter whether right
side is true or false the whole
expression is still going to be false
right that's the property of and
one of these side has to be false and
the whole expression becomes false so
why why evaluate two sides y weighs the
memory in evaluating the right side when
the left side has already turned as
false java takes advantage of that and
that's why if you use double ampersand
you save a bit of processing power of
your computer
by just evaluating the left-hand
condition
and if the left-hand condition is false
it will skip evaluating the right-hand
condition and just make the whole
expression false but if you use this
a single ampersand then both side of the
expression will be evaluated
irrespective of their output so in this
case
even if the left hand expression is
false it is still going to evaluate the
right side expression and similarly it
works for the or case as well in this
case in our case as we know if one of
the condition is true the whole
condition becomes true the whole
expression becomes true so if the left
hand side becomes true and if you use a
single pipe then it will still evaluate
the right height side but if you use
double pipe like this then if the left
hand side becomes true then it knows
that it does not matter if the right
hand side becomes true or false because
ultimately the whole expression is going
to be true if either of the side is true
so if the left hand side is already true
it will not evaluate the right hand side
and it will say the whole expression is
true that's why you see the single
ampersand being used for bitwise just to
explain why it why it is used and how it
is used for or operations in bitwise you
use this cap or whatever you want to
call it as and for uh the inclusive
bitwise or
or operation you're going to use a
single pipe you also use some shift
operations where you shift the value of
bit of a particular variable to either
left or right again these are again very
complex calculations if you want to use
that please read about this and use that
but in the in today's demo what we are
going to cover is the and and or
examples of bitwise operations
so here i have again created a class
called bitwise operator i have a public
static void main method i have two
variables here which are int a equal to
5 and into b equal to 7. now these 5 and
are actually stored as bits
as zeros and ones in the computer's
memory so how they are actually stored
they are stored in a standard bit
representation which you may have
studied in your mathematics
if to give you a recap this 5 will
basically be written in a memory as this
0 1 0 1 and it starts from here 2 raised
to power 0 into 1 becomes 1 2 raised to
the power 1 into 0 becomes 0 2 raised to
power 2
into 1 becomes 4 and 2 raised to power 3
into 0 becomes 0. so 4 0 plus 4 plus 0
plus 1 becomes 5 and that's how 5 is
displayed to you similarly for 7 2
raised to power 0 into 1 is 1 plus 2
raised to power 1 into 1 is 2 so 1 plus
2 3 plus 2 raised to power 2
into 1 which is 4 so 1 plus
2 plus 4 7 and 2 raised to power 3 into
0 is 0. so 0 plus 4 plus 2 plus 1 which
is 7 and that's how this 7 is built and
stored and now if you try to do this if
you try to write this condition you can
also write the condition into a
system.out.println block and it will
basically evaluate this condition so now
if you say a and b
in this case this is going to do a
bitwise operation because this is
bitwise operand it is going to do a
bitwise operation and what would be the
result if you do an and on this so again
use the same logic as if in case of and
if 1 is false then the whole expression
is false
so 0 and 0 becomes 0
and 1 becomes 1
0 and 1 becomes 0 because 0 means false
and 1 means true so if either of them is
false the whole evaluation becomes false
so that's why 0 or and 1 becomes 0 and 1
and 1 is always 1. the value of this is
again 5 as we already have evaluated
similarly if you do a bitwise or and if
you do this again we are doing an or
operation so 0 or 0 or basically false
or false becomes false
true or
true becomes true false or true should
be true because one of them needs to be
true so this is false but this is true
so the whole value becomes true and the
finally true or true is also true so
this is the final bitwise or result and
if we convert this into an integer
representation that becomes 7 because 2
raised to power 0 into 1 is 1 2 raised
to power 1 into 1 is 2 so 2 plus 1 3
plus 2 raised to the power 2 into 1
which is 4 so 4 plus 2 plus 1 which is 7
and plus 2 raised to power 3 into 0
which is 0. so 0 plus 4 plus 2 plus 1
becomes 7 and that's how you get
actually 7 so let's see if we get 5 or 7
in this bit wise operation yes we can
see the values as 5 and 7. so this is a
bitwise operation happening similarly
you can also use the shift operations
where in case if you're using the this
particular kind of representation or
this particular kind of representation
they are called which they are called
left shift and right shift operations so
if you use this in front of a variable
then for example this one will be
shifted here and this zero will be
shifted here and this one will be
shifted here so that's how the whole
value is going to shift all bits are
going to shift one by one towards left
similarly if you are using the right
shift then all the bits are going to be
shifted towards right by one bit that's
the whole concept of left shift and
right shift bitwise operations and if
you want to know more about this please
read some official examples from the
java doc and some other examples
available on the internet to build an
understanding on this
so this is all i wanted to cover in this
lecture let's get started with how to
use do while loops so let's understand
when do we need that and how do you
actually use that let me switch to the
java documentation and if i can find
some syntax of it as well yep so as you
can see here if i just highlight this
portion this is how you actually write a
do while statement block so you write do
you start a code block you write some
executable statements and then after
the code block ends you write a while
expression and end it with semicolon
this is the syntax basically it starts
with do or curly braces some executable
statements a while block or a while
statement basically with an expression
ending with a semicolon let's understand
this with the help of a program to
understand the structure better so for
this i have created a sample program
here which is called do while demo again
having a public static void main method
and it has a variable
which is count and it is initialized as
one then i write do i write this code
block or the curly braces and then i am
just printing the value of count then i
am incrementing the value of count and
then i am writing a condition which says
while count is less than 10 and
semicolon if you compare this with the
previous demo we ran if i just put them
side by side we had while condition
statement
and
the state change condition here we have
do statement condition change statement
and then we check the condition at the
end so the idea is that if you have a
use case
where before you even evaluate the
condition you want to print something
even before you evaluate the condition
if you want to do something in that case
you will use the do while loop even
before the while actual while loop
starts if you want to execute a
statement you will use do while loop for
example if you want to print the initial
value of the count even before the
condition checks then you can use do
while loop if that is not your use case
you can use a simple while loop which is
just described here in this program so
coming back to the do while so i say do
and then i'm saying print this
particular statement without checking
anything this condition will be executed
for the first time without any condition
check at all this will just work as is
like a normal java statement after that
i am incrementing the value of the count
and then i am checking the condition so
remember when this particular condition
is being checked the first increment has
already happened but in the while case
we did the comparison before even the
first increment the first comparison
happened with the original value of
count but here the first comparison is
happening with the incremented value of
the count hope you get the difference in
a better context now that you will use
this when you want to do some write some
initialization code before you actually
hit the condition so this condition will
be evaluated with 2 less than 10 and
then the value will be printed let's
print this example and we'll also try to
play around with this example a bit more
to bring to build our understanding
better if i run this program there is no
difference in output if you compare this
with the previous program we ran for the
while so it prints the count value so
this is coming here then it increments
the value then it checks the condition
saying is 2 less than 10 yes that holds
true if that holds true it will go back
to statement number 9 again print this
again do an increment on the count and
again check the condition with the
updated value of the count which will
say 3 less than 10 now similarly print
the value increment check this will
continue to happen till this particular
condition becomes false and once this
condition is false it will exit out of
this whole do while loop and it will go
to the line number 12 and if you have
any statement written there you can that
statement will be executed in this case
so let's try to change some values here
and let's see if if we can make sense of
this program if we change the value
let's say if i put 11 here what will
happen now let's run this program you
will see the now you will see that this
particular output is displayed which
says count is 11. so what happened here
that count was 11 it entered the do
while block it went to this particular
statement which said count is 11 then it
incremented the value so the value
became 12 and obviously 12 is not less
than 10 so it did not print it again it
only printed once even if the first time
the condition was checked the first
condition execution itself resulted in
false
still line number 9 got successfully
printed and that's the whole that's the
whole idea behind using the do while
what if i change this value to 10 let's
see what happens and after that we'll
run one more combination to just make it
more interesting this time again count
is 10 line number 10 will be printed as
count is 10 then at line number 10 the
count is incremented to 11 and 11 is not
less than 10 so in this case the loop
ends and it will move out now what
happens if i do this
if i say less than equal to here let's
run this program and interpret the
output now again only one statement is
printed because in this case the count
is 10 10 is printed here and we are
saying 10 plus 1 11 11 is still not less
than equal to 10 and that's why the loop
just exits let's make it 9 and see what
happens now you see two values so count
is 9 it enters the do while loop goes to
statement number 9 prints the current
value of count which is 9 then
increments the value to 10
then at line number 11 this while
statement is executed and the condition
is checked is 10 less than equal to 10
yes 10 is not less than but 10 is equal
to 10 so this condition will hold true
it will go back here print count is 10
make count 11
again check the condition is 11 less
than equal to 10 no it's not and then
the condition will return to false and
loop will be exited so hope this will
give you a better understanding now
since we ran different permutations and
combinations of the values and we saw
when this will be executed and when this
will not be executed but the bottom line
is very straightforward that whenever
you want to write some pre-processing
logic even before checking the very
first condition of your loop then in
that case you will be using a do while
loop otherwise a normal while loop or a
for loop will absolutely work fine so
that's the takeaway i would like you to
take away from this particular session
let's get started with understanding the
loop statements in java so first of all
understand why do we need loop
statements so generally whenever you are
dealing with some data structures in
java which can store multiple elements
for example we saw array which can store
multiple elements string is also
basically technically a character array
which is storing multiple characters so
whenever you have these kind of data
structures where you have multiple
elements being stored in the same
then in that case you would like to have
a way to iterate or access all of the
elements in a seamless fashion one of
the ways is to access them individually
one by one but that's too much of work
that's too much of code there has to be
a simpler way of accessing all the
elements one by one if i want to and
that's where the majority of the use
cases for using loops coming to picture
now java provides multiple constructs to
write loops in java there is a while
loop there is a do while loop there is a
for loop there is also an enhanced for
loop and in the previous versions of
java a use case of iterator was also
very popular so there are multiple ways
in which you can actually iterate over a
collection and access all the elements
of the collection one by one and you can
use it to multiple useful cases for
example if you have a huge i of employee
salary and you want to give bonus to
each of the employees and add the bonus
to the salary then you need to do this
edition for all the employees it would
be nice to have to return a while loop
and the while loop can automatically
access all the employee salary one by
one and keep adding the bonus to the
salary this would be an easier way to do
this rather than individually updating
each employee salary and the first loop
statement we are going to understand is
a while loop so the syntax of while loop
is very straightforward you write the y
keyword you enter the actual condition
which will be evaluating to a boolean
true or false so you write the
expression which will be a boolean
expression exactly similar to the
conditions which you use to write in
your if statements so you write your
condition which will evaluate to either
true or false and then you write your
statement and these statements will keep
executing till the time this particular
expression evaluates to true so
generally the way it works is that it
will enter the while block it will
evaluate the expression if the
expression becomes true then the
statements inside this particular while
block will be executed and after the
execution of the statement it will again
go back again evaluate the expression we
call them steps basically so it will go
to the next step again evaluate the
expression if this again if this still
holds true it will again go inside
execute the statement move on to the
next step it will again go to the
evaluation so this this loop will
continue to go till the time this
condition will hold true if it still
doesn't make sense for you don't worry
we will have a demo of it to make you
understand how to use the while loops
and maybe it's a good idea to switch to
the ide and look at an example of it so
i have already created while demo for it
here it is it looks very small and
simple but it will get to the point
where we can understand how and why will
we will be using the while loops so i've
created a while demo class i've added a
public static void main method here
which is the entry point i have declared
a variable which is int count equal to 1
so the count value is 1 right now and
then i'm writing a condition here i'm
saying while count is less than 10 do
this
so it will print the current value of
count and after that i'm using the post
increment unary operator if you remember
we covered this in the previous sessions
what is the meaning of this it basically
will increment the value of count by one
this expression is is equivalent to if i
write it in this way if i write count
equal to count plus 1 this is exactly
the same as this no difference so this
will have the same impact i will just
remove this line because we already have
the count plus plus here so if we try to
understand this we are basically
incrementing the count and then checking
the condition again so at first time it
will be 1 less than 10 yes that is true
it will go inside and print the count
value the current count value which will
be 1 and then it does count plus plus so
now the count value becomes two it will
again go back here again check the
condition saying is 2 less than 10 yes
that is true so the while condition
again becomes true it will again go
inside this print the current value of
count which is 2 then do count plus plus
so it will again increment the value of
count so the now the count value becomes
3 again go back here at condition and
saying is 3 less than 10 yes that is
still true again come here print the 3
again go here make count as four four
less than ten prints four again count
plus plus count becomes five and so on
so forth it will keep doing that till
the value becomes ten so at a step when
count plus plus results in the account
value being updated to 10 it will go
here and say is 10 less than 10 now that
is not true because 10 is equal to 10
but 10 is not less than 10 so this
condition will become false and it will
exit of this while loop and it will come
here and it will execute if there's if
there was anything written after the
while loop that will be executed so
that's the idea that you want to do
something till a particular condition
holds true then you can use the while
loop define your condition and execute
the statements and try to do something
which changes the state of this
condition here i am changing the count
so that every time a new evaluation
happens if i comment this this will
result in an infinite loop because 1
will always be less than 10 i will not
be incrementing the count here and it
will keep running forever it will never
stop it will just keep printing 1 1 1
every time till your computer program
runs out of the memory so always
remember not to end up into an infinite
loop that's probably one of the biggest
mistakes any beginner programmer does so
please try to be aware of that
particular
loophole not try to run an infinite loop
always try to write something in the
code block which can change the state of
the condition and also make sure that
that state condition sometimes sometime
should become false you should also make
sure that that all that always becomes
false because if i do this if i do this
then this condition will always remain
true because it is already 1 then it
will become 0 then it will become minus
1 minus 2 minus 3 so and so forth but
that value of count will forever be less
than 10 and again you will never be able
to exit this loop your program will be
stuck in this loop till your program
runs out of the memory so always
remember to write a statement or a
statement of execution in your in your
code block which can change the state of
the condition which results in some
eventual time when this condition
becomes false this condition has to
become false eventually otherwise you
will never come out of the loop always
remember that so if we run this program
now let's observe the output so we can
see here this particular statement is
printed for 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 and that's
it after 9 the moment the count plus
plus resulted into the count value
becoming 10 it checked that condition
and then it just came out of the loop
because 10 is not less than 10 and the
condition became false so always do
something inside your code block which
results at least of one scenario where
this condition becomes false and that is
how you can use the while loop now you
can see this is a pretty generic code
and you can write any kind of condition
here write any code you want to execute
here and then do something to change the
state of the condition as well in a
positive way in a way which results this
particular condition to be false at some
point of time and then your while loop
will run fine so this is all i wanted to
cover in terms of the while loop we have
lot of more exciting stuff coming in in
terms of different loops let's get
started with for loops in java so so far
we covered about while loops and
do-while loops and we also saw different
examples of using different types of
data structures like arrays but one of
the core requirements whenever you are
working with any kind of collection is
to iterate over it exactly similar to
what i explained in the do while and why
lectures that you would often require to
iterate over a collection or a data
structure and for that one of the most
sophisticated and easiest way to do that
is using for loops so let's understand
the syntax of for loop first and then we
will also look at an example of it in
the in the eclipse ide
so i have just opened the official java
docs here so if you see this is
basically the syntax of a for loop
statement so let's understand it and
let's also try to compare it with a
while loop so that we can understand how
it compares with the while loop so if we
see the syntax we first see the term
initialization
then we see the term termination and
then we see the term called increment
now if i try to compare it with a while
loop there also you basically did these
three things you first initialized a
variable outside the while loop which is
called initialization and then you wrote
a condition
which is your termination condition you
wrote a condition saying let's say while
i is greater than 10 or while i is less
than 10. so that is the condition which
is also the termination statement the
loop will continue to execute till that
condition
evaluates to false and that's when the
loop terminates that's why we call it as
termination and then the third piece of
it is the increment the i plus plus
which we used to do in the while loops
so these three portions together
make or constitute any kind of loop in
any kind of programming language and for
loop if you see the the kind of code
which you use to write in a while loop
in multiple lines where you first
initialize a variable then you write a
condition in the while block and then
inside the while block you use to
increment the variable all of that can
be done in a single line in the for loop
and that's why i said it is the most
sophisticated and easiest way to write
loops in java so you write all of these
three things the initialization the
condition and the increment or decrement
values in a single line and then you
start with the curly braces and you
write the code which you want to keep
executing till the condition evaluates
to false that's the basic syntax of it
so let us try to understand this with
the help of an example so here i have
opened a class which is called for demo
and this is a class which will
demonstrate the usage of a for loop so
again we have a public static void main
method which you can see here which is
the entry point and then i use the
keyword for i put standard
braces for the brackets
and then i do the initialization so this
part is the initialization part you
initialize the variable so i just say in
i equal to 1 initialization done you end
it with a semicolon so that it is a
single statement understood by java and
then you write this condition which is
your evaluation slash termination
condition
so this condition is basically the the
deciding factor of how long your loops
should run it's exactly similar to what
you used to write in the while block if
i just show you the example this is what
we used to do so we did the
initialization at line number seven then
we wrote this termination condition
inside the while uh syntax or the
construct and then we did the increment
here so we are doing all of these three
steps but we are doing it in a single
line so this is the condition and then
we write our increment or decrement
values which are going to change the
evaluation condition every time at every
step so we are saying i plus plus so
technically what i am saying here is
that
start with i equal to 1 and
then check the condition i less than 10
so in the in the first step it will be
checking if 1 is less than 10 if the
condition holds true go inside the for
loop execute the statement at line
number 7 and then go back to this
particular statement so we do y plus
plus so i becomes 2 and then you again
go back to the condition and again you
check if 2 is less than 10 yes it is so
again you go inside inside the for loop
and do whatever is written there there
can be multiple statements here for now
i have just written one
system.out.println
so that happens and once all the
execution is finished inside the block
it will again go back to the increment
does the increment so two plus one
becomes three again does the evaluation
exec and if the if the condition holds
true it will again go inside so this
will continue this condition checking
execution and increment will continue
till the time this condition holds true
the moment this condition becomes false
the control will come out at line number
nine so that's the basic anatomy and
control flow it's very important to
understand the control flow of a for
loop otherwise you might end up into a
program which is forever running and
which will just eat up all the memory
available in your jvm so be very sure of
what you write in your for loop be very
sure of specially these two parts the
condition and the increment or decrement
so this is very important piece the
initialization happens only once and
then this condition evaluates if the
condition holds to true some code
executes goes back to the changing
statement which can be an increment
decrement whatever and again compares
the updated value with the condition so
this will keep happening
let's run this code to interpret the
output
so i will right click go to run as java
application
and if i
interpret the output here i can see that
it started with count is 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
and 9. it stopped at 9. so what happened
there let's try to evaluate the
termination condition so let's say i has
become 9 and 9 is less than 10 so it
goes inside and it prints count is 9
which is i then it goes here and it says
9 plus 1 i plus plus means 9 plus 1 the
current value of i plus 1 it becomes 10
and then it again compares the condition
so now 10 is not less than 10 10 is
equal to 10 but it is not less than 10
so the condition becomes false and count
is 10 is never printed because this
condition has become false it will jump
out so let's say if i do this
if i put an equal to here and if i now
execute the same program
this time i will see 10 here and because
i have said that okay check the
condition if 10 is less than equal to 10
that will become true it will print
count is 10 then it will increment and
the count will become 11 the i will
become 11 and then it will check 11 is
less than equal to 10 no it is not so
condition becomes false and the control
comes out of the loop so that's how you
should always try to interpret the loops
you can also run some infinite loops for
example if i say i equal to 1 i leave it
that and i say i minus minus so what
happens i equal to 1 1 is less than 10
yes it goes here prints the value and
then i decrement the value i don't
increment the value i decrement the
value so whatever value comes out will
always be less than 10 and this loop
will run forever for fun let's try to
run this and i will i will have to kill
this program manually but just to show
you what happens and what you should not
do in your java program so you see it
will continuously keep printing the
values till the program runs out of
memory till it eats up all the available
memory it is cut it is forever running
it will never stop because the condition
will never remain never never evaluate
to false this condition will forever be
true so the loop will run forever so i'm
just going to kill the program but this
is something which you should avoid
whenever you are writing java code and
this happens quite often with beginner
programmers
so this is all i wanted to cover in
today's session we talked in detail
about the for loop let's get started
with enhanced for loops in java so we
covered about the for loops and the
structure of it and the control flow of
it in the previous session and today we
are just going to talk about another way
of writing for loops which is a bit even
more smarter than the traditional for
loops which we call as enhanced for
loops we generally use the enhanced for
loops for scenarios whenever we have to
iterate over a collection of items or an
array of items those are the most
popular and common use cases of using
enhanced for loop and this for loop is
even simpler like i said it's even
simpler than writing a classic for loop
and the syntax is
simply like this you again start with
four put the standard brackets and then
let's start from the right most because
then that we i will be able to explain
it better you specify the collection in
the right most side of the bracket the
collection can be an array it can be a
list can be a map so whatever different
kind of collections which are available
in java and we are going to cover
collections in detail so don't worry if
you don't understand what our lists and
what are maps and what are sets we will
go into detail of each of these one by
one in the upcoming sessions but the
idea is that you put the collection to
the right most then you put a colon and
then you put a representation of the
member of this collection so for example
here this numbers is basically an int
array so this int array means that this
array can only hold integer numbers and
that's why we write int here because
this array is only having integers then
we put any placeholder variable name
this can be anything you can even write
it as i if you want to you can write it
as anything any variable name which you
want to write this is a temporary
variable so now this code is going to
execute in a manner that it is going to
iterate over this array one by one
starting from the first element going
till the last element you don't need to
write any initialization code you don't
need to write any termination condition
code and you don't need to write any
increment or decrement code also and how
these threes how these three values are
actually taken care of let's understand
that as well so when we talk about the
initialization as i have put an array
here a data structure here the automatic
initialization index is going to be the
first index so when we do the iteration
when this for loop is going to execute
it is automatically going to initialize
a temporary variable with the value at
the first index which is the index 0 as
you know that array is a 0 index based
structure then comes the condition part
so the condition evaluation is going to
be again based on the size of the array
or the size of the data structure which
you are using it is going to start from
the first index which is the index 0
and it is going to iterate till the
array's last element is reached so
technically start from the index 0 and
go till the last element that's your
evaluation condition and then comes the
increment part so at each step after it
has
successfully accessed the first element
automatically the index is going to be
updated to pointing to the next element
so if it starts from here once the first
step iteration is complete
i is automatically going to be
incremented to index 1 and then it will
basically this i will be holding 2 then
in the next iteration the same i is
going to be holding three similarly i
will keep holding the new value of the
collection item one by one till the
collection items last element is reached
so this is the basic premise that you
can write a collection variable here and
keep iterating over it and this whatever
variable you write here will hold the
current item's value one by one so in
the first step this i is going to hold
one in the second step this is going to
hold two in the third step this i is
going to hold three and so on so forth
that's the basic idea so now let's run
this program to see what kind of output
do we get so you can see we
basically are able to print all the
elements of the array and that's
probably one of the most popular usage
as well that if you want to just print
all the elements or access all the
elements of
array or a collection one by one then
just use enhanced for loop so you can
see at each step it is printing the
value of i and the value of i is
basically the subsequent elements of the
array that's the whole idea with
enhanced for loop under the hoods if you
talk about how does it work under the
hood it is actually using the classic
for loop construct itself but for
developers it is making it easier
because it knows that if you are
iterating over a collection you will
start with the first element and you
will go till the last element so it
knows the initialization value the
termination condition and it also knows
the increment condition and that's the
reason you will use enhanced for loops
in java for iterating over collections
let's get started with nested for loops
in java so we talked about the while
loops the do-while loops the classic for
loop also the enhanced for loop so now
we are going to look at a variation of
the classic for loops in a in a
condition where we have to use more than
one loop in a nested fashion and how do
we do that what are the use cases when
we use that so in front of you you can
see an example which i have prepared for
nested for loops and in this particular
example i have created a two dimensional
array as you can see on the line number
six i have created an integer array and
i have put two square brackets here
which are basically symbolizing that
this is a two dimensional array so this
two dimensional array is going to hold
technically a 2d matrix and we are going
to use the concept of nested for loops
to print this 2d array in a 2d matrix
style where you will be able to see the
rows and columns clearly let's first try
to
interpret this particular 2d array so we
have a curly braces outside and then we
have these three inner elements which
symbolizes three rows basically so this
is the first row this is the second row
and this is the third row and then each
of the rows have three elements each
which symbolizes the column values or
the item values so it's basically a 3
into 3 2d array which has 3 rows and 3
columns so so we can say that this is
basically a 3 into 3 array which has
three dimensions on the row side and
three dimensions on the column side or
just a three by three matrix or three by
three 2d array so as we know that in
case of arrays everything starts from
zero so technically if we talk about the
indexes it would be the index 0 index 1
and index 2 on the row side and
similarly index 0 index 1 and index 2 on
the column side so that's that's
something which you should remember
because we are going to use this
particular concept when we write the for
loop so let's try to write the for loop
now if you look at line number eight we
put this keyword called for
and then we write the initialization so
we say int i equal to 0 then we are
writing the termination condition and we
are saying
run this particular loop run this whole
loop which ends at line 13 till i is
less than 3 and keep incrementing i at
every step that's what i'm doing in the
line number eight then inside the for
loop i'm writing another for loop which
has another different variable called j
it can be anything you can name it
anything you want and this also starts
with 0 and this also has a similar
condition which is which says run this
particular loop the line 10 basically or
this loop which is signified by this
curly braces run this particular loop
till the time the value of j
is less than 3 and keep incrementing j
at every step and at line number 10
print the element of array which has the
current value of i and the current value
of j these are basically the positions
these are not the elements the element
would be represented by this hole but
print the element which is at current i
and j's position values that's what this
code means so let's try to do a dry run
on this particular code to understand
how this is going to work so at first we
have i equal to 0 0 is less than 3 and
it goes inside it initializes j as well
with zero and j is zero is also less
than three so this condition went true
that's why we went to line number nine
and line number nine condition also went
to true so we went to line number ten
remember that
in this particular case at line number
10 the values of i and j are 0 and 0
respectively and we are saying print the
array of 0 and 0 so 0th rows 0th column
element should be printed so this is the
zeroth row because this is the first uh
first sub block and this is the first
element so in this case in line number
ten two should get printed then it goes
here and it increments the j to one so
zero plus one becomes one it again
checks the condition is one less than
three so yes one is less than three it
goes here remember it did not go up at
line number eight it just came back from
line number nine so when it comes here i
is still 0 but j has moved from 0 to 1
so now we are trying to access the
element which is at 0th row 1st column
which is going to be
7 so 7 is going to get printed similarly
on the next iteration
j is going to get incremented from 1 to
2 and again the condition will be
evaluated so 2 is less than 3 all good
it will again come back to line number
10 and now it will say print the value
of zero row third or the second column
or the third element so zeroth row third
element which is the nine so nine will
get printed then again j will be
incremented and j will become three two
plus one three and now the condition
will be evaluated is 3 less than 3 no it
is not less than 3 the condition becomes
false so it breaks out of the loop goes
to line number 12 prints an empty line
because we are not writing anything here
so it will just print a blank line and
now it will go back to line number
eight's condition and it will do an
increment of i and now i will move from
0 to 1 and now the evaluation will
happen is 1 less than 3 yes 1 is less
than 3 so it will again go to line
number 9 again initialize j with a fresh
0. the previous j got destroyed the
moment you came out of the loop so this
is a new j so this j again gets
initialized to 0 0 is less than 3 it
goes here remember i was 1 in this time
so now it will print the value of this
2d array which is sitting at
1 comma 0 basically second row first
element so second row first element
which is 3 again j is going going to get
incremented and it will become from 0 to
1 so 1 is less than 3 yes it will again
come here and it will print the value of
the array which is sitting at array of 1
comma 1 for a row equal to 1 and column
equal to 1 which will be 6. similarly j
will get incremented again again 2 is
less than 3 come back here we'll print 1
then again we'll increment j j will
become 3 3 is less than 3 no it's false
the condition is false so it jumps out
of the loop goes to line number 12
prints a blank line again goes back to 8
line number 8 increments i and i now
becomes 2 2 is less than 3 yes it will
again go here initialize j again with 0
and again does the same thing for the
row 2 and column 0 1 2 and again it will
come out of the loop this time again
when it will go here the value will
become from 2 to 3 and 3 is not less
than 3 so then it will break out of the
outer loop so the idea is execute the
inner loop for every value of the outer
loop remember this line because that is
how you will be applying your knowledge
of nested for loops to be used in
certain condition so whenever you have a
scenario where you have to iterate over
a collection based on a certain value of
another collection then you can use
nested for loops or you have a scenario
where you have to iterate over 2d or 3d
arrays for example if we were dealing
with 3d arrays then you would have seen
three nested for loops here and where it
will apply the same logic that iterate
over all the collections all the values
of the inner loop on our particular
value of the outer loop then increment
the value of the outer loop and do the
same thing again iterate over all the
values of the inner loop based on a
fixed value of the outer loop so let's
run this program and let's see what kind
of output do we get
so like i said our our motive our target
was to print this in in a metric style
and you can see that it is printing in
it in a sort of a matrix representation
so the first row gets printed here then
the second row gets printed here and
then the third row gets printed here if
you try to decipher it it will work
exactly the same way as i explained so i
equal to 0
0 less than 3 condition becomes true
comes here j equal to 0 j less than 3
condition becomes true comes here prints
the array of zero comma zero which is
two then prints the array of zero comma
one which is seven zero comma two which
is nine then j becomes three it breaks
out of the loop goes up here i becomes
from zero to one 1 is less than 3 yes
again comes here reinitializes a fresh
for loop with a new j setting to 0 and
it will it will print the array of 1 0 1
1 1 2 then similarly array of 2 0 to 1
to 2. so that's basically what we are
doing we are iterating we are picking
the first row and hydrating all elements
of it pitching the second row hydrating
all all elements over it and so on so
forth you can do this for any n
dimensional kind of array or a
collection so this is all i wanted to
cover in today's session where we
discussed about the nested for loops
concept and how and where we will use it
let's get started with access modifiers
in java so when we talk about access
modifiers let's understand what is the
underlying philosophy of the reasoning
behind this
and the reasoning is very
straightforward it can be even wrapped
into a single word which is called
security the reason is that you will be
creating multiple kinds of objects and
variables while you write your java
program and you should always write your
java program or any program in a manner
that only the intended classes packages
modules or applications should be able
to see what they are supposed to see
so as a consumer application i should
only be able to consume the variables
which i am expected to consume i should
not get any variable or i should not
even have access to any variable which i
am not supposed to access so the idea is
providing the least privileged principle
give access to different functions
different variables different programs
only by providing them the kind of
access which they need to run
efficiently and do not give them
complete access so with that notion in
mind java created the concept of access
modifiers and it created these three
modifiers which are called public
protected and private if you do not
provide any modifier then it goes to no
modifier or some people also call it as
default modifier which is also a type of
access modifier so let's understand
theoretically first how it works and
then we will try to have a look at an
example let's understand the first one
first of all these modifiers are
keywords and you can use these keywords
in front of classes in front of
variables and also in front of methods
and you might have already noticed this
particular keyword called public in
front of all the classes i've created or
even when we talked about the public
static void main method we saw this
public as a keyword it is basically an
access modifier and whenever you put
public in front of a class or a variable
or a method that particular component
becomes available to the whole of the
program it will be available to the
whole world basically any subclass or
any package or any other class which
might have been written in your java
program will be able to access that
particular class or variable or method
if you put public in front of that the
second modifier level is protected one
of the other thing which you you will
understand as i explain this is that as
you move down into this particular table
the access level will start getting more
and more restricted by restriction i
mean that less and less components will
be able to get access to those modifiers
so if you write protected in front of a
class or in front of a method or in
front of a variable then everything
within that particular class will still
be able to access it
everything within the package will still
be able to access it i still haven't
covered the concept of package but i
briefly touched upon it showing you how
whenever we write a class we have a
package in front of it and package is
technically is just an aggregation of
the classes if you have to write write
multiple classes and wrap all of those
classes into a single logical bundle
that would be called a package just to
show you an example these all are
packages which you see here you see this
square box here and you see that these
names these all are packages and these
packages contain multiple classes and
technically that's all the packages mean
that you can wrap multiple related
classes into a single package so coming
back to the access modifier whenever you
write protected in front of a class or a
variable or a method then that
particular component will be accessible
to everybody within the same class
everybody within the same package it
will also be accessible to everybody
which is a subclass of the class this is
again a new concept which i have not
covered but this basically means a child
of this class now what is a child of the
class we will cover at
that concept in detail when we will talk
about inheritance but for now you can
understand that it is a basically an
extension of the class so
when the moment you declare something is
protected it can easily be accessible
within the same class in which this
protected component was declared it can
be accessed in the package it can also
be accessed in the subclasses of the
class but anything outside the package
will not be able to access it because
you see an n here then we have the
default access modifier or no modifier
if you do not write anything in front of
a class or a method or a variable it
gets the default access modifier
privileges and that privilege mean that
anybody within the same class will be
able to access that default variable or
a default component anybody within the
package will also be able to access it
the subclasses of the class where the
default component was declared those
subclasses will not be able to access it
and anybody outside the package will
obviously not be able to access it
then comes the last one which is the
most restricted privilege which is
called private so if you put private in
front of a class or in front of a method
or in front of a variable that component
will only be accessible within the class
where it was declared
it will not be accessible in the package
it will not be accessible in the
subclasses and definitely not be
accessible to anybody outside the
package
so private is the least privileged or
least access permission level you have
in java
once you write private in front of any
component that only the the classes
other variables the the same class in
which you declare this particular
private variable only that class itself
will be able to access it and nobody
else will be able to access it and as
you move above the accesses become more
and more lenient you can see there's
just one y and three n here the moment
you move a bit above to the default
modifier you get two y's so everybody in
the class and everybody in the package
will be able to access that particular
component rest of for the rest of the
other world it is still unknown when you
write something as protected then
everything in the class everything in
the package and everything in the
subclasses will also be able to access
it rest of the world cannot access it
and if you write something as public
then anybody can access it it's like y
everywhere so that is how the access
levels work now let us understand this
with the help of example
so i will go here and i've just written
a very simple dummy class here which has
uh which is a class called test and i
have a method here which is a display
method so very simple class nothing
fancy here and if you if you notice i
have not put any kind of public private
or
or protected modifier in front of the
class so this will get the default
privilege if something has default
privilege then the whole world will not
be able to access it so let's go to a
different package let's go to this
package which is here
and let's try to access this particular
test class so we will try to access this
test.java here in the main class
so let's try to do that let's say test t
equal to new test i'm just initializing
the same class
so what do i get i get a compile error
let me try to fix it if i can and i
cannot fix it if you see i'm just trying
to use this particular test class into a
different package but that package is
not able to see the class at all i'm
getting a compilation error and if i try
to click on the error generally eclipse
provide me suggestions to fix the to
import this particular class but eclipse
is not able to find and find any class
with the name of test which can be
imported in this package which is a
different package than the one of the
test class so we cannot access it
because it's in the default access
now let's go back to the test class and
let's make it public
so i've just made it public here and now
if i click on this again i get the
suggestion if you see this suggestion
was not there earlier now it says import
test and if i click on this double click
it gets imported and everything is happy
so you can see the whole access modifier
in effect here the default walls is
versus public you can also try the other
other kind of uh
access modifiers let's try private as
well i think private will also have the
same effect because it will still not be
accessible from the package or from the
subclass from or from the from the whole
world we already saw this particular in
effect but we will see the private in a
different way now
so going back to the test class i have
made the class as public but the method
here is default i have not exposed this
method to be used outside the class
let's see what happens if i try to call
this display method from the main class
so i have successfully initialized the
class and if i say t
dot
and if i look at the suggestions here i
do not get the suggestion of the display
method
why because it is default
if i go back
make it private
can i now access it let's try again nope
still we can't access it eclipse is not
even able to find it inside this package
because it is private
let's go back and make it public
so i've made it just public now going
back to the main class and again saying
t dot now i get that display suggestion
as the first suggested method here and
now i am able to use the display method
once i have made it public so you see
the moment you change the uh access
modifiers the changes are propagated
immediately and you can see the public
versus default versus private in play
here we can even go into further detail
by using the protected but for protected
i have to explain the concept of
subclasses so i will cover this
protected versus subclasses concept when
i talk about inheritance and there we
will see the usage of protected
variables and the protected access
modifier but we saw the usage of public
the default modifier and the private
modifier do check out the documentation
for these access modifiers and i would
strongly suggest you to play around with
this get more comfortable with this
concept of different kind of modifiers
let's also run an example for for
understanding the default modifier in a
better sense because we can see that for
the package it says why right so let's
go back to eclipse and within the same
package where we created test class
let's create another class let's call it
test
demo
so i will just click finish
i get a new class let me also
write the public static void main method
here so i get the public static void
main method here and let's try to access
the test class here within the same
package so let me again go back to the
default privilege here so i put the test
class access as the default class or
default access and same goes for display
so can other classes in the same package
access the test class now let's see that
if i go to test demo and here if i try
to get the test class initialize does it
work or does it give me a compilation
error yes it works it works because the
test class and the test demo are in the
same package and test class has that
default access privilege
so let's try to run one more variation
of it to understand the usage of the
private method better going back to the
test class this display method has the
default privilege right now so going by
that logic if i say t dot i should be
able to get access to the display method
and yes that is possible if i run this
particular program i will be able to get
whatever is given out by the display
method which is hello world
now let's try to make this particular
method as private and let's try to
access this method from one of the other
class in the same package as of the test
class so the class is default the method
is private
and if you see this class has already
turned red there is a compilation error
because now the display method is not
accessible to the test demo class even
if it was in the same package it's not
accessible because the display methods
privilege or access modifier has gone to
private now exactly the same as
explained here because it has become
private so the package level members
cannot access it there's an n here so
this is this was another variation to
show you how you can use public
protected and private together to only
expose the members methods and classes
which are supposed to be exposed to the
consumer this is a very critical and
very important concept to be used in
java and it is used from a very simple
program to all the highly complex
application this is sort of the bare
bone or the for laying foundation for
any kind of basic security level premise
which you need to build your application
let's get started with encapsulation so
again let's understand what is
encapsulation in general and then we
will apply that concept to java
encapsulation if you try to break that
word if i just write it here in the form
of a comment
it's n
capsule
just trying to break this word into to
to make it more visual so you see you
see a word called capsule here so if you
try to imagine a capsule why do you
create that and what's the concept of a
capsule capsule tries to pack lot of
things inside a small tube-like shape
and the concept of encapsulation is sort
of inspired from that not exactly not
literally but that's the basic idea of
of this root word which is called
encapsulation so encapsulation basically
means to restrict
accessing the properties of a class to
the outside world if you want to protect
the properties of your class how do you
do that you do that with the help of the
concept called encapsulation so here you
this is a sort of a security feature you
can think of a think of it as a security
feature that you want to protect the
properties of your class
and you will use encapsulation to
protect the properties how you implement
encapsulation let's have a look at that
now so basic idea is to encapsulate the
objects create sort of a capsule around
the object which can provide that
protection layer and you will define how
the outside world is going to access the
properties of the class if needed so
i've created a simple class here and
it's if you if you remember one of the
previous examples when we discussed
about classes i used the same class
which was the student class and i'm just
using the same class for continuity so
i've created a student class here and i
have created three different properties
of this particular class which is name
name of the student age of the student
and address of the student you see
intentionally i have used the keyword
private
in front of these three properties and
that is the first thing which you need
to do to implement encapsulation on your
object that you hide all the properties
from the outside world remember the
moment you make anything is private only
the class which is the student class
itself only the class itself can see
these variables or these properties
nothing outside the student class will
be able to
access the name or age or the address
directly from the student class it's not
possible that's the whole idea of making
it private because you don't want the
outside world to access these properties
so you make those properties as private
then you create a constructor the
constructor has to be public so that
anybody can initialize the student
object because you want your object to
be accessible remember so you want the
objects to be accessible but you want
the restriction on the access
of the properties of the object
and these are the properties of the
object
so you have restricted them by making it
private but that doesn't solve the
problem because there will be some
illegitimate consumers of the student
object which should not have access to
the student properties but there will
also be some legitimate consumers of the
student object which should be having
access to the properties of the student
for example the payroll
application will need access to these
particular
properties the examination application
will require access to these particular
properties so how do you do that
you create getters we call them getters
because they start with the keyword
get so you create a getter method for
each of the property you create the
method called as get name and this is
the naming convention with java promotes
that you write get and then you write
the name of the property in camel case
so you write get name and this property
is supposed to return the name property
of this particular object and you here
you say return name so you're returning
the the name which is being stored by
the current student object whenever
somebody calls student object dot get
name and this is the way you have
restricted the access of this particular
object as well so remember you made it
private so that nobody can access it and
then you defined your own way of
providing access to the
name property of this particular class
now if anybody wants to access the name
value of your student object there's
only one and one way to do that which is
via calling get name so you have
provided restrictions and you have also
provided prescriptive guidance on how
you are going to expose the properties
of your class that's the second
thing which you need to do to implement
correct form of encapsulation on your
object that that is to provide the
getter methods with the right visibility
you want to make them public so that
anybody can call them but
since you are governing which is what is
written inside the method you have full
control on what kind of exposure you
want to give for this particular
property similarly you create a getter
for age calling getage which returns the
age and then you call get you write get
address and return the address here it
is simply returning it but if you want
to do more stuff here feel free to do
that like i said you govern the control
of how do you want to return the name
maybe you don't want to return the
complete name and you want to just
return the initials then you can split
the string trim the string and return
only the initials so that's the basic
idea of getters
now after you have created the object
there might be use cases where somebody
needs to overwrite the values of the
properties like name age or address
whatever student's name was incorrectly
mentioned when they called the
constructor and now they want to
overwrite the name or fix the name so
basically they have to replace the
existing value of the name with a new
name
so in that case you need to provide what
we call as setters and they start with
set that's why we call them setters and
we follow the same kind of logic that
you provide the setters for all the
properties of your class so you had
three properties which were name age and
address and you provided the setters for
all three of them and how do you provide
that you write you again make them as
public because you want the outside
world to access this setter method to
overwrite the values of the name this
method is not going to return anything
so it is going to be void then you write
the name of the method which starts with
set and then the property name in camel
case and then you provide the new value
which is the value which should be which
should be the new value and this is the
value which should replace the existing
value so whatever new value you want to
supply you supply that as the argument
of the set of methods for set name for
set age or for set address and then you
write this particular line which says
set the current name property of this
particular object with the name which is
coming in from the argument so this dot
name remember this dot name represents
the current objects property because
this represents the current object so
whatever is the current object property
value of the name is just overwrite that
value with the argument coming in do the
same thing for age and set age method
and do the same thing for set address in
the in the set address method so this is
how you are going to provide the setters
and the getters
so setters and getters can also be
generated in smart id is like eclipse so
you just right click you go to source
and here you will see the option of
generate getters and setters if you
click on this it will give you the list
of the fields which are available to be
had to be having getters and setters
currently it says no fields or all
fields have getters and setters already
yes because they have it let me just
comment this and show this how this work
so for example let me comment all the
getters and setters
so i'm commenting them and if i right
click
source generate caters and setters i get
all the fields available for which
setters and getters can be generated so
you can select them and leave everything
as default hit generate and it is
automatically going to generate the
getters and the setter you see all the
code of the getter and setter is
automatically generated you do not even
need to write it and this is the power
of the smart ides let me just uh revert
what i did so you created everything as
all the properties as private
and then you define how you want to
replace the values by providing the
setters and you define how you want the
outside world to access your properties
so you have full control of the class
now you you control the visibility you
control how they are going to get
initialized you are you are controlling
how the properties are going to be
overwritten or set and you control how
the properties are going to be returned
so you have complete control of the
class so you have created a perfect
capsule here a perfect form of
encapsulation in this class and this is
how you can implement encapsulation
let's get started with abstraction let's
first understand the definition of
abstraction before we relate this to
java abstraction generally means hiding
something when you want to hide some
details of of a particular object from
the outside world you apply the concept
of abstraction for example when you
drive a particular car you just hit the
accelerator and the car speeds up now
it's not only one action when you hit
the accelerator the whole machinery of
the car and all the components different
parts of the car work together to speed
up they would be engine there would be
propulsion there would be fuel there
would be there might be some if it's an
electric car there would batteries uh
there would be whole different kinds of
pistons and plugs which will make the
car speed up it's not only a single
component it's a lot of different
components under the hood and that's the
concept of abstraction that we only show
the relevant parts to the user and we
hide all the internal details from the
user that's the basic idea of
abstraction so a car manufacturer
abstracts away all the inner technical
details from the driver and just gives
the driver a single pedal to speed up
the car
for a user it's a very good experience
because he doesn't need to know about
all the internals of the car but the car
manufacturer can hide all the details
and provide a very simple interface for
the driver to interact with which is
just a gas pedal and that's the basic
idea of abstraction and we try to apply
the same kind of concept to java in the
form of abstraction and java provides
this
kind of concept implementation with the
help of a keyword which is called
abstract
now abstract is a keyword which can be
used in front of a class or a method
when you use it in front of a class the
whole class becomes abstract abstract
class is a type of class so the class
itself becomes an abstract class one of
the things to remember is that abstract
class cannot be instantiated but can be
subclassed remember we talked about the
concept of subclass and the parent class
when we talked about inheritance so if
you make a class as abstract class you
cannot call the constructor of the class
because you cannot instantiate it but
you can extend the abstract class and
create a child class class out of it
that's the concept of abstract class
another concept is abstract method you
can also use the abstract keyword in
front of a method and when you use
abstract keyword in front of a method
then that method is only declared
without an implementation you are not
going to provide any implementation of
the method and you are just going to
declare the method something like this
we will see a similar example in the in
the hands-on as well but that's the
basic idea that you just declare the
method you are not providing an
implementation as to what does move to
method actually does because that's the
whole concept of abstraction and it is
the responsibility of the child classes
which inherit the particular class in
which the abstract method would be
sitting so that child class will be
having the responsibility to provide a
concrete implementation of the declared
method let's understand this better with
the help of an example so here i have
created a class called graphic object
and i have made the class as abstract
class this is the keyword which you need
to use in front before the class keyword
and the task becomes an abstract class
now when you create an abstract class it
automatically gets some properties the
first property is that this particular
class must have at least one abstract
method and this is how you define the
abstract methods where you just provide
the declaration but you do not provide
the implementation of the draw method or
the resize method and the way you will
create the abstract methods is by using
the abstract keyword before the actual
method declaration starts so general
method declaration would look like this
and if you use abstract in front of it
this becomes an abstract method
declaration abstract class can also have
concrete methods so that is the liberty
which abstract class gives you that you
can have abstract methods which are just
declared but you can also have normal
methods which are which
where you can also provide the
implementation so you can have normal
methods and abstract methods as well in
an abstract class
so this is the abstract class now if if
you want to provide an implementation of
the draw and resize method you have to
extend this abstract class so we extend
this abstract class by creating two
child classes out of this particular
abstract class which is circle.java
where you can see i create a normal
class and i use the extends keyword for
inheritance and i'm saying that circle
class is inheriting from the graphic
object class which was my abstract class
and once i use this extends keyword then
i have the responsibility of providing
the implementation of the abstract
methods actually java will force me to
provide the implementation of these two
methods if i do not provide all the
declared methods so there are two
declared methods here so if the circuit
class does not provide that the
implementation for both draw and resize
methods then java will throw an error
and it will ask you to take an action
which can be either define all the
methods meaning provide implementation
for all the methods or make the circle
class itself as abstract let's see if i
just comment this particular out i get
an error you see a red line here and if
you click on this particular balloon
here it will say either you can add the
unimplemented methods or you can make
the circle type as abstract so these are
the two options which you will get to
fix this particular error so an abstract
class can be extended by another
abstract class if the child abstract
class is not implementing all the
methods of the parent if you want to
implement all the methods then just
implement them and keep keep it as a
normal class and that's what i've done
here i've just created a normal class
here and provided the implementation and
once you provide the implementation of
both of the methods the error is gone
similarly i have also provided another
child class because it's uh there can be
a
there can be multiple children of a
particular parent so rectangle also
extends from the graphic object and it
also provides its own implementation of
drawing and resize because generally the
way you will draw a rectangle and you
resize a rectangle will be different
than drawing or resizing a circle here
i'm not doing anything in the methods
because this is just to show you the
demonstration i'm just printing a cis
out saying drawing a circle and resizing
or drawing a rectangle and resizing a
rectangle and in the circle class
drawing a circle and resizing a circle
so one abstract class is the parent
class which is the graphic object and
two children circle and rectangle both
providing the implementation of the
abstract methods which were declared in
the base class now let's go to the main
class where i've defined define the
public static void main method and here
you see i have created two different
kind of blocks of code here one block is
where i'm saying graphic object creating
a reference of the graphic object named
as circle and initializing the circle
object now you see a difference here
here is the abstract class and here is
the concrete class so whatever you
define on the right hand side whatever
is the type of object will be the type
of methods being caught so if you
created a circle object and then if you
call the draw method and resize method
these methods will be called from the
circle class if you initialized it as
new rectangle then you are creating a
rectangle class object and then the draw
and the resize method will be called
from the rectangle class that's the
basic construct and that's how you will
initialize a particular class which is
using an abstract class so i i call a
graphic object circle new circle and i
call circle.draw and circle dot resize
similarly graphic object rectangle equal
to new rectangle and rectangle.draw
rectangle dot resize let's run this
program and observe the output so when i
call this particular block of code
circle object gets initialized and then
circle.draw method prints drawing a
circle and circle.resize method prints
drawing resizing a circle similarly when
i create the rectangle class object
referencing it with the graphic object
class rectangle.draw
prints this particular line drawing a
rectangle and
rectangle.resize prints this particular
line which is resizing a rectangle and
this is how you will use the concept of
abstraction there's another very
interesting thing which which is which
is going on here remember i told if i do
this and i i create i just put a system
out here base
abstract plus so if i do this here if i
create if i still write a constructor
though java says that it cannot be
instantiated if i still write a
constructor of it and i do not do any
changes here and if i run this
particular program let's see what
happens you'll see the base abstract
class being called here let me just
reformat it by putting ln here so that
we get a better output so if i run this
particular program you see base abstract
class is getting printed somehow though
we said that abstract classes cannot be
instantiated but still the constructor
of this is still getting called somehow
when i create a circle class the base
class constructor gets called and when i
create a rectangle class again the base
class constructor gets called this is
this is the power of inheritance because
in inheritance remember how it works
when you call when you initialize a
particular child object referencing it
with the parent object see the
references of the parent class and the
object is of the child class so whenever
you do it like this
first the default constructor because
i'm calling the default constructor here
the default constructor of the circle
class will get called which will go here
remember i told you that java provides
the default constructor automatically if
you don't provide it so the default
constructor of circle gets called but
java sees that you are writing this code
here which says circle extends graphic
object so java is automatically going to
call the parent class and going to
initialize the parent class as well
because that's how it will be able to
see these methods and so so that's why
it will automatically call the base
class constructor even if you don't call
it explicitly in fact you cannot call it
explicitly java will not allow you to
initialize the graphic object class
explicitly it can only and only be
called by java itself indirectly via the
concept of inheritance if you try to do
this let's try to do this for fun and
and also for better understanding so if
i write graphic object go equal to
new graphic object you see i don't even
get an option but let's write it and
let's see what happens so you see that
this particular it gives basically an
error because it's not able to find the
constructor of the graphic object class
though even i have defined the default
constructor here but still java is not
able to find it because this class is
abstract so hence proved abstract
classes cannot be instantiated
explicitly they can only be instantiated
by the child classes through the
internal mechanisms of java itself and
that's all i want to talk about in this
particular session where we looked in
detail about the concept of abstraction
couple of more things which i did not
cover in the previous session i just
want to call them out for clarity java
does not support multiple inheritance
when i say multiple inheritance what it
means that you will not have a scenario
where a child will be extending from two
base classes java does not support it it
does support it with the with the help
of interfaces but i will talk about
interfaces in the coming sessions but
here just understand this that you
cannot use multiple inheritance with
classes in java a child cannot have two
parent or two base classes in java java
will not allow that it is also called
the diamond problem because the child
class does not know whether to follow
the route of base 1 plus or the base 2
class if it is extending from 2
different base 1 and base 2 classes so a
class can only extend from one class in
java we can find a work around of it by
using the concept of interfaces but
that's something which will be coming
later another thing to understand is
that when you create an abstract class
here these variables you can declare
declare these variables as well and
these variables will be accessible by
all the child classes as you access them
choose from over 300 in-demand skills
and get access to 1 000 plus hours of
video content for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more let's get
started with inheritance
so inheritance is basically one of the
most important properties of any
object-oriented programming language
it's basically a concept and the concept
says that what if you have a scenario
where you want multiple classes to share
similar behavior and similar properties
let's understand this with the help of
an example let's take the example of a
bank
when you go to a bank to open an account
there are multiple types of accounts
there can be a savings account it can be
a type of current account there can also
be a different offering for personal
account and commercial accounts such as
for businesses
then you may also have loan accounts
which are having different kind of
properties so all of these types of
accounts are still
technically accounts and they will share
some similar properties for example all
of them will have to maintain some sort
of an interest rate for example all of
them will be used to either deposit
money or withdraw money so there would
be some kind of similarity across all of
these types of account classes but at
the same time there will also be some
sort of differentiality amongst these
classes the way you will calculate the
interest rate for a current account will
be different from the way you will
calculate the interest rate for a
savings account and the same applies for
commercial account personal account loan
account etc so you see that we have some
common behavior but at the same time we
also have some different behavior so
whenever you have such scenario
always think about applying the concept
of inheritance in your application
there's another simple way to spot
whether inheritance can be used at a
particular place or not inheritance is
also called is a relationship so
whenever you read the requirements from
a customer just try to find the words
which use this particular phrase is a
for example
car is a vehicle savings account is a
type of account
similarly you will find many other types
of similar examples so whenever you will
see that is a relationship between two
different kinds of objects or two
different kind of entities that means
that there might be an inheritance
relationship being applied between them
and that's how you will spot the usage
of inheritance
so so far we have understood this
concept that there would be some sort of
relationship between the two classes
what would be this relationship the
relationship will be of parent child
type there will be a parent class some
people also call that as base class and
then there will be a child class
so the child class will be inheriting
the properties and the behaviors from
the base class or from the parent class
i will be using base class and parent
class terms interchangeably during this
session but the basic idea and basic
premise is like that only that there
will be a child class and there will be
a parent class and the child class class
is extending from the parents class
remember the word extend because we are
going to use that and i've just shown
you the uh what you see here is
basically the official definition which
is given by javadocs here we can read
the definition as well and the basic
idea which i told you lies in the parent
and child relationship and this is how
you can conceptualize it that you will
have a base class or a parent class and
then you will you can have multiple
children of it and then those children
can again have their own children and so
on so forth so this hierarchy this whole
inheritance hierarchy can go as deep as
you want it to be and that's the basic
idea and basic conceptualization of how
you understand and how you visualize
inheritance now let's move to eclipse
ide and try to understand this with the
help of an example so for this
particular case i have created a set of
classes basically which we will be using
to demonstrate the relationship of
inheritance and i've taken the simple
example of a bicycle so a bicycle is
again a very generic definition of any
two wheeler and bicycles can have
multiple types there can be an
all-terrain bike there can be a mountain
bike there can be a city bike there can
be a bike which is specific specifically
made for ladies and similarly there can
be multiple different types of bikes but
all of these bikes will have some
similar properties for example all of
them will have two wheels all of them
will have a seat all of them will have
brake all of them will have some sort of
some sort of a speeding mechanism where
they can accelerate or de-accelerate so
there will be some commonality but at
the same time a mountain bike's features
might be very different from a city bike
feature a mountain bike features my
feature mountain bike might have gears
for example whereas a city bike might
not have gears because you don't need
that much of a variation in
in inclination and declination when you
drive down the road so i'm trying to
conceptualize the same example here
where i've created a class called
bicycle and this is my base class
i define two properties in the in the
bicycle class which is
gear and speed we will come back to
protected in a while but
let's let's leave that there so i have
two properties which is gear and speed i
have a constructor where i'm
initializing the starting speed and the
starting gear and then
i have three methods here which says set
gear apply brake and speed up when i
apply brake the speed is going to get
reduced so that's why you see minus
equal to unary operator
and when i'm trying to speed up the
speed is going to increase that's why
i'm using the plus equal to unary
operator so when you use the method
speed up the speed is going to be
increased by the value you supply in the
method similarly when you apply the
break the speed is going to get reduced
by the amount you supply in the method
argument and that is my base class
bicycle gear speed and three methods now
let's have a look at the child class
so the way you will define the
inheritance relationship in java is by
using this extends keyword remember i
told you to remember the extends keyword
so what you will do that you will write
your class name as usual and then you
will use extends keyword and then you
will use the parent class name or the
base class name so here i am saying
class mountain bike extends bicycle and
here i am providing an additional
property remember the whole commonality
versus differentiality equation so a
mountain bike might have an extra
property to adjust the seat height so
that's the extra property which mountain
bike is having
and then since this mountain bike is
extending the bicycle class
this mountain bike class has the
responsibility to initialize the bicycle
class as well and the way it will
fulfill that responsibility is by taking
all the arguments of bicycle class plus
the mountain bike class in its
constructor and that's why you see three
different properties here you see the
start height property which is the
property of this particular class which
is the seat height and then you see the
start speed and start gear property
which directly are not available in this
class but this class is inheriting those
properties from the base class remember
the keyword inheritance here and then
once you do that how do you initialize
the base class constructor is by calling
the super method this is again a keyword
in java and you will use this super
keyword to refer to the base class
constructor in this way so what you will
do technically is that you will write
super and you will supply the arguments
which is required by the base class
constructor
if i go back the base class constructor
requires two arguments start speed and
start gear
so i write super and then i write start
speed and start gear so whatever i got
from here in the constructor of mountain
bike i am supplying those values as is
to super and java will automatically
take care of invoking this particular
constructor the moment it
uh encounters this kind of statement
another another thing to notice is that
the super keyword or super statement has
to be the first statement inside your
constructor remember that whenever you
are dealing with inheritance and
whenever you have to initialize the
super class constructor or the base
class constructor use the super
constructor invocation as the very first
statement inside your child class
constructor otherwise java will not
compile the program and then you will
initialize the local variable i should
call this as this remember i we
discussed about this in this in the
classes session
okay and then it just has a method of
set height so there is no extra method
which this mountain bike is providing
but this mountain bike will have access
to all the methods which have been
provided here and all the properties
which have been provided here this
mountain bike can access everything from
the bicycle class and that's the whole
idea of inheritance that the child class
can access the properties of the base
class by extending the base class
now let's look at how do we invoke this
particular class so for that i have a
simple class name as inheritance demo
which has a public static void main
method and then i am initializing the
mountain bike class
i'm supplying three values as 20 10 and
1.
so the 20 goes to start height
the 10 here goes to
start speed
and
one here goes to gear or the start gear
and that's how i'm setting the values so
when i call this particular constructor
here the mountain bike constructor is
going to this mountain bike constructor
is going to get called and which in turn
is going to call the base class bicycle
class constructor as well and everything
will be set accordingly and then let's
try to access the gear property remember
gear is not directly available in the
mountain bike class but i am still able
to do mountain bike dot gear because
child class can access the parents class
properties
similarly the same thing goes for speed
as well and seat height is the local
property of this particular class
mountain bike so it will anyways be
accessible so i can access all the
properties of the base class and the
child class itself seamlessly without
any differentiation now let's try to
call a method so here i'm calling the
method apply break remember apply break
was defined in the base class not in the
child class it's defined here so i'm
calling the apply break method and i
want to reduce the speed the current
speed by one and then i'm printing the
current speed saying that bike speed
after applying brake is mountain bike
dot speed so let's run this particular
program and observe the outputs
okay so the the first statement which
gets printed is at line number seven
which says gear is
one because it's coming from here then
the seat height is mountain bike dot
seat height which is 20 which is the
first argument here and then the bike
speed is 10 which is coming as here and
getting printed here and then when i
apply the brake let's go back to the
apply brake method the logic is that
whatever is the current speed reduce it
by the value i supply in the method
so if i supply 1 10 minus 1 becomes 9
and that becomes the current speed if i
supply 5 here the current speed will be
10 minus 5 equal to 5. let's assert that
particular assumption as well yes we can
see that and similarly you can access
other methods of the base class as well
if i just do control space here and you
can see apply break is accessible set
gears at hide speed up all the methods
which are defined in the base class are
accessible in the child class as well
this is the power of inheritance one
more thing which i said i will come back
to is around the usage of protected
access modifier remember when we
discussed about the access modifiers in
the previous session i said that
protected is used when you are dealing
with inheritance that whenever you
define something as protected it will be
available to be accessible in the child
classes of the base class so if i define
this particular variable as as protected
then this particular property will be
accessible in the child class mountain
bike as well
let's play around this let's make this
as private and see what happens
so if i make this private now when i say
private the scope of this particular
variable is within the class only and
nobody outside the class will be able to
see it
and you can see the effect of it i can
see an error being coming here in my
inheritance demo class because now
mountain bike object cannot access the
gear property because the gear property
is defined in the base class and now it
is private that's why the child class
now mountain bike class cannot access
the property gear
and the moment you make make it back to
protected it will be accessible the
error is gone there's no red line here
so that's how you can you can use the
protected access modifiers it is always
always recommended to use them when you
when you write any kind of inheritance
logic and in inheritance logic as well
intentionally if you want to hide a
particular
property from the child classes just
make it private and that's all i want to
cover in this particular session where
we uh dive deep into the concept of
inheritance we had a look at an example
using the bicycle and mountain bike kind
of construct and you can apply the same
kind of construct on any kind of other
other kind of business requirement
remember the is a relationship let's get
started with interfaces in java now
again let's understand what do we mean
by an interface in general and then we
will see how do we apply the concept of
interfaces in java so imagine let's
let's take the same example of vehicle
industry because that's something which
we see every day around ourselves and we
can relate to it so imagine if all the
car manufacturers were creating a
different way of driving a car what if
in one car you have a steering but in
other car you do not have a steering but
you have something else which is which
may be called something else in one car
you have the gas pedal to speed up in
other car you have a button to speed up
similarly in in one car you may have
different kind of doors and in other
card you may have different kind of
doors which are completely different
looking it's not even a single simple
handle to open it so you see the problem
here the problem here is that all the
car manufacturers are not working on a
single contract they are not respecting
a single interface which will create a
poor user experience because the users
whenever the users have to buy a new car
or they have to switch from one
manufacturer to other manufacturer they
are completely clueless as to how to
drive that particular class because the
interface they were using in the
previous car is completely different
from the interface they are being shown
in the other car and that's that's the
basic need for the concept of interface
think of it as an contract agreement you
see it is also mentioned here that
if you apply the same kind of concept to
programming world imagine if every
programmer was writing their own logic
in their own way without following a
single contract or a single guideline
soon it is going to create a problem and
that's the kind of problem
interfaces try to solve so interface is
again a keyword in java and the basic
idea or the basic construct is that the
interfaces are going to define the
specifications of how a class would act
let me repeat this in a more generic way
interfaces are going to define the
contract or the specification which is
going to govern how an application or
code or programming logic will behave
that's the basic idea of interfaces
so interfaces are their own type and the
basic property of interface is that it
can only contain constants method
declarations similar to abstract classes
and some default methods or static
methods or nested types what is nested
type we will cover that later default
methods will touch upon a bit here and
the static methods as well but the basic
idea is that when you create when you
create an interface in java you cannot
write anything concrete in terms of the
behavior of the interface when i say
behavior always think of that as method
so you cannot define a concrete method
in an interface you can only declare
methods you can also declare constants
you can create a particular type of
concrete method by using the default
keyword but use it in very special
circumstances you can also create static
methods as well which are only going to
belong to the interface and nobody else
now let's look at an example
and and also before we go to the example
let me also phrase this here that if an
interface cannot define a concrete
implementation of the methods then
naturally the interface is going to be
extended by a child class a concrete
class which is going to provide the
implementation of the methods declared
in the interface it does sound like
abstract classes but there is a
difference let's understand the
difference with the help of an example
this is how an interface will look like
i've used the same construct of bicycle
and mountain bike just to maintain some
continuity and less context switching
but this is how an interface would look
like you will not use the class keyword
but instead you instead of that you will
use the interface keyword you can only
declare methods you cannot define
methods remember when we looked at the
abstract classes example we were able to
define concrete methods as well but in
interface that's a strict no no you
cannot define concrete methods let me
show you the abstract class in the case
of abstraction which we used this was
the abstract class and it did have a
concrete method right but bicycle.java
here which is because it's an interface
it is not going to allow you to create a
concrete method another thing is that if
you try to declare a variable inside the
class they will have to be constant you
cannot just declare them without any
value for example i cannot do this
if i do this it is going to give an
error you see an error here and it says
initialize field x at declaration
something like this public static final
so interface is going to force you to
declare all the variables as public
static final with some value if you try
to use them inside interface
so that is also something which
interface will mandate so you see
interfaces are more strict they are more
strict in terms of what you can do you
can only declare public static final
variables and you can only declare
methods you cannot define methods so
abstract class is less restrictive
interface is more restrictive and that
is the differentiation which you have to
keep in mind whether to use abstract
classes or whether to use interfaces
that is also a very common confusing
question in the interviews as well and
remember that interfaces are only for
contracts or specifications where in
case of abstract class you can write a
concrete behavior as well in terms of a
concrete method in the base class
interfaces there is no concrete
implementation in the base class
abstract classes yes there can be a
concrete implementation in the base
class that's the basic difference moving
on i have created a child class here
which is again mountain bike and it has
three properties seat height gear and
speed similar to the previous example it
has a constructor and remember again
interfaces cannot be uh initialized
directly so you do not even need to call
a super method here because there is
nothing to initialize you initialize a
class to create a state state is denoted
by the properties but interfaces will
force you to write a public static final
property and initialize its value
automatically so you do not need a
constructor for the interface because
there is nothing to initialize
everything has been initialized in terms
of the variables and the methods are
anywhere just declared that's why you
don't need to call super here after that
the moment you write this particular
keyword here implements and that is how
you will basically extend from the from
the interface you will use the
implements
bicycle keyword here implements is the
keyword and bicycle is the name of the
interface if you write this here then
java is going to force you to provide
the implementation of these two methods
if i
if i do this implements bicycle and if i
comment out these two methods which is
coming from the base class it is going
to give an error and if i read out this
error it says either you add the
unimplemented methods or you make the
mountain bike class as abstract there
are two ways to fix this particular
class similar to abstract classes it
will force you to write the
implementation of the base class
declared methods
another thing which java will will
suggest you and will also force you via
some ides as well is that you use this
particular annotation we use this
particular annotation to tell java that
we are overriding this method from the
base class since apply break and speed
up methods were defined here in the base
class and this child class is supposed
to provide the implementation of the
methods by overriding them overriding is
again a concept which we will talk about
in detail in the coming sessions but for
now remember that you need to write this
annotation here on the methods which
have been taken from the base class to
provide an implementation and the
implementation is similar to what we
have seen before so whatever value you
supply in the apply break the speed is
going to get decremented by that
particular value and in case of speed up
whatever value you supply in the
argument that value is going to be added
to the current speed and the speed is
going to go up
let's look at the main class here which
is called interface demo it has a public
static void main method and here i'm
again initializing the child class
nothing's nothing strange here and then
i'm using the getter method here because
i have made everything as private here
and rest of the things are just here as
is i have the getters and setters here
for all the properties and i'm using
those here so i'm using the getters to
just get the value of gear seat height
and speed and then i'm applying the
brake and then i'm printing the current
speed after applying the brakes let me
just
expand this a bit more and then i'm
using the speed up method trying to
increase the current speed of the bike
by 10 and then printing the new speed
again so using the apply break and speed
up methods which are concretely defined
in the child class by using this
override annotation and these were the
methods which were declared
in the interface in the base interface
and that's all which is happening in
this particular class let's run this
particular program
and these are the values i get i get the
gear as one which is coming from here i
get the seat height as 20 which is
coming from here i get the current bike
speed as 10 this was the value which it
was initialized with then i'm applying
the brake and after applying the brake
the speed of the bike gets reduced and
it becomes 10 minus 1 which becomes
9 and that's what gets printed here and
then i'm speeding up the bike by 10 so
the current value of the current value
of the speed of the bike is
9 and if i incremented it by 10 it
becomes 19 and that's what gets printed
here
and that's all i want to cover in this
particular session where we had a look
at an example of how we can use
interfaces in java and how we can use
interfaces with the concept of
inheritance let's get started with
polymorphism so polymorphism is a very
generic concept which means that a
particular object can take multiple form
let's not even call it as object let's
make it more generic a particular entity
can take multiple forms if any entity in
java exhibits that kind of behavior then
we say that polymorphism is in action
that entity can be a class or an object
or even a method and in today's session
we are going to talk about that type of
polymorphism which is exhibited by
methods so we will see how a particular
method in java can take many different
forms containing different logics but
still having the same name
and that concept is called method
overloading so whenever you hear the
word that you need to overload a
particular method or this is method
overloading happening technically or
conceptually it's basically polymorphism
in action and polymorphism is being
applied on a method here and that
phenomena we call as method overloading
so in today's session we are going to
have a look at how we can implement
method overloading in java so the basic
idea of method overloading is that the
name of the method should remain the
same so you see in this particular class
which i have created to demonstrate the
method overloading so this is the class
name and the method name which i am
going to overload is called multiply and
that is probably the first thing which
you need to remember to implement over
method overloading correctly that the
method name is going to remain the same
the type of the return of the method may
change here you see it's returning int
here in the first instance in the second
instance also it is returning int but in
the third instance it is returning
double so the return type of an
overloaded method can change another
another thing which which can be varied
between same method being defined again
and again is that the number of
arguments and the type of arguments the
first multiply method takes two
arguments of integer type the second
multiply method takes three arguments of
integer type and the third multiply
method takes two arguments of double
type so by using method overloading you
can vary the number of arguments and
also the type of arguments so the basic
idea is that you declare you define the
method using the same name but you do a
variation in the arguments or the return
types and that's how you technically
implement method overloading in this
case in this particular case the
multiply is the method being overloaded
and in the first case it is accepting
two integer arguments and returning the
result of multiplication of those
arguments
in the second case the same method name
multiply here the same visibility public
and the same return type but this time
three different types of integer values
can be accepted and this method multiply
method is going to return the
multiplication of three integer numbers
in the third case at line 15 i again use
the same multiply name the method name
but this time the return type becomes
double and this method accepts two
double arguments and returns the result
of the multiplication of these double
values so the method name is same but
the arguments vary and also the return
type may also vary that's the basic
premise of how you implement method
overloading so whenever you want to
implement it keep the method name same
vary the
arguments and the return types and after
that i'm just created a public static
void main method here i have initialized
the class here this particular class
itself method overloading demo and then
i am calling the multiply method on the
object and based on the number of
arguments i supply the corresponding
method will get invoked that is
something with java will take care
automatically that whatever type and the
number of arguments you supply in the
call in the invocation based on the
number and the type of the arguments
java will try to find a matching method
in the overloaded methods if it is able
to find a method it's going to get
invoked if it is not able to find the
method you will get an error in fact you
will get a compile error itself while
you invoke a method which for which the
definition is not available for example
if i try to just copy this
and make an invalid invalid method
invocation let's provide four arguments
and if i do that here itself i will get
the error because java is not able to
find a multiply method in this
particular class which is accepting four
integer arguments so you will get the
compilation error itself before you can
even run the program but the basic idea
is that you use overloading with
multiple different types and the number
of variables so i'm calling multiply
three times let's run this particular
program and observe the output so let me
just bring this output down yep so first
i call demo dot multiply and pass two
integer values 10 and 20. when this
happens this particular method gets
invoked and it is it returns a result of
10 into 20 which is 200 in the second
invocation i'm calling again the
multiply method but this time with three
arguments three integer arguments
specifically and this call is going to
match this particular method signature
and it is going to execute whatever is
written inside this particular method
which is the multiplication of the three
arguments being supplied so 10 into 20
into 30 which is 6 000 the third case
let's go back here at line 25 the third
case of invocation of the multiply
method is accepting two decimal based
arguments 10.5 and 20.5 so java is going
to look at the class and trying to find
a method which can accept decimal values
and there it is this is the method
signature which is going to match the
invocation java is going to do this
matching automatically for you and here
whatever logic you have written inside
this particular method we will get
executed so 10.5 into 20.5 returns
215.25
and that's the output you get so this is
how you can use method overloading in
java this is a rather fairly simple
example but you can make it as complex
as you want but a word of caution do not
use it too extensively in fact lot of
expert programmers do not recommend
using method overloading because it
becomes very confusing use it only when
you do not have any other way out use it
only where this is the only way to write
correct form of methods with the right
readability otherwise generally there
would be other ways to avoid method
overloading by writing concrete purpose
friendly method names themself maybe you
don't need to use the multiply name
again again we can call it as multiply
two numbers multiply three numbers
multiply doubles so that the method name
itself is more explicit and
understandable rather than juggling
around different signatures of the same
method especially it becomes more
confusing if you are creating an
interface which is to be consumed by a
third party developers or third party
application so try to use it with
caution that's what i'm trying to stress
here let's get started with method
overriding in java so in the previous
session we discussed about method
overloading concept now in this session
we'll focus on another interesting
concept by which you can have the same
signature of the method again and again
be used in your code but in a different
way and this concept is called method
overriding method overriding basically
is used together with the concept of
inheritance you won't you will not be
able to use the concept of method
overriding without using the concept of
inheritance remember when we talked
about inheritance i spoke about the
subclass and the parent class concept
sometimes we also call the parent class
as super class so the basic idea is that
if a super class defines a method
remember i'm using the word define here
if the super class uses the
defines a particular method and then the
subclass again tries to define the
method with the exact same signature
this phenomena is called method
overriding now when you do method method
overriding there are some rules to
follow and i'm showing you a tabular
structure here a table basically which
will show you what is possible and what
is not possible when it comes to method
overriding so let's try to understand
this table so if you try to define a
method with the same signature as a
superclass method the rules follow as
per this table let's go with the first
one if you have an instance method
defined in the super class instance
method is the normal method which you
define in your in your classes so if you
have defined an instance method in your
super class and if you define a method
in the subclass with the exact same
signature then that concept is called
method overriding and it will be a
successful override override also let me
also explain what override means here
override means that once you try to
initialize the subclass object you will
be able to invoke its own overridden
method definition if you call that
particular method the subclasses own
instance method is going to get invoked
rather than the super classes instance
method we'll look at that when we look
at the example as well but that's the
normal scenario when where your
superclass defines an instance method
and subclass also defines the an
instance method with the exact same
method signature that concept is called
method overriding what if your
superclass defines a static method
static method is is basically a method
which belongs to the class but not to
the object instance method is called
instance method a normal method is
called instance method because it
belongs to the object you can call the
method on the object but static methods
are called by class so you say class
name dot static method name but when you
when you call instance methods you just
call object name dot instance method
name so that is the basic difference the
static methods belong to the class once
you have defined a static method the
same static method will be available to
all the objects of the class but
instance method are unique to each
object so that was a short tour of what
static methods mean so if you define a
static method in the super class
and then if you try to define an
instance method with the same signature
in the sub class you will get a
compilation error it will not be allowed
it's not allowed in java to override a
static method from super class that's
what it says next one if your super
class has an normal instance method and
then the subclass tries to use the same
signature but creates a static method
out of it then again you will get a
compilation error so that the overriding
of an instance method to a static method
is not allowed and the last concept is
again a very interesting concept and a
very popular interview question about
method hiding so if the super class
defines a static method and the subclass
also defines the static method with the
exact same signature then the super
classes static method gets hidden it
basically hides the superclass method so
that's the basic idea behind over method
overriding so if you see technically
it's a form of polymorphism because the
same method is having multiple
definitions but when we looked at the
previous example the multiple
definitions were in the same class here
the multiple definitions are in
different classes and those classes are
having a parent-child relationship that
was about the theory of it let's go to
an example of it to understand it better
and i've used again the same construct
of bicycle and mountain bike which we
have been using in this in this series
just to maintain continuity so i have a
parent class called bicycle here which
has two
properties gear and speed it has a
constructor nothing unusual there and
then it has defined three methods set
gear apply break and speed up set gear
is just setting the new value as the
gear value apply break is going to
decrement the speed by the value you
supply and speed up is going to
increment the speed by the value you
supply simple this is exactly what we
have seen before now mountain bike tries
to extend bicycle so mountain bike
becomes a child class it defines a
variable called seat height defines a
constructor called super here nothing
unusual so far also defines a setter for
height
center for the seat height not exactly
following the center construct but this
is just to set the height but here
things just get interesting let me just
bring this down a bit yeah so here it is
overriding all the three methods of the
base class and by overriding it is
providing its own implementation of the
same methods let's compare them here
when it overrides the gear and whatever
value you supply it adds 2 to the plus 2
to that value and then sets that value
as the gear value but in case of base
class it was just setting the new value
as the gear value so for inst for
instance if you supplied one here the
gear value becomes one but here if you
supplied one the gear value becomes
three similarly when you apply break on
the mountain bike class whatever value
you supply will be subtracted from the
current speed and 10 would be subtracted
even more so if the speed is let's say
50 and your decrement you supply the
decrement value as 10 so it will be 50
minus 10 minus 10 equal to 30 but in
case of bicycle if the speed was 50 and
you supply 10 then it would be just 50
minus 10 40. so there is
and there is extra 10 being subtracted
from the speed when you apply brake in
case of a mountain bike similarly for
speed up its increment of 10 in addition
to what's what value you supply so again
if the speed was 10 and you supplied 10
here in the argument so 10 plus 10 plus
10 30 will become the new speed in case
of mountain bike but in case of bicycle
if you supply 10 and if the current
speed was also 10 then it becomes 10
plus 10 only 20. so that's the
difference so the basic idea i hope you
get the basic idea here is that you
override the methods and your own class
provide its own implementation of those
methods that's the basic premise of
method overriding all good so far and
you do not have a an uh an obligation to
overwrite all of the methods because
here we have the concrete implementation
of the methods so here in case of
mountain bike you can skip overriding
one of the methods if you like to this
is also fine there will be no
compilation error because speed up has a
concrete implementation in the bicycle
class as well so it's up to you how much
you want to override
so let's move to the main class now
so in the main class we have created the
public static void main method here and
let's look at what is happening inside
the class first we initialize the
bicycle class so bicycle class reference
and bicycle class object nothing unusual
here we supply the gear value and the
speed value then we print the gear and
the speed value we apply brake on the
bicycle and then we observe the new
speed of the bicycle after applying the
brakes let me comment out the rest of
the code and let's observe the output
for only this part of the code which we
just walked through for this section so
if i run this as a java application and
if i show you what i'm getting what i'm
getting here so bicycle gear is one
which is what you supplied in the
constructor bicycle speed is 10 which is
again what you supplied in the
constructor then you applied brake and
when you apply brake this logic gets
executed and you supplied one here so
current speed was 10 so 10 minus 1
becomes 9 and the new speed becomes 9
which is what you are printing here so
far so good let's move on to the next
section let me comment out the previous
section now and let me uncomment this
section so here i have a bicycle
reference but the object is of mountain
bike remember this concept this is this
is called dynamic object binding concept
or dynamic binding concept again this
might be asked in your interviews so
here i'm initializing the mountain bike
with a reference of bicycle remember
whatever is written on the right hand
side will govern the variables and the
methods usage we'll we'll we'll see how
that works out what i just said so i'm
supplying three values here 50 50 and 3
in the mountain bike
if i go here in the mountain bike
constructor so the start height start
speed and gear are the three values
which is supplied as 50 50 and 3 then i
am accessing the gear and the speed now
remember gear and speed are declared in
the bicycle class
but they are accessible in the child
class due to the inheritance phenomena
which we have already covered so if i
print only this part i should get the
expected values
mountain bike gear is 3 which which is
what i have supplied here and mountain
bike speed is 50 which is which is what
i have supplied here
then i apply the brakes now let's move
on to this section i apply the break
supply the value as one and then i want
to see what would be the new speed after
applying the brakes so let's see what
happens when we run this particular code
so if i run this code after applying the
brakes the speed becomes 39 before
applying the brakes the speed was 50. so
what happened here is 50 minus 1
basically this this logic is getting
executed here 50 minus
1 minus 10 which becomes 39 that's why
you get the value as 39 as the new speed
similarly if you want to call another
method as speed up speed up method was
also defined here where i'm saying speed
plus the argument supplied plus 10. so
the current speed is 39 right now then
i'm speeding it up by 10 so by this
logic 39 plus 10 plus 10 which will
become 59 and then i'm printing the new
speed after speeding up so let's see
what happens so if i go to run as java
application and if i observe all the
outputs the speed was 50 initially after
applying the brakes the speed became 39
and after speeding up the speed became
59 so this was a quick demo to show you
the power of method overriding and how
you can override the behavior which is
defined in the base class let's get
started with exception handling in java
using try and catch blocks so in the
previous session we had a look at the
scenarios where an exception can occur
how do we
see that there's a runtime exception or
there's a checked exception or there's
an unchecked exception or there is a
custom exception
now we did not talk about how to handle
those exceptions
and now we are going to focus on the
handling part
so whenever you have to handle those
exceptions
the way java provides for that is using
the try catch block so try catch block
is basically a bunch of syntax which you
have to follow to handle different types
of exceptions in your programming code
and the syntax of the try catch block is
pretty straightforward
you write try and you put curly braces
and then you write whatever code
which might throw an exception you don't
know that but it's always safer to
enclose your code in a try catch block
so that you know that if an exception
occurs in the try block
then you can handle it in the catch
block
so it's a it's always considered a
better practice to enclose your
application code in a try catch block so
that you can handle the exceptions
so you put this try block
and write write all the suspicious or
non suspicious code which may or may not
throw an exception inside the try block
once you have done the dry block part
then comes the catch block part
so let me go to the catch block
so this is how the syntax look like once
you have written the try block then you
write catch
and you put braces
and you write the exception type
which this block of code might throw
or the exception type which you are
interested in catching
you might not be interested in catching
all the different exceptions but only a
few ones based on your business
requirements so whatever exception type
you want to catch
you are going to catch it like this
and if an exception occurs in the try
code
let's say you have specified an
arithmetic exception here and if
any line of code in the try block throws
an arithmetic exception
then this catch block is going to catch
that exception and then inside these
curly braces
you can decide what to do with that
exception
whether you want to lock that exception
or whether you want to re-throw that
exception whether you want to
embed some error code or get an error
code out of it or convert that exception
into a business or custom exception of
your own choice so it's up to you what
you want to do with that but catch block
will be able to catch that arithmetic
exception
similarly you can specify as many
exception types to be caught as you want
and keep adding more and more catch
blocks remember that these catch blocks
work in a in a sequential fashion
so if an exception occurs here it will
first go to this particular block to
match the exception type
if it didn't match then only it will
move to the second type
if it did match the first type it is not
going to execute the second type so that
is how the try catch block work
you can see an example here that if the
code here is throwing an index out of
bond exception then it is going to be
caught here
and we are just printing the index out
of one exceptions message
if it is throwing an io exception then i
can do this so you can keep adding
different checked and unchecked
exceptions in the catch block
you can also catch more than one type of
exception with one exception handler so
rather than writing these multiple catch
blocks individually you can combine
these exceptions together if your
logic of processing
both of these exceptions is the same
remember if the logic of processing
these two exceptions is the same
logic means whatever you write inside
these curly braces
so if that code is going to be the same
for both of these exceptions then why
bother writing two catch blocks
just write one catch block like this
use the pipe operator to separate
different types of exceptions
and write the common code which is going
to be applied
if your try block is going to throw an i
o exception
or an sql exception
so that depends upon you
that's the second piece
the third piece of the try block is the
final block so we talked about the try
block we talked about the catch block
now there's a finally block as well
remember this is finally and not final
the finally block is used
together with the try catch block
when you want to perform some cleanup
operations
imagine you are opening up a file
handler in the try block you're doing
something with it and then you want to
just close the file handler irrespective
of the fact if there was an exception in
the try block or not because even if
there was an exception the file handler
resource is going to remain open and is
going to consume memory in your
application you might you don't want to
do that similarly if you opened a
database connection inside your try
block
irrespective of the fact of what happens
in the try block you always would like
to close the database connection
and you can write that closing code in
the finally block that's the purpose of
the finally block that you can write the
code
inside the file block which is supposed
to be always executed
irrespective of the fact whether an
exception occurs or doesn't occur
so now we have built a good
understanding of what is the try catch
what is what is the try block catch
block and the final block now if you
just put it all together
this is how it is going to look like
that you write the try block you do
something inside the try block
then you write the catch blocks
after that you write the final block
you can write the finely block without
the catch block as well remember that if
you do not have any exception to catch
but you have some resources to close or
free up after executing the try block
you can skip the catch block and just
right try finally that is also possible
with that understanding let's switch to
the ide and let's look at some example
so i have a writer helper class
which is having a method called write
list i have a try block here
and this try block is basically
initializing an error list
adding an item to the error list
and then i'm accessing list dot get one
remember when i added this particular
value let me make it tend to make it
more understandable when i added 10 to
this particular list this goes to the
index 0 position
and here i'm trying to access index 1
position
which does not have anything
so in such case it might throw an error
because there is nothing at least not
get one so this is my method where i put
the try block code and then because
i don't want to end up in a position
where i get an index out of bond
exception index out of bonds exception
comes if you are trying to access an
index
which is illegal which is does not
having any value so i'm putting a catch
block and catching the index out of
bound exception
and just printing the message of the
exception
and then i'm for just for simplicity i'm
showing a final block as well though i
do not have any resource to close here
but this is just to show you how this
looks like in the code
this is just to show you that i'm
putting i'm printing assist out here
this is what my method is and if i go to
the main class the try catch demo class
i'm creating an object of the writer
helper class and calling the write list
method which we just walked through
let's run this program and see what
happens
okay so first i get this statement
saying entering try statement so if i go
here
i call this method
the execution goes inside the try block
and i get the cis out which says
entering try statement
then i try to access the second
element in the list because the position
is 1 this is going to index 0 and i'm
trying to access index 1 there is
nothing at index 1 so i get an error
saying index out of bounds exception
index 1
out of bounds for length 1
because the total length of the list
currently is 1 because there is just 1
element and that 1 element is sitting at
zero and not one
so i get the exception
which is the index outer bound exception
but the index outer bound exception is
caught by my catch block and the
system.error.println
is something which gets executed
and i get this particular
line this particular line
from
this
line number 17
and then irrespective of the fact
whether an exception occurred or not my
final block always gets executed
let's fix this and see if the final
block gets executed even if there is no
exception so now i'm accessing get zero
and let's see what happens
yep i access the element 10 no exception
but the final block still gets executed
so this is to assert our understanding
that the final block will always be
executed irrespective of the fact
whether there was an exception or there
wasn't now you can also nest different
try blocks if you want to
let's look at an example where i have
multiple try blocks so you can initial
you can write a try within a try within
a try if you want and you can go as deep
as you want
but remember the more
indentations the more hierarchy you
create the program is going to get more
and more complex so always remember
to have that kind of trade-off
so i write multiple try blocks i
initialize an array i print add a 10
obviously array 10 does not exist
because this array has just four
elements so this is bound to throw an
index out of bound exception and i'm
catching that exception immediately in
the catch block this is the exception
printing assist out and just re-throwing
the exception you can also read through
the exception by just using the throw
keyword remember this throw is different
from the throws keyword which comes in
the method signature this is just to
throw any exception from your code
so this is array index outer bond
exception for this try block
then i have another array index outer
bond exception for this try block
which starts from here block 2 and then
i have another catch block for the block
one try block
so you can see it is already getting a
bit complicated where i have multiple
hierarchies but you can do that
so this is what is happening in this
particular program now let's try to run
this and see what happens and try to
decipher the output
okay so at first i get this particular
line which says
array index out of bounds exception in
block 3.
what happens here is that this line gets
executed
it throws an array index out of bounds
exception
at line 13 that array index out of
bounds exception is caught
which was generated from this line
and then we go inside the catch block we
execute this is out this is what you see
here the same sysout and then we
re-throw the exception
if we re throw the exception
the exception goes to the
enclosing try block the enclosing try
block is this one
there was an exception re-thrown from
this try block
and now it has gone to this try block
and now
this try block block 2 will try to see
if it can catch this
array index out of bound exception
yes we can catch it so it can so so the
block 2 again has a catch block which
catches the array index out of bound and
it prints assist out here which says
exception in block 2
which we see here
and it again re-throws the exception
and if it rethrows the exception so now
the block two
now the block two is re-throwing the
exception so this whole code
is now re-throwing the exception
if this block two is re-throwing the
exception it goes to block one just
going one hierarchy up
and then it sees if it can handle the
exception in the catch block
of this block one so yes the block one
try block also had a catch exception
which said array index outer bound e4
and here it just had a sys out
so if i just bring back the output
yes we do get this a particular
exception printed here which says array
index out of bounds exception in block
one this is what you see here
and this is where the exception just
stops going propagated because i'm not
re-throwing the exception from this
particular catch block so that's where
the exception ends
the reason you see a hyperlink here is
because the text
the text which i have printed here
exactly matches with the name of the
exception so java is pretty smart in
that case if you use the exact same name
exception it will link it to the
matching class name in java which is
pretty cool
i also have a redundant cache block here
which does not have a try block this is
just to show you that you can write a
catch block without a try block but it
doesn't make sense it is of no use so i
can just remove this particular catch
block and the program still will compile
fine
so this was a quick demo to show you how
you can use try catch and finally blocks
and when would you use the final block
and if you want you can use a nested
hierarchy of try blocks and you can
rethrow
the exception from within the catch
block only to be caught in the outside
or the outer or the enclosing block
let's get started with array lists in
java so when we talk about error list we
are technically talking about a list i
have opened the api documentation of the
arraylist class so if we just scroll
down we will see a nice description
which is provided by java and it broadly
covers all the points which i described
in the previous session which were that
an error list is basically an
array-based implementation of a list
it's an indexed-based implementation so
you can access the elements based on
their index position you can directly
access any element if you know its index
it accepts any kind of duplicates as
well and by default it is not thread
safe if two threads are trying to
access the same collection at the same
time or may be trying to modify the
collection then you will get
inconsistent behavior so that was about
the basic description of arraylist there
are it provides lot of interesting
utility methods as well for adding
elements for adding multiple elements or
removing elements for fetching an
element from the error list and we will
cover those methods in detail in the
demo and with that maybe let's switch to
the demo so for this i have created a
class which is called arraylist demo it
has a public static void main method and
it has an error list example written
inside it so at line number 10 you see
that there is an initialization
happening for the error list and this is
how you basically initialize the array
list to start with you write the
interface name you can obviously write
arraylist as well here instead of list
you can write error list that is
absolutely acceptable but the reason i
have written list here is because it is
a better practice or i would say it is a
best practice to always initialize the
concrete implementations with the
interface type i'm making a very generic
statement which is applicable to
collections and at any other type of
classes and objects you might be
creating in your program always try to
declare it with the type of interface
and then define the concrete
implementation on the right hand side so
the lhs on the left hand side will
contain the interface declaration and
the right hand side will contain the
concrete implementation the reason for
this is that if tomorrow if you have to
change the representation of this error
list to let's say a linked list then you
don't need to do a lot of work because
the linked list is also a child of the
list interface so since list understands
and knows about both of the classes you
can interchangeably use this reference
to point to any of those implementations
that's why it is considered a best
practice to basically
write the left hand side as the
interface and the right hand side as the
concrete implementation that's the first
bit of it second interesting thing you
notice is this so you see
these
expressions here and this basically
encloses any kind of generics or class
type what are generics we will cover
this in detail in the upcoming sessions
for now what you can understand and what
you should know that these are denoting
a class type of which the objects will
be stored inside this particular list
so once i say list of integer it means
that this particular list is only going
to hold integer objects
if you try to insert a string object or
if you try to insert a character object
or if you try to insert a float object
or any other kind of object it will
create an error because
it remember in the very first lecture we
said that java is strongly typed
language
it has very strong checks for these kind
of data type mismatch so if that's why
it will expect you to specify the object
type here and whatever type you have
specified here that's the kind of
objects which are going to be stored
inside this list i have been using these
terms called classes and objects inter
interchangeably but for now what you can
understand that this is a type
how how we write classes and how we
write objects and how we create objects
again i will cover this in detail in the
upcoming sessions so we have specified
the list interface and i'm saying that
this particular variable should hold any
list of integer type then on the right
hand side i am specifying what type of
list
this error list is and this error list
will be an arraylist class type and
again i have to specify the class type
specifications and then i'm specifying a
size here this is the size of the error
list the initial size of the error list
you can obviously write it without this
as well this is also a perfectly fine
statement in java and in this case the
error list is going to be initialized
with its default size if you specify a
value then the error list will be
initialized with only that size it is
also considered a best practice to
always initialize the arrow list with a
some known initial value let's say if
the serialist is going to store only two
elements and the default size is
definitely way way bigger than two
elements then you're going to waste lot
of memories so that's why it is the best
practice to specify explicitly specify
some sort of an initial size this is
also acceptable because it is
automatically inferring the type from
the declaration you don't need to
specify it again here in fact some of
these modern ides will also show you a
warning if you write it here so the next
thing i'm going to do is basically going
to add some elements to this error list
so i've created an error list which
should hold only integer values and it
should hold to start with 5 values but
it will not complain if you try to add
the sixth value so for that i have just
written a small loop here let me just
put curly braces around it for
readability so i am saying in thai equal
to one i should be less than equal to
five i plus plus and i keep doing
arraylist dot add so this add method is
the method which is used to add elements
to the array list so whenever you have
to add an element to the error list
remember you need to use the method add
and then specify the actual element
which is supposed to be added so i'm
adding one two three four five in this
error list one by one using this loop
and then i'm just printing the whole
error list that's what i'm doing here
after that to showcase another operation
of this array list i am removing an
element and if you have to remove an
element from error list just simply
called error list dot remove and specify
the index from which you want to remove
the element remember you need to specify
the index and as i said in the beginning
this is an array based implementation so
this is going to start from 0 so when i
say remove the element at index 3
technically it's the fourth element of
the array list after that once we have
removed the element i'm again displaying
the modified error list and then
printing all the elements of the
error list one by one and for uh for
fetching the element if you see here if
you if you observe this particular for
loop i'm using couple of more
interesting methods of the error list
let's understand those methods as well
and then i will run the program so here
you see that i'm saying i int i equal to
0 and then i'm saying i less than
error list dot size
so if this error list has
a capacity initial capacity of storing
five elements and i've just added five
elements to it then the error list dot
size will be five but it says less than
so it will start from 0 and run till i
equal to 4 because the moment i becomes
5 5 is not less than 5 and it will come
out of the loop so basically i am trying
to start this loop where i i's value
starts from 0 and goes till 4 and here
i'm calling another error list method
which is used to fetch an element from
the error list so whenever you have to
get an element from the error list just
call dot get on the error list so error
list dot get and i'm specifying the i
value so arrow list dot get of 0 get off
1 get of 2 get of 3 and get of 4 and
that's technically the 5 elements which
are stored in this array arraylist so
let's run this program so and now let's
observe the outputs here let me just
bring the outputs down yeah so at first
i'm just printing the error list so
nothing nothing
i'm just adding the elements and
printing the complete error list so if
you want to just print the whole error
list just put that inside system dot out
dot print teller and the whole array
list will be printed that's line 17 then
i remove the element at index three so
if i traverse through this particular
list this is index 0 index 1 index 2 and
index 3 so index 3 has an element which
has a value 4 and i'm saying arraylist
dot remove the element at index 3. so
this particular element should be
removed from this particular list when i
call the line 20 and then if i print the
modified error list at line 24 i can see
that 4 is gone now it's only one two
three five that's the remaining list you
also need to notice that whenever i call
system.out.println with arraylist i get
this square brackets which is the
representation of an arraylist if you
don't want that you might not want that
always right if you want to print this
nicely without the square brackets then
you have to iterate over the array list
and that's what i'm doing here i'm going
from zero to error list dot size and i'm
doing get of 0 get off 1 get of 2 and
get of 3 and that's how i get these
values without 4. we can also write the
same loop using for enhanced loop so
let's say if i write
for
int i
colon array list
and then inside it i can just say system
dot out dot print ln i and if i comment
this particular loop for for a moment
and run this program
i see the values one by one because it's
ln so every output comes on on a new
line but you can pretty much see the
same output if i remove
this
and if i write it like this just adding
an extra space
it will look a bit more nice a bit more
formatted like this so as you can see
that we can get the pretty much the same
output either using a classic for loop
style which is a bit verbose or you can
use an enhanced for loop which is a much
simpler and shorter and
less verbose way of doing exactly the
same thing you don't even need to call
the arraylist.geti but i the reason i
put this example because i wanted to
show you the get functionality as well
let's get started with linked lists in
java in the previous session we talked
about error lists and today we are going
to talk about the another type of
implementation of the list interface
which is called linked list if you
remember from the previous sessions we
discussed about the properties of the
linked list and all those properties are
listed here as well so basic idea is
that whenever you want to have a kind of
implementation
where the order of the elements is
strictly maintained where the first
element can refer to the second element
the second element can refer to the
third element and so on in those kind of
cases you are going to use linked list
another property of linked list is that
you cannot randomly access an element
directly as you as you could do in case
of error list in case of error list you
just say you just write error list dot
get and you provide the index location
and you get the element right away
that's not possible in linked list in
linked list if you have to access the
let's say the second last element or the
fifth element in a 10 size element uh
list in that case you have to start from
the head which is the first element and
keep traversing till the fifth element
that's the only way possible to access
the fifth element or any random element
so that's the property of linked list it
is also not synchronized so if multiple
threads are trying to access a linked
list concurrently at least one of the
threads and and one of the threads tries
to modify the list then it must be
synchronized externally by some other
ways otherwise you will get
unpredictable results
and again this also provides a bunch of
utility methods and we will cover some
of those methods as you can see add
method for adding an element add all add
first
contains get first get lost we will
cover some of these methods in the
demonstration which follows this
particular documentation and with that
let's jump to the implementation
so i have prepared an example here for
the linked list which is called linked
list demo i've just created a class for
it and we have created a public static
void main method here and here you can
see at line number 10 i have declared a
linked list so this looks very similar
to the way we declared an error list you
see if you have notice on the lhs i have
root i have written the concrete class
and have not written the interface
reason being i am using some concrete
methods and actual methods which are
only available in the linked list class
so i am not looking at the reusability
aspect in this particular example if you
are then you have to add extra code for
it but here i'm just writing linked list
and again in this particular linked list
i'm saying that i would only store
string objects so that's why inside
these braces i write string and then i
say new link list string again i have
not specified the size so it will take
the default size as per the jvm
implementation now i have declared my
linked list and it's time to add some
elements to the link list for that i
have the method add which is available
in this linked list class which will
provide me with the capability to add
elements
so at line number 12 and line number 13
i'm adding two elements
and if you remember i told you that it
works in a reference based
implementation so at first an element a
will be added and when you try to add
element b element a's reference will be
updated to point to b
that's what will happen in this linked
list and then at line 14 i'm using
another interesting utility method of
this linked list class which says add
last
what this method does that specifically
it will add the element at the very end
of the linked list
so that was about add last and if i talk
about line 15 i'm using another
interesting method of linked list class
which is called add first
so what this will do that this is going
to insert this element d at the very
beginning of this linked list like even
before a d will be inserted so whatever
your linked list looks like whenever you
call add first
that element is going to be inserted at
the very head of the linked list or the
very beginning of the linked list linked
list also provides another variant of
the add method so there is one way to
just add the string element directly
because this is a string a linked list
you can also add it based on the
position so you can say add e at the
second position
inside the linked list so let's observe
this output let me comment all the code
below line 18 because we will be using
some more methods here so we'll cover
that in a while but let's first
understand the output at line 18 if we
run this program so right click run as
java application and this is the output
we get so let's understand the output or
maybe let me do this let me put this
here one by one so that we can interpret
the output so i'm adding two elements
and printing the list then calling add
last and printing the new list then
calling add first printing the new list
and then calling list.add2 comma e and
printing the list again so let's observe
these outputs one by one i'll comment
this and let's run this now
so if i run this particular program the
program till line 14 is executed because
rest of the code is all commented let me
comment this as well and if i run it
again yes this is the output i get so at
line 12 and 13 i've added two elements
and i print the list there are only two
elements and they are printed in the
fashion a comma b everything is good
here now let's uncomment this code and
now i'm calling add last method and i
add adding an element with string c
which should be added at the very last
of this particular list so let's see now
what happens
let me comment this one so that we only
see one list at the output
okay we see a comma b comma c so c has
been successfully added to the end of
the list
now let's interpret this particular
method which is called add first so i'm
going to uncomment this
and comment the previous out so now
there's only one cis out here so i'm
adding two elements adding c at the last
and now adding d at the very beginning
and printing out the list
let's see what happens
okay so the d has been added at the very
beginning of the list even before a so
now it looks like d comma a comma b
comma c so far so good now let's move to
this particular code and now i'm saying
add an element call called e
at the second position inside this list
remember second position so let's run
this list now this program now
so now i see d comma a if you remember
the previous output was d abc if i just
uncomment this for a while just to make
it more clearer and if i run this
program
the previous list was d comma a comma b
comma c and the new one says d a e e has
been inserted at the
position 2 so 0 1 2 position 2 has been
added with this new string e and my list
is modified now it's time to
find some interesting operations about
the removal so what happens if i try to
remove elements from this list and then
we will observe the output again so
let's say if i say list dot remove b and
so i'm saying just drop this particular
element so you can directly specify that
particular elements value and that
element will be removed from the list
and let's see what output do i get if i
just call list dot remove b and i
comment the rest of the code we should
see a new output here which should not
have b so running the program again yes
so this was the old collection and this
is the new collection from which b is
gone because i've called list dot remove
b
now you can also remove elements based
on the index position instead of
specifying the element explicitly you
can specify the index position and what
happens if i call list dot remove three
let's observe the output here as well so
i'm just going to copy paste this is out
and we'll see what output do we get if
we remove the element at third location
okay so this was the previous output
after removing b and if i called list
dot remove three so zero one two three
c is the element which is at third
location and it is gone when i call list
dot remove three c is gone and d comma a
comma e
is only remaining
now let's try to understand this
particular line which says list dot
remove first
expectedly this is going to remove the
element from the very beginning so
whatever element is present at the
beginning it is going to remove the
element and then we are going to print
the list the modified list so we were
here till d a e and d was the
element which was at the beginning and
if i called remove first d is removed
and now only a comma e is
available and now i use another
interesting method which is called list
dot remove last and then i print the
list the modified list so this is the
list remaining and i'm calling remove
last so e should be dropped and only a
should be
left in this particular list
yes we only see a here so this is
basically what i wanted to show you in
this program that we can perform
different kind of operations using
different methods like add add first add
last remove remove first remove last
obviously there are more interesting
methods available in this particular
class do check out the api documentation
for it and there you can see all the
different interesting methods which you
can use while implementing linked list
let's get started with hash set in java
if you remember i covered in the
collections framework session that has
set is part of the set interface
hierarchy and sets have a property that
they keep the collections element unique
if you try to add duplicate elements to
the asset it will not accept that and it
will still maintain the uniqueness
property of the collection hashset
provides some additional features to the
set which is that in this case the
elements would be accessed in a random
fashion they will not be accessed in a
fixed sequence rather they will be
accessed in a random fashion hence the
name hash set so if you read about this
particular class in the documentation it
will basically cover all the things
which i just described it also accepts
null elements if you want to insert null
but why would you try to insert null
that's the first question which you
should ask it again provides similar
kind of utility methods to the list
interface collection hierarchy we
covered like some utility methods to add
the elements to remove the elements to
check the size of the collection and to
check if an element exists in the
collection or not etc etc and we will
cover some of these methods in the demo
this is again not synchronized so this
is not a thread safe collection which
you should know so let's look at a
demonstration of hash set and how do we
actually create a hash set how do we
operate upon a hash set using different
utility methods
so as you can see i have created a class
here which is called hash set demo
there's a public static void main method
and then at line number 10 you will see
that i have created the hash set and
again it starts with the concrete class
here which says hash set and you can
obviously write it as set as well which
will also work fine so we write the set
type as string so this particular set is
going to hold only and only string
objects and nothing else and this set is
basically a type of hash set again this
is not mandatory so you can remove that
it will still not complain and the
program will run fine if you want to
specify a size please do that if you do
not want to specify the size nothing
goes wrong and it will be initialized
with the default memory footprint but
remember doing this wastes a bit of
memory so if you are running this
program on a machine which is really
tight on memory always put some kind of
initialization size based on your
knowledge of how many elements are going
to be stored in this collection so after
that at line number 12 we start adding
elements to this collection and for
adding the elements the method which is
provided by the hash set class is add so
you use the add method to add new
elements so at line number 12 line
number 13 14 and 15 i use the method
again and again to add some elements
if you observe the line number 14 and
the line number 15 these two lines are
adding the same element so i'm trying to
add c
twice to this particular hash set and we
will observe the output to see what
happens if we try to add duplicate
elements in the hash set because if you
remember the sets are supposed to be
unique they should not be storing
duplicate elements that's the property
of sets so that's what i demonstrate by
by adding duplicate elements to see how
it behaves and let's do that let me
comment the rest of the code for a while
and let's run just this part of the code
where i add c twice and i print the hash
set and let's see what happens
so i go to run as and i click on java
application and i only see three
elements even though i added four i only
see three and c has been added only once
not twice
now you might be wondering whether the c
is
the c added at line 14 or the c added at
line 15. so
to understand that we need to understand
how hash sets add method works
so this add method is basically
returning a boolean value if the element
is added successfully this ad is going
to return true and if the element could
not be added successfully this add
method is going to return false so let's
do that let's store the result of these
add methods let's call this r1 and let's
call this one as r2
okay and now we will try to print r1 and
r2 and see
what happens
so if we write system dot out dot
println and i say r1 and then i just
copy this
after line 16
and write r2 and now we will observe the
output of these to see which
when
we did the add at 14 and when we did the
adder 16 which actually resulted in c
getting added did c get overwritten or
did c did not add twice what happens
so we see that uh when we do the add at
line 14 we get true so it means that
this ad was successful and c was added
here and when i did the add again at
line 16 this returned a false it means
the hash set rejected this add operation
so this c was not added so the actual c
was never overwritten the original c was
maintained and when you try to add a
duplicate value with the same value a
duplicate element with the same value
hashtag is going to reject that
so that actually
proves that the set will maintain the uh
the uniqueness property and it will
reject all the duplicates subsequently
that was about the ad
property now let's understand another
interesting property of the contains
method contains method of the set class
is used to find if an element exists in
the set or not so you can just use the
hash set variable name dot contains and
just type the actual element and this is
going to return true or false based on
whether this element is present in the
hash set or not present in the hash set
if it is present then this contains
method is going to return true otherwise
it is going to return false
so let's run this method and observe the
output at line 21.
so it says list we are writing this
particular string which says does list
contain c or not and it returns true
because yes my hash set does contain c
now coming to line 23 i use another
method of the hash set which is the
remove operation which you can use to
remove an element from the set and then
i'm again doing ssout and i'm asking
the to print the set this should be set
and not list so then i'm checking if uh
what happens to my hash set if i call
the remove method and i'm just printing
the modified hash set at line 24. so
let's see what happens with the effect
of remove operation okay so after
removing a this is what remains in my
hash set and a has been successfully
dropped if i call the remove method and
then i try to just iterate over the hash
set to show you how does this iteration
work it again works on exactly the same
way it has been working for the list
implementations that on the rhs of this
column you write the collection name so
hash set and on the lhs of this colon
you write the representation of the
element so this hash set is going to
contain string and this is just a
placeholder it can be anything this is
just a temporary variable to store the
current value at the current step of the
hash set iteration and i'm printing all
the items one by one
so if i run this
i'm able to print b and c because that's
all which is remaining in this hash set
so this was a very quick demo to show
you the functionalities of the hash set
how does hash set maintains uniqueness
how do you remove elements how do you
add elements how do you check for an
element's existence using contains
there's also a method to get the element
of the headset if you want to so these
are all the different properties and
methods available in the hash set and do
check check out the api documentation of
the hash set to learn about more methods
let's get started with three sets in
java so in the previous session we
talked about about hash set which is one
of the implementation of the set
hierarchy and today we'll be focusing on
preset and if you remember when we
talked about this collection framework i
discussed briefly about preset that the
main reason you will use tree set is
basically when you want to maintain
natural ordering of the elements if
you're adding your custom elements then
you need to tell java how to compare and
sort and order the elements but that's
for another day when we'll cover about
the detailed comparable and comparator
interfaces for now what you can
understand that whenever you have to
maintain the natural order of the
elements automatically then you should
use preset along with that the set
property still holds true that this tree
set cannot have duplicate elements
we should also know that tree set is not
synchronized so it is not a thread safe
collection so be remember be aware that
whenever you are trying to use preset in
a multi-threaded environment you need to
write more wiring code around it so that
preset works as expected okay that was
about the brief theory about the preset
you can read about
about it in detail in this tree set
documentation class and with that let's
switch to a demonstration of the tree
set class
so i have prepared a class here which is
called reset demo as you can see it has
a public static void main method and at
line number eight i'm initializing the
reset again it's again the standard
representation of initializing a
collection which we have been using
throughout the different examples of the
collections so preset of string so this
particular preset is going to hold only
and only string elements if you try to
add another element it is going to
through a compilation error and the on
the rhs i'm just saying new tree set and
again this is not mandatory so i can
remove that and it will still work you
can specify the size whenever you know
about the scope of the collection you
should always specify the size for this
demonstration it's a lightweight program
so it's fine
after that from line number 10 till line
number 13 i'm again going to add some
elements and again if you see i'm adding
elements in random order i'm adding b
and then i'm adding adding a then i am
adding c twice just to show you the
uniqueness property of the tree set does
it still hold true or not we will be
able to figure that out from this
particular example and we will also see
if i am adding b before a will it be
printed in a fashion called bac or will
it be printed in a fashion called abc we
should also know that so let's try to
run this program and understand the
output
so if we look at the output we see a
before b
but here when we added the elements we
saw b before a we added b first and then
we added a and then we added c twice and
as for the uniqueness property of this
set the second
addition statement at line number 13
returned false and set rejected this
edition because it could see that c was
already present in this particular
collection so c is added only once but
what's interesting is that b is added
first but b is added b is printed after
a so the natural order of the elements
in this collection is automatically
maintained by tree set so what under the
hood reset does here that it looks at
the type which is a predefined type in
java string is a predefined class in
java so it will use its own sorting
algorithm to sort the strings based on
their natural order of sequence and in
the natural order of sequence a will
always come before b and b will always
come before c so it will automatically
apply that sorting and will present the
result to you if you're using a custom
class here let's say your own student
class or your own customer class or your
own account class in that case that
account class or student class or
customer class needs to tell java how to
sort elements and for that you need to
write comparable and comparator
implementations which we will cover in
detail in the future sessions but for
now you must understand that whatever
the type of class you are specifying
here should
tell java how to sort the elements
either java should know it automatically
if it's a predefined class like string
or integer or float or double then java
would automatically know by default how
to sort the elements but if you are
creating a custom class of yours in the
tree set and specifying that as a tree
set type then you should also tell java
how to sort the customers whether you
want to sort them based on your first
name whether you want to sort them based
on their age their salary java doesn't
know that so you need you need to tell
java about that if you're trying to use
a custom class as the type entry set in
this particular example i'm using string
here and it will apply the natural
ordering
let's put c here in the very beginning
to see what happens and i can comment
this as we have already maintained and
verified that c is only printed once and
added once so i'm adding c b a and let's
run this program
i still get abc because again the
natural order is implemented contrary to
this when we talked about hash set
remember i told that hash set is a
random access
element collection list so if you run
the hash set if you try to print the
hash set again and again and again you
might see a different order sometimes if
i use a hash set here sometimes it will
print abc sometimes it will print bac
sometimes it might print cab any kind of
sequence any kind of random sequence it
will pick automatically that's the
property of hash set but in case of tree
set no matter how many times you run it
you will always get the same order based
on the sorting implementation available
in the class type so that's all i wanted
to cover about preset please read about
read about its java documentation in the
api docs to understand what all other
methods and utilities tree set provides
but it's pretty much similar to what we
saw in the headset example like remove
or get etc etc and contains etc so all
this all similar methods are available
in the tree set class as well and that's
all we'll focus on on this particular
session and in the next session we're
going to talk about an interesting
framework called maps let's get started
with maps in java
so first of all before we understand
this particular diagram and the classes
in this map framework let's understand
why do we need map
so
there would be instances when you would
write a java program or any kind of
program there would be always be
instances where you would need to store
a key value kind of arrangement a very
simple example can be that you want to
maintain a company database and you want
to just bring the whole mapping of the
employee id to the employee name into
the java program
how do you do that you need a key value
sort of arrangement where you can store
the employee id as the keys
and each of the employee id key would
correspond to an employee name which
will be called the value so you need a
key and value
arrangement in a java program to store
that kind of information and use that
kind of information in your program and
that's where map comes into picture
whenever you have to store a key value
arrangement remember you would always
think about maps maps should be the
right collection or the right data
structure to be used if you want to
store any key value arrangement in your
program so that's about map and here you
can see a nice framework representation
of map and this is going to be a
theoretical lecture where we will
understand how this map framework works
what is the property and what are the
different implementation classes and
then in the future sessions we will
again look at some examples of the most
popular map implementation classes which
are used in the java world
so again uh the orange oval are
interfaces the blue boxes or the light
blue boxes are the abstract classes and
the purple boxes are the concrete
classes so map is an interface which
will provide this kind of a blueprint
that every class underneath it would be
working on a key value arrangement when
we talk about this key value arrangement
so we have these keys and we have the
values
so the keys here
are supposed to be unique the values can
contain duplicates
remember this is a very important
concept that in map the keys will be
unique and the values can have duplicate
and because we want to maintain the
uniqueness in the keys part that's why
the keys are technically stored as a set
because we know that set cannot contain
duplicate sets are by designed made to
be storing only unique elements so map
uses the set class to store its keys and
to store the values it generally uses a
list class so you can see map is
basically reusing
the classes from the collections
framework sets for storing the keys and
lists for storing the values that's the
basic anatomy and basic idea of how map
is working now you see some classes here
called abstract map and sorted map and
again similar to the set hierarchy
whenever you see the sorted world and if
you look at the
concrete class which is called tree map
this is going to provide you some sort
of an order sorting order automatically
and then you have the hash map class and
this class is going to be providing a
random access this will not maintain the
insertion order this will not provide
you a natural sorting order this is just
to store elements in random order and
the element here a single element here
is basically consisting of two parts
which is key and value always remember
that you also have hash table here hash
table is basically a synchronized
representation this is a thread safe
hash map and tree map are non-thread
safe so multiple threads if you try to
work in a multi-threading program with
these hash map and pre-map you're going
to get very unpredictable results but if
you use hash table then it is inherently
thread safe so it will only allow one
thread to be to access the hash table at
a particular time
you will also you will also be thinking
then it's always better to use hash
table right because
you will never get into those weird
errors and you don't have to migrate
your program
to a multi-threaded environment whenever
you are trying to use hash tables yes
that is true but hash tables are slower
for the same reason because only one
thread can
can access it at a time and that's why
hash tables are slower and hashmap and
treemap are way way faster because they
allowed multiple access at the same time
so you have to always
be mindful of what kind of collection
type you're using there are some
external ways as well to make these hash
maps and tree maps and hash set and
preset and
array list and link list as synchronized
as well and we will talk about that in a
future session but for now you can
understand that hash map entry map are
non-thread safe and hash table
are thread safe there's another class
which is
which is coming out from the hash map
class which is called linked hash map
and linked hash map as the name shows it
will basically carry two properties it
will carry the property of hash map
where the elements are stored or
displayed or accessed in random order
and at the same time it is also
providing the linked property of the
linked list where the sequence is
maintained so you can see you can
actually get the insertion order if you
use a linked hash map the way in which
you insert the elements would always be
the way in which the elements will be
accessed so you are getting sort of a
ordering property but the order is the
insertion order it's not the natural
sort order it's the insertion order
that's why the name linked hash map
because it brings the linked list part
of the link property inside the hash map
where the elements would be presented to
you in the order they are inserted when
you call the add method so that's what
we covered here we covered about map
interface we covered about hash map
class which is going to store the values
and the access will be random the value
means uh the element means a key and
value we sometime also call this as an
element you will see that representation
sometimes some some people also call it
as i table element it's all the same
thing but it's a key and value
arrangement pre-map also stores the key
value arrangement but it will provide
you a sorted representation
and here the salting will happen on the
keys
not on the values the salting will be
happening the natural order of salt
which will be maintained by the tree map
is only applicable to the keys here
similarly link hash map it will insert
the elements but when you try to access
it it will maintain the insertion order
no matter how many times you access it
it will only be presented to you in the
order the elements were inserted and
hash table is very similar to hash map
with the difference that hash table is
thread safe multiple threads cannot
manipulate the hash table at a time it
will only let a single thread access
itself at a time so that's the property
of hash table the most popular classes
are generally these ones hash map tree
map and link hash map very rarely you
will also see hash table but since we
have some
ways to
get these synchronized so generally you
would not see much of the hash table
implementation let's get started with
hash maps in java
in the previous session i covered about
the theoretical concepts of map and the
key value arrangement and the keys being
basically are set and the values
basically being a list
and now we are looking at the api
documentation of the hashmap class you
can see the k comma v here these are the
types of the key and the value which the
hash map will accept you can see k is
basically the type of keys and v is
basically the type of mapped values
uh like i explained it's basically keys
are stored in a set fashion and values
are stored in a list collection fashion
this is not by default synchronized so
if you want a thread safe collection
then you would have to do something else
which i will cover in the future
sessions
this is a very brief overview of what
hash map is but let's look at the
example to understand better and then i
will be able to explain it in bit more
detail so now we are looking at an
example which is basically a class which
is called hash map demo i have a main
method here and then at line number 10
i am initializing the map
and as you can see that on the lhs we
see the concrete class hash map and i
can do this
and this will still work provided you
have the import here i had the import
here so it will work fine and i am
saying that this map is going to contain
a key value arrangement where the keys
are the string type
and the values are of the type integer
and it's ultimately a hash map here i i
don't need to again provide the generics
because i have already provided the
generics here
the name of the map is just simply a map
and again you can specify your size or
you can skip the size based on the
memory requirements and the program
requirements
now coming to the point where you want
to add elements to the map now since
this is a key value arrangement here the
name of the method through which you are
going to add elements is put so you call
map.put
and then you provide the key
comma you provide the value
that's the syntax for adding an element
or we technically call that element an
entry this key value together is called
entry so if you have to add an entry to
the map you have to write it in this way
where key comma value is the convention
so i'm adding three elements or three
entries here which is
a comma 10 b comma 20 and c comma 30 abc
are basically the keys and 10 20 and 30
are the corresponding values of these
keys respectively
after that i'm i'm showcasing another
utility method of this particular class
which you can use to find the size of
the map so you can just call map dot
size and it will print the size of the
map
after that i'm printing the actual map
the whole map and then i'm using some
more methods but again let's comment
this code and let's understand this code
one by one so that there is no confusion
so to start with i'm going to add some
elements some entries and i'm going to
print the size of the map and the map
itself let's run this program
so here
you can see the size of the map is
printed as three because i have added
three entries and then when i call map
inside the
system.out.println method
i get the whole map printed here and
this is how the map will look like when
it is printed we can see key equal to
value syntax here where a equal to 10
b equal to 20 and c equal to 30 are the
key value representations or the entries
here separated by comma enclosed by the
curly braces
that's how our map looks like so far so
good the next thing which i am going to
showcase to you is the contains method
and since the map has this set which is
the keys basically that's why map
provides a method called contains key
basically you can check if a particular
key is present in the map or not and if
you know the key is present then it's
very easy to get the value from the key
map will provide a method also where you
can supply the key and get the value so
knowing the key is the most important
part and that's why map provides a
method called contains key so you can
call this method specify the key which
you want to check for the presence in
the map it is going to check whether a
is present in this maps key set or not
if the a is available in this keys we
can see a is available then this
condition is going to hold true and then
like i said if you want to fetch the
value then you can call the get method
providing the key you can fetch the
value from the key that's the that's the
core idea which you should remember so i
call map.get specify the key and this is
going to spit out the value which is
being pointed by this particular key in
this case a is pointing to 10 when i say
pointing it's not pointer remember it's
just a reference so map dot get of a is
going to get the actual value which this
key is pointing to which is 10 and then
i am printing this integer a which is
the actual value pointed by this
particular key so let's run this program
and see if this works
so we get these two outputs from the
above and then this is the output which
is coming from the if block
so it checked whether the map is
containing a key with the name a yes it
was able to find that and then we asked
the java program to fetch the value
corresponding to this particular key so
we just called map dot get off a and it
fetched 10 and it printed 10 here that's
why you see 10 here okay so that's how
you can basically use the contains key
method and the get method now what if
you want to iterate over all the keys
what if you
what if you have to use
the
all the keys and you have to make some
pattern or make some observation about
all the keys in your map you can do that
by iterating over the key set and for
that map provides a method called key
set so you just call map.keyset and this
is going to fetch all the keys
in a set representation and will be
provided to you so here when i call
map.keyset this is basically giving me a
set which is containing all the keys and
then i'm iterating over the keys one by
one you would be familiar with this
syntax by now which is the enhanced for
loop syntax and inside this i'm printing
the key which is the current temporary
variable holding the current key and the
value pointed by that particular key at
that particular step and i'm again using
the same method get which is which i
showed you
here
same method so you provide the key and
you will get the value so i'm going to
get all the keys hydrate over the keys
and then print the key and the value
let's see how this looks like
so till this we were good and here you
will see the output which is coming out
from this particular for loop from this
particular for loop line 25 to line 27
where i'm iterating over the key set
printing the key and value one by one so
this is how to show you if you just have
access to the key set you can still
hydrate over the whole map but what if
you know everything you have access to
the key set you have access to the
values and if you was if you just want
to iterate over it then you can use this
particular
way and instead of map dot key set
you're going to use map dot entry set if
you remember map treats each key value
arrangement as a single entry entry is
the keyword here so map dot entry set is
going to give me all the entries in the
map
and then
each entry is basically of type entry
class
this is the representation of each entry
and we know how this representation
formed entry is the class basically
which is coming out of this map
collection hierarchy and then let me
just save this and then string is the
key and integer is the value held by
each entry inside the map so that's what
we are going to do we are going to pick
up all the entries in the map and going
to iterate over the entries one by one
by writing this enhanced for loop and
entry is the temporary variable which is
going to hold each entry one by one at
each step and then it's very simple you
call entry dot get key you will get the
key and you call entry dot get value and
you will get the value so it's much much
simpler than this one where you had to
do map.get to understand it's very
implicit get key is going to get you the
key and get value is going to get you
the value so you just need to call
map.entry set hydrate over the entry set
and get each entries key and value and
print them or do whatever your program
requires to be done that's how you will
use it so let's run this one as well to
verify if this works okay so this is the
output which is coming from the last
loop this loop basically you can see key
i did not put any space that's why you
see key a eb and key c together let me
put a space here and put a hyphen so
that the output looks better and let me
rerun this yep this is much better so
you can see the key a value 10 kb value
20 and key c value 30. this is coming
from this particular for loop which i
just showed you so this is all i wanted
to cover in this particular session we
went deeper into the hash map
representation and we saw a bunch of
methods contains key key set entry set
get put etc and we showed how we can use
the hashmap for different purposes in
the program let's get started with three
maps in java now if you remember in the
last lecture we talked about hash maps
in java and we also had a look at an
example where we saw how a hash map
works and how we can use a hash map we
also had a look at different utility
methods of the hash map as well now in
today's lecture we are going to focus on
tree maps which is an another type of
map as we discussed when we were
discussing about the map framework and
the main property of a tree map is that
when you enter elements into a map they
will naturally be sorted or naturally be
ordered now when i say naturally ordered
what it means that if you put the
keys as let's say integer
then the tree map will automatically
sort all the map entries in an integer
sorted fashion where you'll see the
natural number sorting behavior like 1 2
3 and so on similarly if you store
alphabets or strings then they then
those will be sorted in a natural
sorting alphabetical order starting from
a to z so these are the uh these are the
data types which the java is already
aware of on how to sort them like
integers doubles floats strings etc but
there can be a case where you have your
custom key this particular key is your
own custom class if that is the behavior
or if that is the scenario then in that
case you will have to provide an
implementation to java to know how to
sort those elements because java doesn't
know for example a student class or an
account class java doesn't know how to
sort that so if you have that kind of
scenario then in those cases you will
have to provide your own sorting
implementation and we will cover about
what kind of sorting implementation you
can provide in those kind of scenarios
in the upcoming lectures for now we will
look at have a look at an example of
tree map where you can see that i have
created a class which is called tree map
demo and i have initialized a tree map
with the keys as integer and the values
as string so this means that each entry
of the map will have key as the integer
value and the value of that particular
entry will be of string type so
basically an integer to string mapping
is what each entry of this tree map is
going to store so nothing different here
you would have already seen this kind of
this kind of initialization for any kind
of map and after that at line 11 i use
the standard put method of the map and i
i started storing the values so at line
11 i'm saying store 3 and a so 3 is the
key
and string a remember this is not a
character this is a string because i
have specified string here if you
specify a character here and if you try
to store a string this is going to throw
an error and you need to fix that so i
store 3 as the key and a as string as
the value similarly at line 12 i store 2
as the key and
b as the value and at line c i store 1
as the key and c as the value so these
integers are the keys and the string are
the values
and if i just put them and if i just try
to print them what happens
what kind of order can we expect
let's try to analyze that so i right
click on this i go to run as
and i go to run as java application
it will run the program because i have a
static void main method and now you see
that the map is printed in a different
fashion
than the way it was added we added the
map elements in this sequence that we
added 3a first 2b second and 1c as the
third element
but when we started printing them we saw
one c printed first to be printed second
and three c 3a printed third so what
this denotes that this tree map because
the key was integer here it
automatically
sorted these keys into a natural order
sorting and it provided when i tried to
access the map it provided the access in
that sorted sequence only no matter how
many times you run this particular
program it is always going to return the
map in the same format in the same
sequence the sequence of representation
of the elements is not going to change
and you can basically do the similar
behavior for example if i just
change this to string and integer let's
do it like this
and if i again swap the elements here as
well i say a comma 3 and i say b comma 2
and here i can say c comma 1. if i do
this i just switch the keys in values
position now the string is the key and
the integer is the value and let me just
put these two
before a
so that
we can demonstrate the behavior of the
tree map properly so i'm inserting b two
first and c one second and a three third
and i just save this file and now let's
run this file and let's see how the
output comes so now you can see that
since the key is now string it has
applied it has automatically applied the
natural sorting ordering of strings
which is starting from a going till z
and that's why you see a entry as the
first entry b entry as a second entry
and the c entry as the third entry again
no matter how many times you run it or
you hydrate over it you try to access it
you will always get the sequence in the
same fashion so this is a basic overview
of how tree maps work now you can and i
would strongly recommend you to go and
read about all the other methods which
are available in the tree map which you
can use for example how can you remove
elements how can you uh how can you
iterate the elements of the tree map etc
in fact the iteration is is going to be
exactly the same way as we have seen in
the case of hash maps because iteration
behavior doesn't change but to uh if you
want to see what all different kinds of
methods pre-map support it supports a
lot of different methods we can't cover
all of them in this short tutorial but i
would strongly recommend you to go and
read the javadocs api of the tree map to
get familiar with those methods so that
you know what kind of functionalities
pre-map can provide
so the first question what exactly is a
servlet
now imagine you're searching for some
information on the internet
you open your local browser and start
typing it
this question from you to the internet
is called as request
so further this request is sent to the
cloud or in technical terms your browser
sends your request to the respective
server responsible for storing for that
particular information and helps you
with it when requested now the server
gets triggered with your request and in
written it helps you back with the
information you have requested for this
answer from the server is called the
response
so this is how the request and response
work in a server for this process to
happen so smoothly and effectively we
need a servlet digging a little deep
into the server we find the component
responsible for such an effective job it
is called the servlet container that
holds java based web application and a
set of individual components called as
servlets now we are close to our answer
so this particular java based component
takes care of web requests and response
to sum it up with the form of a
definition
we can define it as follows
a servlet is a java program that runs on
the java enabled web server or
application server
they are used to handle the request
obtained from the web server process the
request produce the response and then
send a response back to the web server
now hoping that it was a clear
explanation can we move ahead with the
next topic
so the next topic we have is so how does
the servlet work in reality or more
practically or in depth what's the life
cycle of a servlet
so the life cycle of a servlet in real
time has the following stages
these stages are the ones that a java
servlet actually follows in real life to
get our work done so the stages are in
it service
and
the crud operations which are the get
post put delete and finally
destroy now let us understand each one
of them in a bit more detail
the first one is the init process
the init method is called only once it
is called only when the servlet is
created and not for all the requests
afterwards so it is used for the
one-time initializations just as with
the init method of applets the servlet
is normally created when a user first
invokes a url corresponding to the
servlet but you can also specify the
servlet is loaded when the server first
started when a user invokes a servlet a
single instance of each servlet gets
created with each user request resulting
in a new thread that is handed over to
the do get or do post as appropriate
the init method simply creates or loads
some data that will be used throughout
the lifecycle of a servlet followed by
the init method we have the service
method
so what is service method
surface method is the main method to
perform the actual task the servlet
container that is the web server calls
the service method to handle request
from the client or the browser and to
write the formatted response back to the
client each time the server receives a
request from the servlet the server
spawns a new thread and calls service
the service method checks the http
service type and accordingly performs
the crud operations which are the get
post put delete etc and calls do get do
post do put do delete etc methods as
appropriate
the service method is called by the
container and service method invokes do
get do post do put and do delete etc
methods as appropriate so you have
nothing to do with service method but
you overwrite either with do get do post
and other types depending on what type
of request you receive from the client
so this is how the init and service
methods work now digging a little deeper
we have the do get do post do delete and
do put methods
so first we will discuss about do get
method so what exactly does a do get
method do a get request results from a
normal request from a url or an html
form that has no method specified and it
should be hardly by do get method
followed by doget we have
do post a do post request results from a
html form that specifies list post as
the method and it should be handled by
do post method similar to to get and do
post the do put and do delete options
are usually used to update and delete
the data
when asked by the client
so to sum up these do get do post do put
do delete we can consider them as crud
operations so do get basically gets the
information what you're looking for do
post method usually post the information
or provides you with the response from
the server and followed by that we have
the do put which is usually used to
update the data which is present on your
server and finally delete which is used
to delete an existing data on your
server so these can be considered as
crud operations
and finally we arrive at the last method
which is the destroy method
the destroy method is called only once
at the end of the life cycle of a
servlet this method gives your servlet a
chance to close database connections
halt background threads write cookie
list or hit accounts to the disk and
performs other such cleanup activities
so with this we finish up the life cycle
of a servlet now we shall understand its
architecture
basically the architecture of a servlet
can be understood by reverse engineering
the life cycle of a servlet so this is
how the servlet execution takes place
when a client or a browser makes a
request to the web browser
so the servlet architecture includes the
following first one servlet interface
to write a servlet we need to implement
the servlet interface servlet interface
can be implemented directly or
indirectly by extending generic servlet
or http servlet class
followed by that the next part is
request handling methods as we have
discussed before there are mainly three
methods defined in servlet interface
which are init
service and destroy and inside service
we have do put do post do get and do
delete methods the first time a servlet
is invoked the init method is called it
is called only once during the life
cycle of a servlet so we can put all
your initialization code here the
service method is used for handling the
client request as the client request
reaches the container it creates a
thread of servlet object and request and
response object are also created
these request and response objects are
then passed as parameter to the service
method which then processes the client
request the service method in turn calls
the do get do post methods if the user
has extended the class from http servlet
and lastly the creation of instances
this is based on the load of the servlet
so with this we have finished the
architecture of servlet moving further
we shall quickly discuss the features of
servlets and then enter into the
practical mode
so the following are the features of
java servlets the first feature is java
servlets are portable in nature as i
have mentioned above the servlets use
java as programming language
since java is a platform independent
programming language the same holds true
for servlets for example you can create
a servlet on windows operating system
that uses glassfish as a web server and
then later run it on any operating
system like unix linux and apache tomcat
web server this feature makes tablet
portable and this is the main advantage
of servlet over cgi we shall discuss all
the differences of cgi versus servlet in
the next section for now we will discuss
the features
followed by the first feature we will
now enter into the second feature which
says java servlets are efficient and
scalable once a server is deployed and
loaded onto a web server it can
instantly start fulfilling the request
of the clients the web server invokes
servlet using lightweight thread so
multiple client requests can be
fulfilled by servlet at the same time
using the multi-threading feature of
java
compared to cgi where the server has to
initiate a new process for every client
request the servlet is truly efficient
and scalable the next and the final
feature of java servlets is they are
robust and highly secure by inheriting
the top features of java such as garbage
collector exception handling java
security manager etc the servlet is less
prone to memory management issues and
memory leaks
this makes the development of web
applications and servlets secure and
less error prone so these were the
important features of java servlets now
let us enter the practical mode
so we are in the practical mode right
now there were two parts in the
practical mode the first one was to set
up the environment for java servlets and
the second one was to execute a basic
program
so this document has the following steps
to follow
that is the prerequisites before
executing a java servlet program
so we have these prerequisites where we
have to set up java home
and java path followed by that we need
to set up the home and path for jre
which is the java runtime environment
and finally catalina home and path so
catalina home and path is nothing but
the tomcat server home and path
now we will set up these things by using
the environment variables now i'm using
a windows operating system so i'll be
using the control panel to enter the
environment variables
there you go you have edit environment
variables
so inside that just select environment
and inside this you can see that i have
already set up the environment variables
for catalina home java home and jru home
so now let us just select java home and
edit it so that we can see how did i set
it
so you can see i have named the variable
name as java home and inside the
variable value i have a location so this
location is nothing but the java jdk
location in my local system
now followed by that we have jre home so
similar to java whom we have set up the
jre home as variable name is equals to
jre home and the variable value is the
location of gre folder in my local
system so i have my jre folder in my
local system at c drive program files
java jre
and similarly the catalina home
which is inside my program files apache
software foundation and tomcat 8.5
so similarly we'll also check up the
path variables so inside system
variables you can see the path just
edited so then you can see the path
variable set for
java
jre and tomcat
now just select okay
okay and finally another okay
now your prerequisites have been set up
so this is how you set them so in case
if you have doubts about the tomcat
version to download then i'll help you
with that just open google
and type in tomcat download
so now you have entered apache tomcat
official site and since i'm using a
windows operating system i'll be
selecting the 32-bit or 64-bit windows
service installer version
and after this gets downloaded you need
to set up the home and path variables
for catalina server
so once after the environment is set up
you need to follow four stages to create
a servlet program which are creating a
dynamic web project create a servlet add
servlet api jar file and run the servlet
so to create a dynamic web project you
need to select new and inside that you
have
the option of other just select other
and inside that you'll be finding web
so select web and inside that you need
to select the dynamic web project and
select next
so you just need to name to your dynamic
web project so i'll be
naming a server
then select next
and inside that you have a source folder
and now you can select finish
now there you go java eclipse will ask
you for opening this particular in java
ee perspective
then just select open perspective
now basically java will set up
everything you need here
and there you go you can see
server folder here which has already set
up everything you need now what you need
to do is set up a new servlet
so right click this
and select new
and inside that you can see the option
of servlet just select it
now you can see a new dialog box and
here you need to set up the class name
for now let's just type in hello and go
to next
now again next
and in here you have a lot of options
so for now we are just executing a basic
program so let's just select do get
method
now let's just finish it
and there you go your servlet has been
ready so this is the basic template
created by eclipse for you now next we
need to add in the build path
so for that you need to right click the
server
and then
select build path
and here configure build path
from here you can add the external
library select the external libraries
option and you can see i have the tomcat
libraries here just select all and open
and that's how you add all the required
libraries of tomcat server now apply and
close
now the last step is to execute the
project now just to save time i have
already typed in the program
which is over here
now let's try to execute this
this program will just provide us a
simple output which is none other than
hello world
now the server i have choose this tomcat
server
let's finish it
so there you go the message has been
displayed successfully hello welcome to
simply learn
now we'll move ahead with our next topic
now that we are done with the
environment setup and the basic example
let us now discuss the advantages and
disadvantages of using java servlets
so first we will discuss the advantages
the following are the advantages of
using servlets in java
servlet is convenient in modifying
regular html
we can write the servlet code into jsp
so let's include the feature of
multi-threading of java
we can make use of exception handling of
java
servlets have a separate layer for
business logic in the application and
finally it is easy for developers to
show and process the information so
these were the advantages of using
servlets in java moving ahead we will
discuss the disadvantages of using
servlets
so following are the disadvantages of
using servlets in java
designing a servlet is considered as a
little complicated so let's often slow
down the application
business logic of servlet is difficult
to understand we need a jre which is the
java runtime environment on the server
to run our servlets and finally the data
connectivity is a little complicated so
these were the major disadvantages of
using servlets and java
moving ahead we will understand cgi
why are we learning cgi because even cgi
is similar to servlets and it also does
the web interactive jobs similar to
servlets so thought you should know
about some basics of it so let's
understand its definition and
architecture real quick so the cgi or
common gateway interface is a standard
for writing programs that can interact
through a web server with a client
running on web browser
these programs allow a web developer to
deliver dynamic information usually in
the form of an html via the browser a
cgi program can be written in any
language including java that can be
executed by your web server cgi programs
are commonly used to add search engines
guest book applications database query
engines interactive user forums and
other interactive applications to
websites in very basic terms a cgi
program must interpret the information
sent to it process the information in
the same way and generate response that
will be sent back to the client
most of the input of cgi program is
passed into through environment
variables so with this we will move
ahead into the architecture of common
gateway interface
so you can see the architecture of
common gateway interface is completely
similar to servlet normally the request
is sent in the form of an http request
so this particular http request is
divided amongst the cgi shells and it
will be processed by the cgi shells
based on the program provided and the
response is sent to the user now moving
ahead we shall understand the
differences between the common gateway
interfaces and
the servlet so the first difference is
the common gateway interface scripts are
executable codes written in native
operating system while on the other hand
the servlets are written and run using
the java virtual machine
the next difference is the common
gateway interface performance is
considered to be low compared to
servlets on the other hand servlets are
having high performance compared to
cgi's
the third difference is
for a common gateway interface it is
hard to switch between different
platforms that is the operating system
platforms
when we come into servlets the servers
are considered to be completely platform
independent
followed by that the common gateway
interface scripts are directly executed
so on the other hand servlets are
translated into bytecode because the
servlets are executed using the java
virtual machine and in java virtual
machine whatever the code you transfer
it will be converted into bytecode first
then executed and the last difference is
the common gateway interface is not
portable and on the other hand we have
the java servlets to be completely
portable so these are the major
differences between the common gateway
interface and java servlets now let us
understand the java servlets requests
and responses so first we will deal with
the request phase in request we have
various types the first one is being the
http request the http object is used to
represent the http request to a browser
that the user sends to the web
application thus anything the browser
sends is accessible through the http
request followed by the http request we
have the request parameter the request
parameters are the parameters that are
sent from the web browser along with the
request the request parameters are
typically sent as a part of the url or
as a part of the body of an http request
followed by the request parameter we
have the request header the request
headers are the name value pairs sent by
the browser along with the http request
the request headers contain the
information about the web browser
software being used what type of files
that the web browser can receive etc
followed by the request header we have
the input stream if the browser sends an
http post request request parameters and
other potential data is sent to the
server in the http request body it
doesn't have the request parameters that
is sent in http request body it could be
pretty much as the data like file or
soap request the next one is a request
session the session object can hold
information about a given user between
the request so if you have set an object
into the session object during one
request it will be available for you to
read during any subsequent request
within the same session time scope
followed by the request session we have
the servlet context the servlet context
contains the metadata related to the
application followed by servlet context
we will enter the response phase in the
response phase we will deal with the
first one which is the http response the
http response object is used to
represent the http response to your
request a web application sends back a
response page to the user as a response
to the http request from the browser
sent to your web application
followed by the http response we have
the right html to initiate the process
of sending the html back to the browser
you need to retrieve the print writer
from the http response object
this can be done using the right html
followed by the write html we have the
response header similar to http request
the http response includes headers as
well these are responsible for all the
data written in the response followed by
response header we have content type the
content type header is responsible to
tell the browser about the type of
content you are sending in the return
followed by content type we have the
content length the content length header
is responsible for telling you about the
number of bytes your server is sending
you in return followed by content length
we have redirection redirecting will
help you to redirect yourself to the
different web page from the current one
so these were the http requests and
responses in java servlets now we will
enter the next part where we will deal
with the session tracking and cookies so
first we will understand session
tracking session simply means a
particular time of interval session
tracking is a way to maintain state or
data belonging to a user it is also
known as session management and servlets
http protocol is stateless so we need to
maintain state using session tracking
techniques each time the user requests
to the server the server reads the
request as a new request so we need to
maintain the state of a user to
recognize a particular user you can
understand this in a better way by
looking at the picture shown on the
presentation each time you send a
request you will be receiving a response
from the server as well as this
particular request will be recorded as a
state in order to recognize you as a
particular user now after session
tracking we will enter into cookies
cookie is a small piece of information
that is persisted between multiple
client requests
a cookie has a name a single value and
optional attributes such as comment path
and domain qualifiers a maximum age and
a version number by default each request
is considered as a new request in cookie
technique we add a cookie with response
from the servlet so cookie is stored in
cash of a browser after that if the
request is sent by the user the cookie
is added with a request by default thus
we recognize the user as an old user
there are two types of cookies they are
non-persistent cookie and persistent
cooking let's understand non-persistent
cookie first a non-persistent cookie is
valid for a single session only it is
removed each time when the user closes
the browser now let us understand the
persistent cookie the persistent cookie
is valid for multiple sessions it is not
removed each time when the user closes
the browser it is only removed when the
user logs out or signs up from the
browser let's get started with enums or
enumerations or enumerated types in java
so before we go into enums let's
understand why we need it when you are
building when you will be building the
java applications you will face
scenarios where you will have to define
some variables which will remain
constant forever for example months of
the year they are not going to change
they are always going to be 12 months in
an year
similarly let's say name of flowers they
are not going to change a lotus will be
a lotus forever similarly the name of
the seasons will always remain same the
season of summer or winter will always
be called summer or winter they will not
be changed the meaning of those
variables will never be overwritten or
will never be changed so you can think
of them as constants but they are not
the constants which your programs may
mutate or your programs may interpret
differently they will be interpreted by
multiple applications multiple
components multiple consumers in exactly
the same way
similarly if you take the example of
time zones they are fixed they work with
the gmt with respect to the gmt time
zone and they will always remain like
that so if you have if you whenever you
have a situation where you have to
define such constructs or such constants
always think of enum types or numerator
types enum is basically a language
construct and you can use this language
construct to define type safe variables
when we say type safe variables what we
mean is that these variables
are not integer or string they are of
enum types that's the reason java
created a completely new data type which
is called the enum type
they are by default constant so you
cannot change them that's their property
and the way you define enums is like
this
you say public enum so instead of the
keyword class you use the keyword enum
and then you define the name of the enum
the name of the enum type and then you
define the possible values just simply
separating them by a comma so for
example days of the week is again a
constant thing there will always be
seven days of the week irrespective of
what you do on this planet
so that's why you can declare an enum
for the day and you can define those as
as the values
you also notice that the values are caps
by default and yes that is how you
define the enums
let's have a look at a more interesting
example of the enums in the ide now so
if i switch to the ide
i have created a class called color not
a class but an enum type called color
and this enum type color is basically
holding all the different color types
their values basically like all the
vibger colors for example so i've
defined three colors here which are red
green and blue
so you see i've defined them as caps
they automatically become bold you don't
have to bold them
but you see an interesting thing a
difference here that there is another
value in the brackets here this was not
there when we looked at this example of
day there is no value inside each of the
enum types but i have defined the value
of the enum types and that is optional
there will be use cases where you want
to define some enum constants where the
name of the enum type is a constant
which is a placeholder but it will have
an internal value which may be more
practical for your application so this
is what your consumers see and this is
what
is used whenever you call red inside
your application is just for simplicity
there would be there might be use cases
where you use some abbreviations and
their full forms for example if you want
to use here an abbreviation of let's say
wh o
and inside this you can define the value
as
world
health
organization so this is just an uh toy
example i'm giving you where you will
have use cases where you want to define
a constant but you want to define an
internal value of it which is to be read
by your application elsewhere but
everybody who wants to consume this enum
can just use this particular keyword and
if they want to get the value they can
get the value as well
so this is the use case where you might
need to define values of your enum types
as well but whenever you have to do that
if you want to fetch the value of an
enum type you have to write some extra
code which is written here if you were
not defining the value of your enum
types your enum can be as simple as this
you don't need to define anything else
apart from just defining the constant of
the enum types
i'm giving a more complex use case so
that it covers both of the things of
using just the constants and also using
the values so if you just want to read
the constant you can just say color.red
or color.green or color.blue in
different classes and you will be able
to refer to the enum types or use the
enum types
but if you want to refer to the value of
the enum type then probably you need to
call this method called getvalue so
whenever you define a value what you
would do is you will define a private
member variable inside the enum which is
defined here you can name it anything if
you want you define a constructor where
you set this particular value and then
you define a getter so whenever some
consumer application wants to refer to
the value of your enum type they can
call this get value method to get that
so this is the enum now let's see how we
can use this enum for using this enum i
have this main class where i have a
public static void main method and you
can simply fetch the enum types by
writing the code like this just write
the enum type holder and then type the
enum type so let me show you how this is
done if you just put a dot here you will
get all the enum type options so i've
defined three enum types red green and
blue and i get all the options so
whatever option i want to choose i can
just select here and i can store this
inside an enum variable
so if you want to just refer to the name
of the enum so this c1 is holding
color.red or red so if you want to refer
to this just this red then you can call
the dot name method on the c1 variable
so if you say c1 dot name it is going to
put or print the red in caps and if you
want to fetch the value inside the red
remember the value is
read in in small caps so if you want to
refer to the or if you want to fetch the
value of the red then you call the get
value method
which we have defined here
so that's what we are doing here in this
first two sysouts where we are printing
the red enum name and then printing the
redinum value
now you can also iterate over all the
enum types
and for that you need to call the dot
values method on the enum so you can
just say color dot values which is going
to iterate over all the enum types
and you are just storing each of the
enum type in this color placeholder then
you can either call getvalue to get the
actual value of that enum type or you
can call the name to just print the name
of the enum as well both of the options
are available so
let's just put it back to get value and
let's run this code
so if i run this application i get some
output here which looks like this
first sis out says red enum name is red
in caps because we are calling the name
method second says red enum value which
prints red in small because we are
calling the getvalue method and then we
are iterating over all the enums so i
had three enum variables here red green
and blue
and i am going to iterate over all of
them one by one here printing their
value and not the enum constants
so that's why you see the red green and
blue here in small but if you just want
to print the enum constants themselves
and not their values then you change
this to dot name and then all the enum
constants will be printed here so this
is how you can create enums and use
enums for the constants which are never
going to change in your application
let's get started with annotations in
java
now annotations is a bit advanced
concept so let's understand why we need
it there would be some cases in your pro
in your application where you need to
provide some metadata information to the
java compiler now this sounds a bit
complicated but it's much simpler than
that because you might not want to code
everything with lot of lines of code
rather you want to give some smart
instructions to the java compiler so
that they understand what to do we have
already seen some of the annotations but
the basic idea of annotations is to
provide some shorthand metadata
information about the program to the
java compiler generally annotations will
not have any direct effect on the
operation of the code they annotate but
they provide additional logic to the
code that's the idea with annotation
remember they are shorthand metadata the
main use is providing information to the
compiler or providing some compile time
or deployment time processing or also
providing some instructions for runtime
processing we have already seen some of
the annotations if you remember when we
were dealing with inheritance we had
this ad the rate override over the
methods right this add the rate override
is an annotation this annotation if you
if i if i show you what i'm talking
about if i take you back to one of the
inheritance example or the method
overriding examples and if i open the
mountain bike class here mountain bike
extends bicycle you will see this
override annotation this is an
annotation an annotation always starts
with at the rate in java and the
annotation name is overwrite now this
override is just a shorthand to tell the
compiler that hey i am overriding this
method from the base class that's what
this annotation does if you remove the
annotation in some cases the java
compiler might not understand what to do
and the java compiler has to do some
extra processing to figure out that this
method is actually being overridden but
if you put this at override here then
the java compiler pre-hand will know
that this is coming from the base class
so you save some of the compiler
processing time as well by using the
annotation it's a shorthand providing
instructions to the compiler you see
exactly what i'm talking about so this
is one of the annotations which we have
used but we will look at some of the
other more generic annotations and we
will also see how we can build our own
custom annotation in java you might have
also seen some other annotations like
for example you can put aggregate
suppress warning annotation which is a
very popular annotation to suppress any
kind of yellow warnings in your code
generally we do not recommend doing that
but if you have a use case then you can
use advanced suppress annotation as well
there are some other annotations as well
like advert author if you want to put
your name as the author of a particular
piece of code then you can add this
metadata so that whenever somebody looks
at even the documentation of your code
your name will be shown there as the
author so that's the idea with
annotations so let's see how you can
build your own custom annotation
whenever you have to do that there are
multiple ways to doing that and the
first type of annotation we are going to
have a look at is called marker
annotation a marker annotation is just
an empty annotation without having any
metadata logic at all you can see it is
i have defined an annotation here i will
talk about what is all this means but
inside the block there is no code here
and this is how you define a marker
annotation marker annotation is just to
provide very high level instructions to
the compiler and the way you will write
your custom annotation is you will put
an access modifier keyword like public
then you will write add the rate
interface this is the keyword which you
have to use whenever you are trying to
create your custom annotation marker or
no marker doesn't matter whenever you
define your annotation you have to use
ad grade interface once you do that then
you provide a name for your annotation
which can be anything but still not
complete you need to also provide more
instructions to the compiler or the
runtime processor to tell them when to
execute this annotation and what the
annotation type is going to be applied
upon so at first you specify when this
annotation is going to be active or
executed or evaluated so here you can
say add the retention which is another
annotation so you say add direct
retention and then you say retention
policy dot whatever you want to write as
you can write it as runtime or you can
write it as source if you write it as
source then it is going to be applied at
compile time and if you select it as
runtime then the annotation is going to
be processed at runtime so this is the
first thing which you need to provide
the second thing which you need to
provide is where this annotation is
going to be applied whether you want
this annotation to be applied to a class
or to a method or to a member variable
or to any other type and that's what you
define in the add the rate target
annotation you specify the target
audience for this particular annotation
and here inside the element type you
will get multiple options you can apply
this annotation to a constructor to a
field local variable method module
package record component type etc so
here i'm going to use type which means
it can be applied to a class or a
generic element type which generally
means class type and that's all you can
define your marker annotation like this
but generally these marker annotations
does not have any logic so
you will not get much value out of it
until you have very special cases but if
you have a case where you want to also
run some business logic or provide some
metadata logic to the compiler while
defining the annotation then you can
define your annotation like this so i've
created one more annotation here which
is called which is called my custom
annotation again the target audience for
this is method so this annotation can
only and only be applied to methods if
you try to apply this annotation to a
class you will get an error the
retention policy is runtime it means it
is going to be processed at run time and
have declared a method here which is
called hint value so this is how you
will declare your annotation now let's
see how do you how do you use this
annotation so i have a class called as
my class here and if you look at this
structure of the my class we create the
class and then i create a method which
is named as sayhello and i am applying
this annotation on this particular
method remember the target audience of
this particular annotation was method so
it only be applied on method if i try to
put this on the class type here then i
get an error here it says the annotation
my custom annotation is disallowed at
this location because the type specified
is of type method so the compiler will
not allow you to use this at an illegal
place so you write any method and you
apply your annotation but you provide a
value to the method the int value method
is going to consume this value and
inside the method you can write any
other logic so let's see how this pans
out i create a public static void method
and i create an object of my class so my
class h equal to new my class and after
that i'm saying h dot get class dot get
method i'm basically calling the method
by using reflection api you can also
call the method directly if you want but
this is how you need to call it if you
want to use the annotation property
value if you want to fetch the value of
the annotation so this is just an
example of me showing you how you fetch
the annotation so we created an object
and then we say get class which is going
to return my class type and then get
method is going to return the method
type which has the name say hello so
this is a way to fetch a method name or
a method type from a class using java's
reflection api which is an advanced api
you might you might not need to use it
but for the sake of demo i'm using this
so we fetch the class and we fetch the
method it is going to search the class
for a method name say hello if it finds
the method it is going to return the
method in this variable and then you can
call methodval which was this variable
dot get annotation give me any
annotation which is applied on this
particular method and you supply the
annotation class type as well once you
do that you get a my custom annotation
reference type and then if you call the
value method on this you will get this
value as 10. so this is a way where you
can apply an annotation and you can
actually see the effect of the
annotation you might not always want to
do this because like i said these are
metadata instructions to the compiler
but if you have a need to actually see
what your annotation is doing you can
use the getclass.get method to first
fetch the method store it into a method
type and then call getannotation
supplying the exact annotation class
type and then you can call the exact
method which is defined in your
annotation here i've defined it as value
so i'm just calling the value method so
if i run this particular example i get
the value as 10. so i'm able to see or
fetch the exact value which my
annotation metadata is holding at the
runtime and this is the power of
annotation there are very powerful
concept and they're a very advanced
concept there would be very rare
scenarios in your application where you
need to create your custom annotations
generally you will be better off will
with your with your predefined
annotations which are provided in java
like at the rate override and direct
author at the rate
suppress warning etc let's get started
with serialization in java now before we
go further let's understand why we need
the concept of serialization when you
will be building the enterprise grid
applications in in different
organizations you will often have a use
case or a need to send an object from
one application to other application
which is deployed on some other machine
so if you have a network of computers or
if you have a lot of different uh
complex setup where you need you have a
producer application and you have a
consumer application producer
application produces the object and then
this object gets traveled over the
network lines over the network wires and
reaches at the consumer application and
how does the consumer application
receive the object and how does the
producer application sense the object
because when the data travels over the
network lines it will be all bytes so
how do you convert a java object into
bytes send it over network and then the
consumer application has to again
convert that bytes back to an object
representation and then store that or
use that inside its application so you
need to do this whole conversion right
so the process of converting an object
to a byte so that it can be sent over a
network is called serialization and the
process of converting back the byte from
the byte from the network to a java
object is called deserialization so
generally you you may have a use case
where you serialize an object create a
binary representation of it send it over
the network and that's where the java
serialization concept kicks in whenever
whenever you have to do this in java you
will be using the serializable interface
so you need to extend your objects from
this serializable interface so that
those objects themselves becomes
serializable you need to tell java that
this object is able to serialize itself
and deserialize itself and the way you
will tell java is by letting that object
implementing the serializable interface
let's have a look at an example for of
this serialization and deserialization
to understand this concept better so
here again i've used the same student
class where it has the name age and
address so you can see i have created a
student class but the student class
implements serializable this is
something which you have to add to your
class
second thing the moment you do that all
the modern day ides like eclipse or
intellij will ask you to add a serial
version universal id to this particular
class this is added so that java can
uniquely identify your object once it is
serialized and deserialized and it will
also keep a versioning track of it right
because when you serialize the object
what happens if somebody hops over the
network line and change the
representation of your object and the
consumer application will get a
completely different object copy now so
this is java's way to make sure that the
same version which the producer
application is producing is received by
the consumer application so it's also
sort of a security feature it basically
whenever you do an update on to the
object it is going to increment this
serial version uid by one so when you
create the object first time and you
serialize it for for the very first time
the value is going to be set as default
1 and as you mutate the object again and
again before deserializing it the count
will just keep on increasing so that's
how you keep a track of the state of the
object which is being serialized by
adding this long serial version uid you
can also specify your own value if you
want to by default java initializes a
value of one and this is a long type
variable so that is the only new thing
which is happening the moment you do
implement serializable after that i have
the same fields here i have the
constructor and the setters and the
getters
and i also have a tostring method just
to print the object nicely where i print
the name
the age and the address
so let's look at a main class and where
we use the student object we serialize
this object and then we deserialize this
object so what is happening here is i
create a class i create the main method
and i create a student object this is
something which we have already seen
then i
want to store the state of this object
when when you serialize this object this
object has to be either sent to a
network but since i'm running this demo
on the same machine what i will do that
i will serialize this object onto my
local file system it's the same thing
right you can put it somewhere and then
fetch it from there so either you can
send it over the network or you can put
it on a file system so i create the
object and then i need to store this
into a file so far i have not covered
the file handling operations so we will
not go deeper into the file handling
classes here but i will just explain you
the reasoning for it and when we'll do
the file handling session there i will
go in detail about the file handling
classes so i specify your file name
where the serialized representation of
my student object is going to be stored
and this is the location where i'm
supposed to store this then i create two
different classes which is for writing
to the file and then creating an object
for it so that's what i'm doing here we
can ignore this particular part where
i'm just supplying the file name and we
can focus on this part this line where
i'm saying write the object the student
object to this particular file that's
what i'm doing here in this particular
in this three lines of code that i'm
writing the student object to the file
so when java has to write this object to
the file it is automatically going to
serialize it that's the only way java
can write an object to the file so you
serialize the object and then you print
that message that the object has been
serialized again you can ignore this
part as well like i said we will not
focus on this but what we technically
did is we just wrote we just wrote the
object to a file by serializing it then
i try to deserialize it so i load the
file load this same file into the java
jvm and then i read the object and the
way i read the object is by using this
object input stream class i supply the
file that read this particular file and
then i call the read object method which
is going to return an object a general
object when you call the read object
method the read object method does not
know that it is a student type object so
you so you need to explicitly cast this
to the student type so that you can
store this as a student object if you do
not cast this you will get an error
because like i said read object does not
know anything about the student class so
what does what does this mean is that
when you serialize an object the class
type information is lost
you cannot store the class type
information when you serialize an object
because the moment you call this write
object method from the object output
stream class so you created this object
output stream class you supply the file
output location and you call the right
object the moment you call the right
object it's just any java object for the
this java program the signature of the
student class is lost it does not know
that it's a student class anymore once
it has been once it is being serialized
similarly when you deserialize it the
serialization api has no idea about what
student class is and what student object
is so you need to tell the read object
method explicitly that hey you are
reading an object of the student type
and that's how this line works once you
explicitly provide the casting operation
once you have casted it we try to print
the same deserialized object to see if
all the state which we stored in the
object is still persisted there or not
when we deserialize it so our major
focus in this particular class is this
object output stream classes and the
right object method these are the two
most important statements which you need
to take care of the file output stream
is basically a file location what is an
output stream we will talk about that
later but
whenever you need to serialize you need
to use this particular class called
object output stream so that's all i'm
doing here i'm serializing the object
with this these values and then i will
deserialize and i will again print the
object to see if these values are still
there or not so let's run this
application so when i run this
application let's start from here first
this sysout gets called which says
object has been serialized so you see
object has been serialized and what i
serialized was the student object which
had the value of name as john age as 25
and the address as 23 east california
and that's what gets printed here then
this whole block gets completed this
whole try block gets completed it's a
standard try catch block you see i have
also added the i o exception you need to
do that because these file operations
will force you to catch or throw the i o
exception which is a checked exception
that's why it will force you to do that
then we move to the deserialization
block where we create an object of the
object input stream class and then we
call the read object we cast it to the
student type and then we print the
object so when i print this object this
line gets printed object has been
deserialized and then i can see that the
exact same state is still there the name
which is set in the object is still
there after being after being
deserialized the age and the address is
exactly intact so this is how we you can
serialize an object
send it anywhere you want and then the
consumer application need to read the
object and cast it back to the student
type and they will be able to see the
exact same state which you saved in the
object just before serializing it what
if you have a use case where you do you
have a property in up in a student class
or in your object but you do not want
that to be serialized that's also a use
case where you may have 50 different
properties inside the student class and
one of the properties something which
you do not want to serialize because you
do not want the consumer application to
see that value if you ever had that
scenario use the transient variable so
transient is again a keyword and the
moment you put this keyword in front of
a member variable that variable becomes
transient the use case of transient
variable is that if you do not want this
x to be serialized and deserialized then
you put the transient keyword in front
of it the normal member variables will
automatically get serialized and
deserialized when the object is
serialized and deserialized but if you
have a use case where you do not want a
particular member variable to be
serialized or deserialized put transient
in front of it and then have the getters
and setters for this x variable and
let's use this and see if this actually
gets serialized or not so i created the
student object and let me call
student
dot
set x and let's put a value to x let's
say 10 so i have said the value of x is
10 and x is our transient variable and
then i am serializing the whole object
here and then i'm deserializing the
object and let's see if i'm able to
fetch the value of x after deserializing
the student object so i'm calling the
system.out.println
and
the serialized
value of x is
object
dot
get x
let's see if i'm able to see the value
of x or not so let's run this
application again
so
this is exactly the same as before this
is also exactly the same as before but i
see the value of x is 0. remember i set
the value as 10 before serializing it
but i don't see the value 10 anymore
when i deserialize the object because it
was transient
if you remove transient from it then you
will be able to transfer or travel this
value of 10 between serialization and
deserialization so if i just remove this
here don't change anything at all and i
just rerun the application this time
when i deserialize the object the value
of x as 10 is still present there even
after deserialization so this is how you
can use the transient variables if you
want to
not have that object serialized or
deserialized when you're doing the
serialization let's get started with
concurrency and threads the reason i
want to talk about concurrency because
once we understand about the concurrency
it will become much more simpler to talk
about threads and the idea behind
concurrency is very simple and plain and
that idea is that as a developer when
you write a program you would expect the
machine or the computer to run multiple
tasks in parallel for example right now
i'm recording this video on on a
particular laptop which is regarding my
voice which is also recording the screen
which is also running the eclipse ide
and also running a chrome browser it is
also have it also have opened multiple
background applications so there are a
lot of tasks running in parallel at the
same time and that's the idea about
concurrency now how do we work with
concurrency in java is with the help of
processes and threads so these are the
two basic units of execution when we
talk about concurrent programming in
java and when we talk about processes
you can think of a process as basically
an execution environment or i should
call it as a standalone execution
environment think of a logical box which
is completely cut out from everything
and it has its own environment for
example again the recording software is
running it's in its own execution
environment and when we talk about
process process generally has an
everything or a private set of all the
runtime resources it needs and the
memory space it needs now this another
concept or another construct which is
very important is threads so threads are
also sometimes called lightweight
processes and
basically when we talk about threads
it's a thread also has an execution
environment but creating a new thread
requires lot less resources than
creating a new process and you can also
think of threads as a mini version of a
process because a process can have
multiple threads remember that statement
that a process can have multiple threads
threads always exist within a process
and whenever you start a process there
will be at least one thread attached to
it and each thread is basically a task
for example the voice recording can be
a process and inside that the mic
recording
expression or the mic recording or task
can be run by a particular thread let's
take another example that when you play
games let's say you are playing a racing
game so when you play the racing game
there are multiple things happening at
once you see the current speed of your
car or bike on the screen you also see
your leaderboard position what ranking
you have in the race currently you also
see some other kind of features like
players health or the car's health or
the fuel
consumption available and lots of other
stuff the graphics the motorcycle the
other comp other competitors bikes and
their speeds and their distance to you
as well so if you see all of these are
running are different threads there's a
different thread to show your current
speed there's a different thread to show
the current leaderboard position there's
a different thread to show the fuel
indicator etc everything is running in a
different thread so all of these threads
need to run at the same time in your
program for a complete immersive user
experience and that's what we mean when
we say multi-threading that we want
multiple threads to run at the same time
to create a better experience in the
application so that's the basically the
theoretical part of it please do read
about more about how threads work and
how processes work and there's a lot
more documentation available in the java
docs as well when we talk about threads
but i will keep the theoretical part to
this particular point and now we will
move to an eclipse example to see how we
can create threads so with that let's
move to the eclipse ide and here i have
a demo prepared basically so what i have
here is a threading demo class which has
a public static void main method and it
has a simple for loop and inside the for
loop i see this strange code here where
i am initializing two threads and
starting them so that's all i'm doing
here but let's see how this thread one
and thread 2 class have been written and
why do i see two different ways of
initializing them let's go deeper into
this now so let's see how thread 1 can
be created so first of all you can
create a thread by just creating a
simple class but make sure that you
extend it with the pre-built thread
class this thread class is from coming
from java so from the jdk basically so
the moment you extend your normal class
from the thread class then you will have
to override the run method so if i show
you the thread class here this is the
thread class uh implementation available
inside the jdk and this is the class
which is getting
called when you are extending is from
the thread class and this thread class
will ask you to override a run method
here the override annotation is missing
so let me just add this for better
understanding so you need to overwrite
the run method and this is something
which you need to do so that you can
specify what happens when you run the
thread so this run method will be called
whenever the thread is running at this
particular point i would also like to
tell you that there are different states
in the thread so there is a thread which
says thread is ready then there is a
state which is which say thread is
running there is also a state where the
thread is waiting for an i o input from
the user from the console or the command
line there can also be a state which
says dead where the thread has completed
its task and it's not working there can
also be a state which is called sleep
state where the thread is paused so
there are different states of the thread
and in this example we are going to
focus primarily on three states which is
the ready state and the running state
and the completed state so when you call
the run method the thread state is going
to change to running and whatever code
you write inside this particular run
method will be the logic which this
particular thread is supposed to execute
here i'm just putting a dummy logic
where i'm just
printing assist out but definitely if
you try to create your threads this will
contain your actual business logic for
example that fuel indicator code or for
the leaderboard position code will go
inside this run method and then i'm
catching an exception if there's an
exception but obviously there will not
be an exception coming in because i have
nothing here literally so that's what we
are we are doing when we are creating
this thread one class and let's come
back to the threading demo now so to
initialize a thread or initialize might
not be right word to run a thread the
first thing which you need to do is to
initialize the class containing the run
method so i would avoid calling this
class as thread because technically this
is just a class so you initial so you
basically create an object of the thread
just like you create the object of any
other class there is nothing new here
right so we just say new thread 1 and
then we call
t1.start now if you observe carefully
there is no start method here we just
had a run method but this code is still
compiling fine and i'm calling the start
method here because the start method is
the internal method of the thread class
which in turn is going to call the run
method so you are never going to invoke
the run method directly you just need to
start the thread which is going to
change the state of the thread from
ready to running so this start method
has the responsibility of changing the
state to running and the way the start
method is going to do that is by calling
the run method internally inside the jdk
itself from developer perspective you
just need to call the start method and
that's it the thread will start running
and whatever is present in the run
method will get executed so that's the
way to start the thread second thing i
have one more thread created here which
is the thread 2 class so
in this case when i create a thread 2
class i am not extending it from the
thread class rather i am implementing
the runnable interface here so this is a
different interface available which is a
functional interface which means it will
have just one method which is the run
method but the interesting thing is that
here when i created thread one i said
extends thread but here when i'm
creating the second thread i'm not using
extends thread but i'm using implements
runnable let's understand why do we do
that first of all the reason java
provides two different ways of creating
threads is because there might be a use
case that you need to extend your thread
to class from some of your custom java
class remember java does not support
multiple inheritance so at a time you
can only extend this class from one
class so what if there was no runnable
interface and you need to extend this
thread to from student class let's say
so you need to do class thread to
extends
student for example the student is not
present here but let's assume it is so
you do this and then you also have to
extend it from thread now java doesn't
support multiple inheritance and this
will not work so what would you do if
you have to also create it as a thread
but also extend it from some of your
parent class you will not be able to do
that and that's the reason java provides
the implements runnable because then you
can extend it from any of your super
class of your interest and at the same
time also implement implement it with
runnable interface so that you can treat
this class as a thread so that's the
reason java provides two different ways
of creating threads remember that it's a
very important concept and once you
implement runnable again it will ask you
to override the run method so i will
just put overwrite annotation here so
once you override the run method again
you can write whatever logic you want
this particular thread to execute inside
the run block coming back to the main
class so
when you are extending from thread the
initialize initialization is very simple
where you create the object and you call
the start method on the object but if
you are creating a thread by
implementing the runnable interface the
initialization of the thread is a bit
different and it's different in this
particular part on the left hand side
you still say thread t2 remember you are
saying thread and not thread 2. this is
a this is the java thread class this is
the jdk thread class not your own thread
class so you say thread t2 then you say
new thread and inside the new thread you
provide your own class type thread two
was your own class type so you specified
your own custom thread class here inside
the new thread constructor this thread
class is the jdk class if you click on
this you will see this is from the jdk
class so that's the difference extending
thread simple initialization
implementing runnable interface do the
initialization like this and after that
you call the similarly the start method
which is in turn going to call the run
method so that was how you create
threads differently and now let's run
this program to understand how the
output looks like when we run these
threads in loops remember i'm
initializing 10 instances of each of
these threads so in total there would be
20 output lines
so if i go to run as java application i
see this output here so let's observe
this output for once so thread 1 thread
2 is running in sequence in the first
time but then you see thread 1 is
running twice and then thread 2 is
running twice then again you see a good
sequence but again thread 2 has run
twice here again thread 1 has run twice
if i go further down thread 1 runs once
then again thread two runs twice
thread one runs once thread two runs
once so there is no particular order
here though based on the code which we
have written we should expect thread one
is running from here and then thread two
is running output from here in a
sequential fashion but we don't see the
sequential fashion here and this is the
power of concurrency this is because
threads never run in sequence they run
in parallel and which thread will
execute first you can't really predict
that so it's so be very careful when you
whenever you're writing multi-threading
code because you cannot predict the
sequence of execution because threads
are going to run whenever they find the
idle cpu so the key is the idle cpu
whenever a thread finds an idle cpu it
is going to occupy that cpu and going to
run its own execution and the moment its
execution finishes the other thread will
jump in and take up and take a piece of
the cpu so whichever thread gets the
idle piece of the cpu is going to
execute and that is the reason you see
this randomized output the next time
you're going to run you will see a
different random order so so this time
you see thread one ran four times you
did not see this in the previous
execution if you run it again you will
see again a different output this time
the third one ran thrice so every time
you will run this you will see a
different sequence there is no guarantee
of order because the threads are running
in parallel and they are running
whenever they get the idle cpu that's
the bottom line so this is how we are
going to create threads and remember you
cannot guarantee the sequence of the
execution so write your code accordingly
and use the threads for independently
running parallel threads which do not
depend upon each other let's get started
with thread synchronization in java so
in the previous example we saw that when
we execute threads then we can't
guarantee the sequence but it's actually
technically not a problem in the example
which we had look at before but it can
become a bigger problem when two threads
are trying to access the same object
remember object has properties and state
so what if the first thread modified the
object state and the second thread is
reading the state of the object the
second thread is expecting the original
state but while it was trying to read it
the other thread modified its state so
you can see this become a this can
become a big problem for example if you
are working with a banking system and if
there are two persons accessing the same
account at the same time one is
depositing the money and one is
withdrawing the money from the account
and if the total balance is thousand and
if both of them deposit 500 and withdraw
500 at the same time then who sees what
and if these are two if these are
handled by two different threads then we
can't guarantee if somebody sees a 1500
as the total sum or somebody sees a 500
as a total sum or there can be a
scenario where somebody sees zero as the
total sum so it there so the application
can turn into really weird scenarios if
two threads are trying to change the
state of a particular object at the same
time and java provides a solution of it
with the concept of intrinsic locks and
synchronizations so the idea is that
when a thread tries to work on a
particular object it basically takes a
lock on that particular object we also
call this as an intrinsic lock or
monitor lock so it takes a lock on the
object and it means that that particular
object becomes completely inaccessible
to other threads in the system at that
particular time so the moment you put
synchronization or you put lock on a
particular object only the thread which
has taken the lock will be able to
access the object and other threads will
be forbidden from accessing the object
so that's the idea behind intrinsic
locks and synchronization so that was
about the brief theory of it now let's
have a look at a practical example so i
have prepared another example for it so
here i have again created two threads
but these two threads it's the pretty
much the same threads which we covered
in the previous
session named as thread one and thread
two one is extending thread class and
other is implementing runnable but
that's the that's same but the
interesting part is this both of them
have a reference to a class called
mathutils if you see thread 1 also has
the reference and thread 2 also has the
reference and what the math utils is
doing here is basically you supply a
number and it prints the multiples of it
till five so for example if you supply
two you will get the output two four six
eight ten if you supply three you will
get the multiple of three up to three
times five so three six nine
15. if you supply 4 you will get the
outputs
of the in the multiples of 4 till 20. so
whatever number you will supply you will
get the next 5 multiples of that
particular number that's what this class
is doing and another thing which
interesting thing which i've done here
is this thread dot sleep which means
that when you run this loop where you
are printing the multiples till five of
that number every time you do the first
multiplication then you sleep for 400
millisecond and when i say sleep it
basically means the current thread is
going to pause its execution for 400
millisecond and it is going to leave the
cpu idle and if there is another thread
running currently in the system that
thread will get the share of the cpu for
that 400 millisecond and once the 400
milliseconds is finished the thread is
going to wake up and it is again going
to hunt for the idle cpu to pick up and
start doing its execution so that thread
dot sleep happens for 400 milliseconds
at every step of this iteration in this
for loop so thread one is going to use
this particular method of this
particular class and it is going to ask
the class to print the multiples of 2
and thread 2 is also going to access the
reference of the class and access the
get multiples method but this thread
asks to print the multiple of 3. so
thread 1 asks for printing the multiples
of 2 up to 2 times five and thread two
wants to print the output to multiple
sub three up to three times five so
that's the basic scenario two threads
accessing the same object supplying
different values and expecting the
output so if i run this demo as is
without any change here i'm just
initializing the math utils class
initializing two threads and then
calling the start only once so if i run
this particular program i see get i see
this strange output that even when i
said t1 dot start first so t1 was
holding the multiple of two remember but
i still get three first then two then
four six so multiples of two gets
executed here but then the other thread
takes the cpu and it starts running its
own multiples outputs and you see nine
printing first and then six gets printed
then twelve then eight then fifteen and
then ten at very last so the output
looks very random it would have been
nicer if i could have seen two 4 6 at 10
once and then 3 6 9 12 15 once if i see
them in different sections in different
sequences that would have been so nice
because then i know which thread is
running when and when that particular
thread is working on the object so i'm
just trying to replicate the same
scenario where two threads are accessing
the same object at the same time but
they are executing the object randomly
they are changing the state of the
object randomly here so how do we fix
this to fix this we can put so we have
this get multiples method which is the
bone of contention here this is the
method which is being randomly accessed
so what i can do here that i can put
synchronized keyword in front of the
method so once you put the synchronized
keyword in front of the method which is
being accessed by multiple threads at
the same time this method this whole
method gets synchronized now what this
means that one thread will be execute
this method at once there will never be
a scenario where two threads are
simultaneously executing this get
multiples method or even getting a hold
of this get multiples method at the same
time there would be only one thread at a
time executing this method so if i put
the synchronized here and if i rerun
this example you see i get a more
streamlined output if you notice
everything is one running like clockwork
where first the thread one gets executed
so i get two four six eight ten really
well printed and then the second thread
starts which says 3 6 9 12 15. the
reason i get this output is because when
i did t1 dot start it immediately went
to execute the get multiples method but
it saw synchronized there so it took a
lock on the method and even when the
t2.start might have got executed maybe
milliseconds after that or nanoseconds
after that it still could not get hold
of the getmultiples method because
thread1 occupied this particular method
it took a lock on this particular method
due to the synchronized keyword so
that's the power of synchronized keyword
that you can take a lock on a particular
method if you put it in front of the
method now there can be scenarios that
you do not want to lock the whole method
you still want two different threads to
access the method but there can be very
few lines of code inside the method
which is that which is thread sensitive
code now how do you spot that sensitive
code there is no magic bullet there is
no silver bullet for it and it comes
with experience so you need to have that
experience to know which is the thread
sensitive code which can create problems
if two threads run that code at the same
time so the moment you have spotted that
code and if you don't want to lock the
whole method you can lock the exact
lines of code by putting the
synchronized block so if i remove this
and i enable this particular part so
what i'm doing that i know that this is
the code which is exactly causing the
problem which is creating this random
output so what i can do that i can put
the synchronized keyword right before
the block of the code starts which is
thread sensitive and the way you do that
is you write synchronized and you supply
this which means whoever has the current
who whoever has the object of the math
appeals that whole object gets logged
for this particular block of code so
whoever has the math utils object takes
the lock on the object for this
particular block of code if there was
some other code which was written in the
get multiples method before the
synchronized block or after the
synchronized block that block can be
accessed by multiple threads at the same
time but this code will only be
accessible to one thread at a time there
will never be there will never be a
concurrent access to the synchronized
block that's the power of synchronized
block and it will work the exact same
way so to show you if i run this
particular program i still get the
output in the same streamline way where
first the multiples of two get printed
and then the multiples of three get
printed so that's how you can actually
use synchronized methods or synchronized
block to make sure that one thread is
accessing a sensitive object at a time
and there will never be a scenario that
two threads are mutating the same object
at the same time again like i said be
very very cautious of when you use
synchronized blocks and when you use
threads because threads have
unpredictable execution cycle execution
sequence basically and synchronized
blocks also have problems if you have if
you have thousands and thousands of
threads running in your application and
if you put synchronized on a particular
method your application may face severe
performance issues because all of the
threads will be executing that method in
a sequence imagine you put this onto a
huge application or a huge ecommerce
application or a news website it is it
is going to create serious performance
issues so be very cautious of how and
when you use synchronized method and the
key to that is to have that developer
dna to spot the code which is causing
this problem which might be thread
sensitive and maybe you might need to
change the code itself you might not
need to go into the multi-threading
scenario and you might you might be able
to fix it without using the threading or
synchronized concept it completely
depends but always have a good trade-off
when to use the synchronized methods and
synchronize blocks let's get started
with auto boxing and unboxing in java so
if you remember in the very first
sessions i talked about the primitive
data types and then later on we talked
about the objects for example we had the
int data type but there later we also
saw an integer data type which is which
can also pretty much do the exact same
work which int data type was doing and
we saw the similar kind of uh experience
for the float data type and the float
class double data type and the double
class care data type and the character
class and so on so forth so java
provides an easy way to convert a int
data type variable into an integer data
type variable and also back from integer
data type variable to an int primitive
data type variable now you might be
wondering why we need that there would
be scenarios for example if you had an
int array as a primitive int array and
if you want to store that into a
collection now collection can only be of
type of objects it cannot be a type of
primitive data type so you might need to
convert this int primitive data type
array into an integer object collection
so you need to do this conversion of
into data type to integer data type and
there would be cases where you invited
you might need to do vice versa so
that's the basic idea about auto boxing
and unboxing so when we talk about the
definition you can see auto boxing is
the automatic conversion that the java
compiler makes between the primitive and
their corresponding object wrapper
classes so whenever you are converting a
primitive data type to an object class
this is called autoboxing and when you
do the reverse it is called auto
unboxing or simply unboxing so let's
understand this with the help of an
example now so i'm just going to open an
example about auto boxing and unboxing
so that we can have a look at it and
here it is i've created a class which is
called auto boxing demo it has a public
static void main method and inside the
method i'm first simply declaring an int
data type variable i with the value 10
then if i need to auto box this if i
need to convert this primitive value
into an integer object wrapper class or
an integer class type then i need to
write the code like this which says
integer dot value off and then you can
supply the primitive data type value and
the output of it will be of type integer
class so you get an integer object and
then you can print the object to check
if it is successfully doing the auto
boxing or not similarly doing the other
way round once i have converted this
into an integer object let's convert
this back to a primitive data type so
from integer object i'm converting this
back into the primitive data type and
you see here it's a simple assignment i
just have to assign the object to the
primitive data type and that's it i can
do the same for a character
object and a cad data type so first i
create a character object care obj and
then if i have to unbox it i can simply
assign this cad obj to a care primitive
data type ch and that would be it so you
can do the similar drill for any other
primitive to object wrapper conversion
let's say you want to convert a float
data type to a float class or you want
to convert a double data type to a
double class then whichever primitive
data type has an object wrapper class
you can do the auto boxing and auto
unboxing like this remember whenever you
have to do auto box it means you're
going from primitive to object and for
that you need to call the value of
method for example if you were
converting a double primitive to a
double object class double object type
basically then you are going to call
double dot value of and similarly the
same kind of behavior will be seen for
other object wrapper classes as well so
for auto boxing you call the value of
and for auto unboxing you literally just
assign this to an primitive and the
object wrapper class value will
automatically be assigned to the
primitive data type so let's run this
now and observe the output so i had the
int i equal to 10 then i wanted to
convert this primitive into the object
wrapper and the way i can do that is by
calling the value of method and
supplying the primitive data types value
so that's why i'm doing it that's what
i'm doing here and this i obj
should get the 10 value now which i can
see if i print the out and if i just
print the integer object all together i
get the value 10 so this concludes that
i've successfully am able to
auto box the primitive into an integer
object now looking at auto unbox like i
said you simply can assign the object
wrapper to the primitive data type
variable and that should work as is and
that's why at line 15 we get this output
which says value of i1 is 10. similarly
when we try to auto box the character
object so i have created a character
object here and then i want to unbox
this back into a simple car data type ch
so when i print ch i get the same value
and when i print the car obj i again get
the same value remember the reason i've
put this as auto box is because this by
default is being stored into a car data
type i can also write it like this for
example i can say care
x equal to a and then i can refer here
as character
dot value of x this will pretty much
have the same impact or the same effect
which i had just now it is going to
print the exact same output if i read on
this program i'm going to get the exact
same output so this this basically
concludes our understanding that you can
use the auto boxing and auto unboxing
pretty easily whenever you have a
scenario where you want to convert the
primitive data types to the object
wrapper classes or you want to convert
the object wrapper classes back to the
primitive data types let's get started
with i o in java or i o streams in java
so when we say io it basically means
input output and the basic idea is that
your program takes an input and gives
you an output so whenever you have to do
some i o handling generally the i o
handling involves taking input from some
external source it can be the command
line it can be from a file it can be
from another consumer application it can
be from a hard disk but the basic idea
is that whenever you have to do that
input output handoff or input output
operation we call that as io generally
whenever you will hear the term io we
refer to the input output operations
with respect to the file system or the
hard disks or the external disks
basically now when we talk about streams
what is an io stream so the basic idea
is that you have an input source you
have an output destination now the way
that the input source sends the data to
the destination is via streams so
basically it converts the data into one
and zero and that one and zero travels
as a stream for example you can see this
pretty good image here where you have a
data source and you have a program and
your program is trying to read the data
from this data source which is basically
sitting on the file system and this data
gets converted into zeros and once and
then this is streamed to the program bit
by bit or piece by piece similarly when
the program wants to send the data back
to the data source it again goes in the
form of stream so when we talk about
stream we also use the terms as input
stream or output stream so a program
uses an input stream to read data from a
source remember whenever we are reading
we will call it as input stream and
whenever we are writing something we
will call that as output stream remember
that because i will be using this for
these particular terms again and again
in the demo so that's the basic idea
about streams that you convert this into
one and zero and input stream means
reading something and output stream
means writing something so now that we
have built that understanding let's have
a look at what kind of classes support
java provides to do this io streaming
operations so this is the java io
hierarchy where you have the object
superclass and then you have different
types of streams stream classes so you
have input stream you have output stream
you have reader and you have writer so
if you talk about this particular
section in the input stream you have a
file input stream in the output stream
you have a file output stream this is
basically showing an inheritance
relationship so you have the input
streams for reading something you have
the output stream for writing something
and you have java provides the classes
to write to read from a file or to write
to a file using the file input stream
and the file output stream class
respectively there are more classes
under it but only a few are few of them
are shown for simplicity similarly if i
go to the right side i also have a
reader class and a writer class which
also have an input stream reader and
output stream reader and again these
have multiple other sub classes like
file reader buffer reader and file
writer so i will also try to showcase
the understanding of why we need this
and why we need these i mean ultimately
you have to write a stream right so why
creating two different types of classes
i will come back to that in a while with
that understanding let's go into looking
at an example and let's build an
understanding of how do we work with
streams and this is also the session
where i will talk about the file
handling operations in detail
so to understand that
i have created two different examples
one for byte stream and one for
character stream so let's take that
concept first why do you need two
different types of streams and the
reason is pretty simple whenever you are
reading data from some some data source
or writing data to the data source so
the data can either be simple character
strings like english characters or the
unicode characters or it can be some
tabular data setting in a table in a
database it can be an xml file it can be
an html file it can be literally
anything it can be a mathematical
expression file it can be an image you
don't know that so that's the reason
java created two different types of
classes that if you want to
work on a particular file which is
holding characters then you can use
character stream and if you are dealing
if you don't know what kind of data the
file is going to contain then just use
byte streams character streams also
internally will be using the byte stream
only but it is much more simpler and
much more faster to use character
streams if you just have character files
also it is worth noting that when you
are using character stream the file will
be read character by character and when
you are using byte stream the file will
be read bite by byte so one byte at a
time and one character at a time so
let's look at the byte stream example
first i've created a class called byte
stream example it has a public static
void bin method and then i'm using the
file input stream and file output stream
classes basically what i'm trying to do
in this example is i'm trying to read a
file and write to a file and like i said
the uh when we look at the theory
whenever we are using the input stream
term we are primarily doing a read
operation and whenever we are using the
output stream term we are writing
something to the file
so for these kind of operations java
provides for file handling java provides
these two classes which are called file
input and file output stream so i create
null references and then i enter a try
block and inside the try block i
basically provide a location to read the
file from so i've created a source.txt
in the java tutorials location and if i
show you what this source file is
containing so if i go to this location
java tutorials and if i open the source
file it just has a simple text which
says this is a sample text file let me
delete this dest.txt for now so i just
have a source.txt here which is
containing a sample text this is a
sample text file so i am reading the
source.txt using the file input stream
and storing the output into this in
stream which is a byte stream and i'm
also creating another output stream
where i will be writing the destination
file so i'm saying this particular
location write the file with the name
test.txt but these are still just
containers i haven't done much here so
you are going to initialize the reading
stream and the writing stream and then
you are going to read one byte at a time
till the time you reach the end of the
file the way to denote the end of the
file or the way java tells you that you
have reached the end of the file is when
the read operation returns -1 so you
keep reading the file till the read
operation returns the value as -1
whenever it returns the value as -1 it
means that you have reached the end of
the file so i'm going to read this
source.txt byte by byte one byte at a
time till my re until i reach the end of
the file so i call in stream dot read i
store the output of in stream dot read
into a variable called content and at
the same time i also run this condition
that till the time this output is not
equal to minus one keep writing right
where right to the outstream so i want
to write to this particular stream so i
i call the write method and remember
this is a byte stream but here i the
output of in stream dot read was an
integer output so you need to convert
this int output to a byte by doing the
explicit casting here so we do the
explicit casting here so that the int
content gets converted into a byte type
and then out streamed alt right writes
that byte inside the stream onto this
particular file so that's what is
happening here that you load the
in-stream you read the file byte by byte
and you start writing the
output file byte by byte that's what you
do in this while loop once you have
reached the end of the file you will be
broken out of the while loop because the
whole file has been read and whatever
was written in that file has been
written to the outstream to this
particular file location and then in the
finally block you close both of the
streams remember it's very important to
close these resources otherwise these
resources will be present till the time
java runs a garbage collection so it's
very important to make sure that you
close all the resources which you open
in terms of file handling these are
costly connections and they take up a
lot of memory so make sure that you
close them in the final block and that's
why if you see i don't have a catch
block here but i've put the finally
blocked so that i can say i can
seamlessly close them so that is what
i'm doing here and now if i run this i
don't get any output because i'm not
printing anything but if i go to this
particular location and see if i have a
deskt.txt so yes our desk.txt has just
appeared which was not there earlier and
if i double click on this it has the
exact same text
as i had in my
source.txt so the source.txt and the
desk.txt have the same content because
i've just written the source.txt to the
desktop cds.txt
so this is how you can use byte stream
operations to do file handling now let's
have a look at the character stream
example it is doing exactly the same
thing it's just that you have to use
different classes so instead of file
input stream and file output stream we
are going to use file reader and file
writer so i create the file leader and
filehead references let's call it as
reader for simplicity
and let's call this as writer so i
initialize file reader and file writer
again pointing to the same location let
me delete the desktop txt again so that
we can observe the output so i create
the object for file writer and file
reader and i again do the same thing i
call the read operation the read
operation is going to return an integer
value output and i i'm going to continue
reading the file character by character
this time the byte is not read but the
actual character of the file is being
read so i'm going to read this file
character by character till i reach the
end of the file which is denoted by this
condition and as the output is int i
need to convert this into care so i cast
the int output to a care output and then
write it to the writer then i close the
reader and writer both and that's it so
if i run this now and if i go back here
i will see desk.txt and i see the output
here exactly as same so in terms of
output there was no difference but since
this was a purely character file the
character stream demo is a better use
case or like file reader and file later
classes are a better use case but like i
said there would be cases where you have
to read it as bytes because for example
if you're dealing with databases or if
you're dealing with another type of
files for example image files etc that
will be traveling as bytes so using a
byte stream might be a better example in
that case and that's that holds true for
any other different type of data source
as well let's get started with using
jdbc in java to connect to the databases
in this example i'm using the open
source community edition postgresql but
you can use any database vendor provider
if you want to if you want to use oracle
or mysql feel free to do that but in
this demo i'm going to use postgres so
you can download the postgres windows
installer since i'm using a windows
machine here you can download the
installer from the official
postgresql.org website and you can also
download the jdbc driver for post resql
going to this particular official
website which is jdbc.postgresql.org
similarly you will be able to find the
jdbc driver for all other database
vendor providers as well once you
download this this is going to download
a jar for you and you can store the jar
anywhere like i put this jar into this
particular location you can see this
latest jdbc driver jar for post sql so
for every database vendor there would be
a different jdbc jar which you need to
download so that's that you install the
postgresql you set up its database and
when you install the post sql you also
get a nice sql client to talk to the
database because database has a server
and database has a client right so to
deal with that you install the server
and all these database vendors like
postgres oracle microsoft sql etc they
also provide a nice thin client with it
postgres also provides a client when you
install the uh postgres server it will
also ask you or it will actually
automatically install the sql client for
it as well which is called pg admin so
this is how the pg admin client looks
like the current edition of it is pg
admin 4 so you will get that installed
automatically and once your postgres
server has been successfully installed
if you just go to search and type pg
admin you will get this option once you
click on this option a new browser
window will be opened and you will see
this client here you will not see this
particular window let me let me close
this one but you will see something like
this you will see a server here so you
can go inside it you will see a
postgresql edition here and if you go
inside it you will see a database here
if you open the database you will see
the postgres database by default created
so you can just right click on this and
create a database here you can name it
as whatever you want you can leave
everything as is for now and hit save
another thing which you need to do when
you do the installation is it will ask
you to set a database user and password
so choose whatever database username and
password you are comfortable with and
you will be using that user username and
password in your program as well so
create your database here and just leave
the database at this particular point
and now we will try to connect to this
particular database in the in the
example which i prepared i'm going to
connect to this test database so let's
go to the jdbc demo and see what is
happening there so for this purpose i've
created a class called jdbc demo it has
a public static void main method and
there's a lot going on here so let's
take it step by step and i will be keep
shuffling between the database sql
client and this particular class to
build a nice narrative so if you think
carefully what you need to have if you
want to connect to a database the
obvious answer is the address of the
database where is that database you need
to know the location of the database to
connect to it so that is called the
connection url every database vendor
will provide its own connection url and
you can find that connection url from
the official documentation there are
tons of examples available for it as
well but always refer to the official
documentation for that particular
database provider the general syntax is
jdbc colon your database vendor's name
colon double slash the host name this
can be any ip address or your local host
generally we also put a port here
something like this 5432 is the port on
which the post resql server runs but
again you can put the post the port here
on which your database server is running
every database vendor has their own
default port the postgres sql server has
the default port as 5432. so you provide
the hostname you provide the port and
then you provide the database name you
provide the database name to connect to
so if you remember i told you that i
have written the program to connect to
this particular database called test so
whatever that be you provide that name
here and this is going to form the
connection url i can remove this for now
but this is how the connection string is
going to look like and it is going to
it's follow it follow the same format
for any database vendor that you say
jdbc colon you write the database vendor
name and then you say colon double slash
you provide the host port and then you
provide the database name so that is
your connection url after that to
connect to
connect your java program to a database
you need to use the
java.sql.connection class this is very
critical class and very important and
probably the single most important class
which you need to have in your program
if you want to connect to a database
so you say connection con equal to null
i'm just creating a null reference to it
and before we go any further let me also
tell you why we need this jdbc and what
is actually this jdbc so
java is a programming language it does
not comes with its own database but
there are multiple other vendors like
postgresql mysql microsoft sql oracle
etc so java wanted to provide a uniform
way to connect to all of these databases
because imagine all of these databases
building their own api contract it would
have been a nightmare for the developers
to connect to different databases or
shift from one database to other
database and that's the reason java
created this nice interface called jdbc
and it said whoever wants to connect to
java should follow this jdbc
specification and provide their
implementation similar to the the
interface and concrete class thing it's
not exactly that but you can think of it
in that manner that jdbc provides an
interface with the method declarations
and then oracle postgresql mysql all
these database vendors are supposed to
implement that interface and provide
their own implementation but jdbc apis
will always remain the same whoever
wants to connect to java has to create a
driver and that driver contains that
implementation and that's the reason we
downloaded that jdbc driver and i will
come to how how do we include that but
that's the background of jdbc and that's
why you need jdbc to build that uniform
contract and your vendor will provide
their own jar which will have the
implementation of the jdbc interface and
in this program what i'm trying to do is
basically i'm trying to insert a record
into a table so what is a table and how
do you create that so let's go back here
so in this test database you will see a
schema by default you will see a public
schema and you can create a new schema
if you want to or you can just use the
public schema so inside the public
schema you will go under and you will
see a an entry for tables so you just
right click and you say create table you
can also write in complete sql statement
but i'm just showing you how to do that
in pg admin and you can give the table
name you can give the column information
and that's how you create the table so i
have created a table here which is
called student and the student table has
three columns roll number name and age
if i show you the exact query or the the
whole create tdl for it it looks like
this so i created the
student table in the public schema which
has a roll number field or roll number
column which is of type numeric it has a
name column which is a varchar or a
character varying and it has a age
column which is again a numeric so roll
number name and age these are the three
different columns which i created inside
the student table so i have a student
table with these three columns so that's
that now let's go back to the program so
i have the student table and now i want
to insert some records in the student
table so let me just change the values
here so that we can see a different
entry so i have just hardcoded some
values generally you will be getting
these values from somewhere in the
program but for simplicity let's say you
have got those values once you've got
those values the next thing you need to
do is to build the sql statement the
exact sql statement which the postgresql
which is going to be run on the sql
server so you write that statement in
this case i'm showing you in a creation
example so it is going to be an insert
query so i say insert into table name
which is student and then i provide all
the column names it is always a better
practice to provide the column names in
these brackets even if you are inserting
the values to all the columns still
provide the column names so i say insert
into table column values and then you
provide the actual values as the roll
number variable which i created here the
name variable and the age variable
values so i just supply the values here
remember the when you are inserting the
values roll number and age are integer
so you don't need to put any single
commas single inverted commas for it but
name is a string variable so i put this
single inverted commas it's a simple
string concatenation nothing fancy here
so i'm just writing and a plain sql
statement here and storing that into a
string once i've done that the next
piece which i need to do is to get a
connection to the database and the way
you are going to get a connection is by
this uniform method no matter which
database provider you are using you are
always going to use the
drivermanager.getconnection method to
get a connection to the database and how
do you get the connection you supply the
connection url you supply the username
to connect to the database and you
supply the password in this case i've
just set the username and password as
postgres and postgres so postgres is the
username and postgres is the password
pretty lame i accept but this is just
for demonstration purpose so it's fine
but generally you will be getting these
values from some application property
file so these are the three parameters
which you need to supply to this get
connection method and then you will get
a live connection to the database this
is this uh this is the line which is
going to make it all happen to connect
to your database server so if this line
gets executed successfully you have a
live connection once you have a live
connection the next thing which you are
going to do is to create a statement
object on the connection statement is it
can be anything it can be an insert
statement or a select statement or
update statement or a delete statement
everything is a statement there right so
that's why you need to create a
statement object so you create a
statement object and then you execute
the sql this insert sql which you
prepared you're going to execute the sql
here saying st dot execute update
execute update is the method which is
used for any insertion or deletion
operations so that's the method you're
going to use and supplying the sql query
which you built with the actual values
of roll number name and age the execute
update method returns the number of rows
affected once this statement got run on
the database server or the sql query got
run on the database server it might
impact one rows if it's just if it's an
insertion it might impact multiple rows
if it was an update query right so it is
going to return the number of rows
affected and that is what we are going
to use to check if my insertion
successfully went or my insertion failed
so if this execute update is going to
return 1 which means that my row got
inserted successfully in the database so
i'm just printing us this out here and
if any if this particular m returned 0
which means none of the rows were
affected by my sql query which means my
insertion operation failed so i'm just
printing assist out here and then i'm
just putting this in a catch block here
to print any error and finally closing
the connection this is again very very
important database correction is one of
the costliest connections you will be
creating when you will be writing your
java applications always and always make
sure to close these database connections
otherwise your application is going to
face serious database bottlenecks so we
close the connection so that's all we
are doing here we prepare the url we
prepare we just create a placeholder for
connection object we prepare our sql
query with all the relevant values we
get a connection to the database we get
a create statement we get a statement
object from the create statement method
and then we execute the statement and
then we can validate the statement
execution if there is a way to validate
it once you've done all of that you
close the connection so let's run this
program and see if we can see this new
record inside the student table and
before we do that let's also validate
what is present in the student table as
of now so if i go here and i say view
all rows this is just going to run a
select star on the student table so
currently student table has one record
with roll number one name as john and
age as 20. and now i'm trying to insert
another row with roll number two name as
jane and age as 22. so if i right click
and run as java application i get this
entry which says inserted successfully
which is coming from here insert it
successfully and it also prints the
exact sql so that you can see what sql
actually got executed on the database
server this is the same string sql which
i built so this is the sql which got run
on the server which said insert into
student values and the roll number the
roll number was 2 and the name was jane
with single inverted commas because this
was a string and then age was 22. this
was the exact sql which got executed so
my sql has been executed my connection
has been closed if i go back to the pg
admin client and if i try to rerun this
query now i get two records so if you
remember this record was already there
but now i get the second entry which is
the new entry it just got inserted
because i did i ran the program and you
see the roll number two the name as jane
and the age as 22. so this was a very
simple example to show you how you can
do the jdbc correction but one of the
things which i still haven't covered is
the usage of the jdbc driver the jar
which i talked about so the way you are
going to add the jar is you go to the
project you right click on the project
you go to the build path go to the
configure build path and there you will
see different tabs source projects
libraries so go to the libraries tab and
select the class path here and you can
choose the add external jars option
click on this load your sql jdbc jar for
your particular database vendor for my
case it was post resql let me just
quickly remove this jar and show you
right from how it's done so this is how
it will look like for you you select the
class path you click on add external
jars you go to the location where you
have downloaded your jdbc driver jar for
your particular database select that
click open it will come here hit apply
and close that's how the jar is going to
be there if you don't provide the jar
your program is going to fail miserably
it is not going to work so make sure
that you have the jar and then only it
is going to be able to create a
successful connection and be able to
successfully execute the query remember
jdbc provides the specifications and
then the particular database vendor like
postgresql provides the jdbc driver
which has the implementation for that
jdbc api and that the java has this
uniform jdbc avi api and every database
vendor is expected to honor and
implement that api only so that java
developers can work on the jdbc contract
and everything should work as is let's
get started with generics in java so
before we go about generics let's
understand why do we need generics and
what what was the requirement that led
to the creation of generics so as we
know that when we work in any
object-oriented programming language we
created classes we create objects we
create variables and everything has a
type everything has a type and that type
is static the type cannot be changed
that's why we call java as as a strong
type checking language at compile time
it checks the types of the variables of
the classes at the compile time and if
the classes are mismatching or their
types are mismatching then you basically
get a compilation error but
what we see as we as we moved along we
saw that we were creating the similar
kind of functionality again and again in
different classes for example if there
is a login functionality which should
allow a person to log in and we should
also allow an application to log in then
these are the two different use cases
but the functionality still remains the
same so how would the login
functionality allow both of the types of
entities be it user or application to
get into the application or login into
the consumer application how do you do
that and that's what led to the creation
of generics that you can reuse the same
code with different types of inputs
remember the stress here is on the types
and that's what it is mentioned here
that we will like to reuse the same code
with different inputs we will just keep
changing the type parameters and we'll
keep using the same same code again and
again it has some benefits over the
non-generic code like we mentioned like
i mentioned earlier that when we work
with the non-generic code we have the
statically assigned types to the
variables and objects and if we use
generics then we don't have to do that
and at the same time you don't even have
to explicitly cast them we touched upon
this concept of uh generics in different
bits and pieces in different sessions
throughout this tutorial series where we
saw that whenever i was creating a list
i was supplying this type into these
brackets right and i told that this that
this is the generic type but now we'll
go deeper into this concept and we'll
see how we can create our own generic
types if java does not provide it so
with that let's move to an example and
see how we can implement our own generic
types to create generic code
where we can supply the types
dynamically so i've prepared an example
for this i've actually prepared two
examples for this and we'll go through
both of them one by one so here what i'm
doing that i'm creating any class you
can think of it as any class holding any
functionality which is applicable to
multiple entity types think of it as the
same login class which i just talked
about so if your class has a
functionality which should be reused by
many different types then one of the way
to not repeat the code or repeat the
class or repeat the functionality again
and again is to make that class use a
generic signature and how you do that
you write the class name and then you
put these brackets and you just type t
you can write any variable abc or
whatever you feel like but t is sort of
the default standard the java developers
have been using since generics was
launched so you put this t here now
whoever calls this class or whoever
whoever initializes this class will have
to supply the type of the class on which
this particular functionality is going
to get executed now remember the
collection examples i took i took in the
past series what if this was a list
class because we have used the exact
same syntax right we use list we put
brackets and then we wrote string and we
said okay now this list is a
list of strings if we said list of
integer then we just write integer in
these brackets and that list became a
list of integers so you see the same
list was being reused for different data
types and the exact same concept is
applied here for your custom classes and
your own custom functionality so i write
t here then i can do whatever with this
t i want so i just
put a reference of it inside the class i
create a constructor constructor is also
assigning the t type i do a get object
and that's all it's a very simple toy
example but just to get the point across
you can write as complex logic as you
want inside the class depending upon
your use case but this is just a
straightforward example that you can use
generics in the classes as well once you
do that then how do you initialize this
class so let's have a look at that as
well so i've just created a public
static void bin method inside the same
class obviously you can create this
method outside the outside this class as
well there's no stopping that logic but
but for the sake of simplicity i've just
put the main class here so it's a simple
public static void main method there i
am initializing the single generic
holder class the same class and here the
t type is of integer this t type can be
of anything else as well for example
your own student class can also be
supplied here and then the single
generic holder will become of student
type in this case i'm just using a
pre-built java class so this single
generic holder becomes of integer type i
give a reference i create an object and
i provide a value to the object because
you see the constructor is this whatever
t you supply so if the t is the integer
this t becomes integer and this obj is
going to hold the value 10 because
that's the constructor being called here
and after that you can do whatever you
want in terms of the logic here i'm just
i just have i just have a get object
method so i'm just calling that method
and printing the object that's all
similarly you can also initialize the
same class with the string type so you
see i'm reusing the same class in the
same functionality again and again for
different class types so this time i'm
using the string type instead of integer
and i'm supplying a string parameter
this time and this this constructor
still will work because this is generic
when you created with integer this
constructor this t became of integer
type and when you initialized it with
the string type this constructor started
accepting the string objects so just
supply a string called simply code and
then i call get object
so let's run this method so when we run
the main method from the first
invocation at line 16 and 17 when you
call the get object the value of the
object gets printed which is 10 for the
integer and then at line 20 the value of
the string gets printed which is simply
code so that's how you can use generics
inside a class or for a class now there
might be use cases where you have to
create a class which can accept multiple
types of generic types let's take an
example if you remember when we talked
about hashmap we had the exact same
situation so you had the key and you had
the value now key can be of any type any
data type it can be string integer
whatever and then value can also be of
any data type it can also be your custom
data types for example the key becomes a
roll numbers and the value becomes
student object so map is a situation
where you have two generic types so i'm
just trying to replicate that similar
kind of behavior that if you have to
create a class with two three as many
generic types as you want you can still
do that by just providing a comma here
you can go on doing as many generics as
you want in this example i'm using two
generics and then it again goes to the
same drill that i created references for
both t and u i have initialized both p
and u in the constructor and then i have
a display method which is going to call
the and display the obj1 and obj2's
values or their two string methods
basically because when you when you try
to call the object inside the
system.out.println method the by default
the tostring method of the object will
automatically get called so that's all i
have in this particular class so it's a
simple class accepting two different
types of generics and then calling the
display method and here is the public
static void main method for the same
here i am initializing the dual generic
class and here the t is string and u is
integer so these t and u are
assigned these class types and then i
create the class i again write the same
types and i provide the value so for the
string one i provide simply code for the
integer one i provide 10. this
constructor gets called obj1 gets the
value simply code and obj2 gets the
value 10 and then i call display method
there i am printing obj1 and obj2 so
let's run this method okay i'm getting
simply code in 10 because when i call
the display method at line 13 obj 1 gets
printed obj 1 is holding simply code
value and at line 14 obj 2 gets printed
or the 2 string method of the obj 2 gets
printed which is holding the value 10.
so this was a quick tour to tell you how
can you use generics you can obviously
use generics in the variable types as
well you can use generics in the method
argument types as well wherever you want
the simple idea is that one you would
like to reuse the functionality again
and again and second you would like to
you would not like to have a strong
strict type checking and like i said try
to relate these generic concepts with
the collection framework we listen
because collection framework is
completely built upon the concept of
generics whenever we initialize a list
or a map or a hash set or a linked list
or error list or anything we always
supply the type and the type is coming
from these uh if you look at the
implementation of error list class you
will see that let me see if i can open
that for you to show you how that looks
like if i go to an example
of collections and if i try to just open
the class you will be able to see that
yep so if i click on this list class you
see list of e type so here e is the type
which you are going to supply so in this
particular case when you say list of
integer this integer
gets
typed into e so whatever so this this
whole list class whatever operations you
are doing inside the list class will be
applied for the integer type so
similarly you can look at other
collection classes and you will always
see these generics everywhere in the
collection classes let's get started
with string handling in java so we have
been dealing with string types
throughout different sessions in this
whole series but in this session we are
going to look at lot of different
utility methods which the string class
provides string class is very versatile
in java and it provides lot of handy
functions which can help you manipulate
strings in multiple ways for example if
you want to trim a string or if you want
to append a string to another string or
if you want to find a particular
character at a particular index or if
you have an index and you want to see
what character is present at that
particular index or if you want to do
any other kind of pattern matching in
the string so string is very versatile
in that in that context and today we
will have a look at some of those
methods so i've just opened the java
docs api for string and you can see in
the method summary you will find a long
list of methods we will go through some
of these methods for example if i just
show you a snapshot of what i'm talking
about it has a care act method so you
provide a index and integer index and
this particular method will tell you
which character is present at that
particular index in the string remember
string is basically a zero based
character array zero index based
character array similarly you can also
call code point at which is going to
return the character in the unicode code
point at a specified index similarly
compared to method can be used to
compare two strings with each other
compared to ignore cases also there
which can compare two strings ignoring
whether they are in uppercase or
lowercase you can use concat method to
join two strings together you can use
the contains method to find if a
particular character or a particular
sequence of character exists in a
particular
string or not you can do a content
matching you can do copy you can also
see if a particular string ends with a
particular character or a sequence of
characters so there are tons of
different methods available here and
please do check out the api because like
i said this is going to come very handy
when you start writing real time
projects or the real life projects so
with that knowledge let's go to uh our
ide and let's have a look at some of
these examples in action so here also
you can obviously have a look at the
string class
from the ide itself just write string
and hit ctrl and you will see an
underline and a hyperlink so just click
on this and you in the string class will
be opened and you can actually read on
about the documentation of the whole
string class but we are not going to do
that we are going to have a look at some
real life examples of how we can use
different methods of the string class so
here i have created two strings str1 and
str2 str1 is holding a string which says
john is studying and str2 is holding a
string which says in college now the
first utility function which i'm going
to talk about is the length method so if
you want to find out what is the length
of this particular string then you can
just call the length method on the
string and that is going to return the
length of the current string let's see
that in action let me comment the rest
of the code and let's see this one in
action so if i run this program i get
the value 16. so if you count this one
two three four space is also counted 5 6
7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16. so you get
the exact length of the string when you
call the length method similarly another
method is concat method and concat
method is used to concatenate two
strings together concatenation basically
means joining two strings together so if
you want to join the string one and
string two then just call str1 dot
concat with the string you want to
append or you want to concat so the
concat method on the left heights left
hand side of the string is going to get
concatenated with the argument which you
pass in the concat method so let's see
that in action now and let's see the
result as well because i'm storing the
result of concatenation into a new
variable and printing that variable so i
get this whole text here and you see the
studying in just got merged there was no
space in between because there is no
space here if you just put it like this
and if you rerun this you will see the
proper space as well while concatenation
one of the things which i also want to
call out is strings are immutable in
nature when i say immutable it it means
that once you have created this str1
holding this value then st and then this
particular object's value pointing to
str
cannot be changed you cannot mutate the
strings if you try changing str's value
java is going to create a new object and
point str1 to that object but the object
which was created initially is not going
to be overwritten so remember that
concept that whenever you're doing
manipulations on the string the previous
string object still remains there it
doesn't get overwritten or it doesn't
get modified whenever you modify a
string you get a new object that's the
property of string so we saw the
concatenation let's move ahead this also
format method format method is used to
dynamically populate some parts of the
string for example if you have a long
list of students and if you want to
print the name of students then what you
can do here is that you can change as
you can assign those names to certain
variables and you can point or refer
those variables in the string with the
percentage syntax percentage s syntax
basically so the string.format method is
used to supply dynamic values inside a
static string so in this case this part
of the string is static where i'm saying
the name of the student is
then in the next string remember plus
also can concatenate it it is also doing
the exact same thing as the concat
method you can it's just a shorthand so
i'm creating first string then i'm
creating second string but here i'm
writing percentage s i will come to that
and then i have created one more string
where i'm using percentage b so what
happens that java format method supports
certain special type of references for
example if you want to dynamically place
a string you can use percentage s if you
want to dynamically place an integer
value you can write percentage d in the
format method similarly you can also
write other percentage f for for a float
value and there are more other
similar placeholders which are available
in the format method so do check out the
format method documentation if you want
to know what all percentage types or
variable types can be dynamically placed
inside the format method here i'm just
using percentage s and percentage d and
then once you have created the first
part of the format method which is
string with with dynamic placeholders
till this particular point then you put
a comma and you start providing the
values remember the sequence of the
values have to be exactly the same way
in which you have used them here so if
percentage s is coming first then you
have to supply a string value if
percentage d is coming after that after
the string value you have to provide an
integer value if there was another
percentage s after percentage d in the
same string then after 21 you had to
provide another string value so that's
the
contract which format method needs to
honor and if i run this particular
program and if i say if i try to see the
output let's try to see the output as
well and for the output i need to store
this whole string.formats output into a
variable so let's say i say string
r and then i can print r and see what
comes out so that's it let's run the
program now and now you will see this
line the name of the student is john
comma and the age is variable is 21. i
think it's coming because i've just
wrote variable is here but if you if you
remove this and if you say the age is
percentage d then you will get a nice
human readable output without any extra
formatting so the name of the student is
john and the age is 21 and that there
was a comma that's why you still see the
comma but this is the basic idea with
using the format method now another
method which i want to talk about is a
cad at method let me comment the
previous output so that we can follow
along so i'm just going to comment all
of this which we have covered already
and let's focus on the care at method so
caret method can be used to find the
character present at a particular index
in a string so whatever index you
specify in the caret method the
character present at that particular
index will be returned so when i say
str1 dot care at 5 remember strings are
0 based indexed character arrays so
0 1 2 3 4 5 at 5 i is present so this
car at method should return i so if i
run this particular program yes i see
the output as i now let's move ahead
with next example or the next api call
the next api call is that usage of
equals method where i can see if the two
strings are equal or not so here i'm
saying str1 dot equals str2 if both
strings are same it is going to return
true otherwise it is going to return
false so if i run this i get the output
as both strings are different it goes in
the else block because str1 and str2 are
different they are holding different
values so here the exact content of the
string is going to be matched the next
one is the index of method so index of
method can be used just for the reverse
functionality of care add in caret we
were supplying the index and getting the
character here we can supply the
character and get the index of it so
what what is going to happen that you
write the string dot index off and then
you supply the character where which for
which you want to find the index of so i
supply y here and if i run this
particular program for this line the
output is 12. let's see if the output is
correct so here if you try to find what
is sitting at the index number 12 in
this string so again 0 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 11 12. so yes y is present at
the 12th index and that's the output i
get what if you provide a character
which is not present in this particular
string that says z which is not there
and see what the output is in that case
you will get the output as minus one so
if the character is not present in the
string you will get the output as -1
another thing what if the
character is uh present more than once
in the string for example i is present
more than one time in the string so if i
write i here whether i get the index of
this i or this i let's see so i'm going
to run this program again and i get the
value 5 so
5 is basically this i because this is
definitely not 5 it's far
far further index so the first match of
the index is going to be returned in
terms of the index of method okay so
that was about the index of let's look
at the next one which is the replace in
replace it's as the name suggests you
can replace a character or a sequence of
characters in a string by calling the
replace method on the string on which
you want to do the manipulation and
remember you're doing the manipulation
here so the previous object is not going
to get overwritten but a new object is
going to get created so what i want to
replace is with r so in this particular
string i see an occurrence of s here so
this s should be replaced with r if the
replace functionality works as i just
explained so let's run this program and
yes i can say instead of s i see r being
replaced there and that's the usage of
the replace method next one is the split
method where if you want to split the
string into multiple elements so you
just call the split method and you
provide the separator here i am
separating the string whenever there is
a space i'm basically breaking up the
string into multiple sub strings that's
what i'm doing here or multiple strings
i would just call it as so whatever
separator you provide whenever the
string is going to encounter that
separator it is going to split one part
of it so in on providing the separator
space it means in this particular case
i'm going to get three items the first
breakup is going to go going to happen
here so the john part of it will go out
and this will go out in a separate
string then again between is and
studying i have another space so there
will be another break here so i should
get three elements if i call the split
method one element will be holding the
value john the second element will be
holding the value is and the third
element will be holding the value as
studying and then i'm printing all the
elements of the of the array remember
that split method returns a string array
so that's what i'm using here to store
the output of the split method and then
i'm just using the streams api to
iterate over this string array
outputting or printing the each element
of the array so let's run this program
okay so i can see three different
outputs through this
system.out.println first john then is
then studying like i said split method
is going to create a three element size
array of strings because i'm separating
it based on the space the last utility
function which i want to talk about so
this is the last one but i'm skipping
some of some more due to the interest of
the time but like i said do check out
the documentation to read or understand
more about other string utility methods
which i'm not covering here in this
session so the last one i'm going to
talk about is the substring method and
substring is basically going to take a
mini string out of the long string so
what if you want to trim the string what
if you have a long string and you only
want to get a part of the string so you
can specify the starting point you can
specifying the you can specify the end
point and whatever string characters are
present between the starting index and
the end index will be taken out from the
string and you can store that output
into a new string and print that so here
i'm calling the substring method
providing the starting index as one and
the ending index is five let's run this
program and interpret the output so i'm
getting the output as o h n so what is
happening here let's go back to the str1
so i said start with one remember string
is a zero based index so it starts with
zero one it starts with o because o is
present at the first index and then i'm
going up till five so one gets printed
whatever character is present at one
index get printed second index get
printed third index gets printed
fourth index gets printed which is just
a space and then the fifth index is i
which is not printed here so it means
that when you call the string substring
method then the end index position will
not be printed it starts from the
beginning index and it will go till
index mine end index minus one position
in terms of printing because if you
select this you'll see an extra bar here
because the space is also getting
printed so it is printing everything
before the fifth index it will not
include the fifth index character
remember that when you use the substring
functionality that the end index is not
included in the substring if you want to
include that you need to increase the
index by one so for example if you want
to print i as well then you have to
write it as index s6 and if you run this
then you will also see i now yeah so
that is how this
substring functionality works let's get
started with java.lang package so
java.lang package is one of the most
core and fundamental packages in java
which is provided out of the box to the
developer you never explicitly import
this package in your java program
because you don't need to java provides
this automatically the moment you create
a file with dot java extension or and
you have you are running that particular
program inside or on a jdk you get the
java.lang package automatically for
example when we were when we were
running the string handling demo i was
using the string class but i never
imported the string class you can see
there is no import for string because
string class is also part of the
java.lang package it's automatically
imported for you you never need to
explicitly import the package or any
classes of that package so this is going
to be more of a theoretical lecture
where we will just have a look at or a
quick overview of all the java.lang
package classes and other utilities you
don't need to remember all the classes
and utilities but this is just to give
you a sense of what all it contains so
in terms of the interfaces it has the
appendable interface autoclave auto
closable care sequence clonable
comparable if you remember we also used
comparable when we were writing the
comparable
implementation to compare different
objects in a collection so this also
comes automatically as part of the
java.lang package iterable runnable
again we use this in the in the
threading example so this also comes
automatically to you you never need to
import the enable class from the
java.lang package when we move to the
classes all the data type classes which
you can think of in terms of boolean
byte character class class loader
compiler enums even float integer long
math so all the classes which we were
using the the data type classes which we
were using in different examples are
also part of the java.lang package okay
so this is a long list long list it also
has a thread class so whenever you are
creating thread you again never imported
thread class but it still just worked
fine because there was uh
this was also coming as part of the
java.lang package there are also bunch
of enumerations which it provides in
terms of unicode thread state etc it
also provides exception classes like
arithmetic exception or or that the
different runtime exceptions which we
dealt with like array index out of bound
store class cast class not supported the
root exception class so a lot of
exception classes also come as part of
the java.lang package it also provides
some error classes if you remember when
we talked about the exception framework
you have the error types and you have
the exception types so it also provides
some error classes if you want to use
that you don't you never need to import
any of these classes and you will
automatically get them from the
java.lang package similarly it also
provides some annotations as well like
functional interfaces or you remember we
use this annotation a lot the add the
rate override annotation but we never
imported the override class or the
override annotation because it's part of
the java.lang package so this basically
tells us that there are a lot of
different classes utilities enums errors
exceptions data types which are provided
out of the box from the java.lang
package which makes our life so much
easier whenever we want to work with
java because we don't need to import the
very basic classes which
which we use very frequently and another
very important package is the java.util
package we have been using the java.util
package in all of the collections
examples and tutorials we walk through
in this whole tutorial series so let me
just open the java.util package for you
so if i go here to java.util
and
i will be able to see the java.util
packages different classes etc yes so
here is here it is the java.util package
and remember java.util package is not
imported automatically you have to
explicitly import the java.util package
to use the classes of it so it so that's
the difference between java.lang package
and java.util package that you cannot
you can use
the classes coming from the java.lang
package without explicitly importing
those glasses or importing the java.lang
package but java.util package is
something which you have to explicitly
import in your java program to make it
work or even make it compile so what
java.util provides first of all the
collections framework the whole
collections framework comes from the
java.util package so for example all the
interfaces which we use while we work
with the collections framework classes
interfaces like collection list set map
you can see the map interface you can
see the list interface with the generics
so all the interfaces which we use from
in the collections framework are present
in the java.util package similarly when
we talk about the glasses all the
concrete classes implementation of the
collections framework in terms of error
list linked list hash map hash set
preset tree map you will see all of
those classes here here we are covering
all the this is showing all the classes
summaries so you see some abstract
classes and you will also see some
concrete classes as you move further
down in this particular list so you see
hash map you see hash set hash table
linked hash map linked asset linked list
we used all of these classes while we
were going through the collections
framework tutorials so it provides all
of these and lot of other classes like
the scanner class which we covered in
the java project for taking the inputs
from the command line from the user uh
stack class again from the collection uh
some time classes and it also provides
bunch of enumerations like the locale
basically setting the language
categories for a particular program it
also provides some exceptions which we
used while we were working with the
collections framework so most of these
exceptions are or some of these
exceptions are related to the collection
classes for example the concurrent
modification exception gets thrown uh
whenever you your the whole execution
detects concurrent modification of an
object when such modification is not
allowed you will see other different
types of exceptions like illegal format
etc in this particular exception section
of this particular package then it also
provides just one error class as well so
this is what the java.util uh package
contains and just to refresh your memory
whenever we ran any collection demo we
always imported the java.ut classes you
can see this is all coming from
java.util so this is something which you
have to import without which your
program will not even compile so that's
also one of the difference between the
java.lang package and the java.util
package and that's pretty much all i
want to cover in this particular session
so
we basically did a quick tour of the
java.lang package and the java.util
package and like i said it's impossible
to cover all of that for all of the
classes and enums and interfaces and
errors and exceptions
with all the examples so i would suggest
you to just keep this in mind about the
java.lang package and java.util package
i told you the basic construct that
java.lang contains all the types the
class and the variable types or the data
types we dealt with and java.util
majorly contains all the collection
classes uh that's that's the that's the
basic uh thing which you need to
remember whenever you work with java and
your java.lang package never needs to be
imported but java.util package needs to
be imported always whenever you use the
util classes let's get started with
networking in java so when we talk about
the networking in java java has a whole
dedicated package called java.net
package which has all the different
classes which you need to have to write
a networking program in java so we'll
you will see bunch of classes with two
classes most important ones which are i
net four address and i net six address
so as you can see you can understand
that i net 4 address is the class which
can be used to represent the ipv4
addresses and inet 6 address class can
be used to represent ipv6 addresses and
then you can learn about sockets it also
has socket classes it has a lot of
interfaces the with the prominent one
being the networking interface there are
some high level apis for example the uri
class is there which can be used to
represent a universal resource
identifier as specified in the rfc and
this is just an identifier this doesn't
provide the means to access the resource
if you want to access the resource then
you need to use url which is the class
representing the universal resource
locator which is a slightly older
concept than uri but with url you can
hold the address as well as access the
address url connection is also one of
the class which is created from the url
class to set up a communication link
with the url and similarly http url is
for an http connection and you have
protocol handlers there are a lot of
interesting classes which
you can explore if you want to learn
more about what all networking support
java provides but when we talk about the
basic ones like ipv4 address the url uri
classes these are the ones which
generally most developers interact with
if you want to write a socket
programming uh socket program that's
used you can still do that with the
classes and interfaces support provided
by java so you can see bunch of
interfaces here cookie policy socket
option then in terms of classes you can
see again content handler cookie manager
http cookie i net four and i need six
address with the classes which i talk
about it also has a generic class but i
would always recommend to use one of
these if you know what address you are
dealing with uh the url connection the
jar url connection class proxy class
some bunch of socket classes uri url
classes and some enums and exceptions as
well which are related to networking
connections for example malformed url if
the url itself is is not correct then
you get a malformed url exception socket
exception if there's a socket timeout
exception then also you have a dedicated
exception for that so there are a bunch
of different exceptions uh classes enums
and interfaces available which you can
have a look at if you want to dig deeper
into it so i've also prepared a demo
where we will be using some of these
functionalities of these of this
particular package so let's jump to the
ide and see what i have built so here i
have created a class called networking
demo and what we are trying to do that
we will provide the simply launch url
and we will try to get bunch of
information about how this website is
hosted so you just create a simple
string variable and you can type any
string you can write
any favorite website of your choice here
and then we create the inet address
class and like i said you always use the
concrete implementation of the inet
address class which is in this case inet
4 address so i use the get by name and
we supply the url to get an inet address
object and what does inet address
contains it contains all the information
in terms of the internet address on
which that particular website is hosted
so you will see lot of different
functionality in this class let's
explore some of the functionality and
methods which are provided by the inet
address class so once you do this you
will get an inet address address object
if the url is correct if the url is
incorrect you will get a malformed url
exception anyways if you want to just
see the address of the ip address where
this particular website is hosted you
can call the get address method and if
you want to see the host address method
then you can call the get host address
now you might be wondering what is the
difference between get address and get
host address so let's get first that out
let me comment the rest of the code and
let's first focus on this particular
part so let me comment the local address
part as well we will come to that in a
while and i can just remove this comment
so we are printing the get address and
the get host address and let's see what
values do we get and how do we see if
it's a different value so this explains
right when we call init address dot get
address we just get all the values as we
know that when we deal with ipv4 address
the address has four values something
dot something dot something dot
something if you want to verify it just
go to your own laptop and you you will
be able to see some address like
192.168.something or something so that
uh so ipv5 address has four sections and
all the four sections will have some
values so if you use the get address
method and you try to convert this into
a string it basically will return an
array the get address method will return
an array which will look like this but
if you want to see it exactly in the
format in which the real world
networking protocols understand it then
use the get host address which is going
to show it exactly in the way in which
we write the ip address where we write
some integer dot some integer dot some
integer dot sum integer so that's the
difference between get address method
and get host address method same value
different representation the next
function which i'm going to talk about
is about local address and the local
address or the method name is is any
local address so this method is going to
tell me if there is a wildcard address
which is associated with this particular
host you can also see what this method
is doing from the documentation so if
you go to the documentation and if you
search for this particular method in the
inet 4 address class you will see it
says utility routine to check if the
inet address is a wild card address the
result will be a boolean which will
indicate if it has a wildcard address or
not so let's run this program and
understand if it has a wildcard address
no there is no wildcard address
associated for this particular website
similarly there is another method which
we can explore which is is link local
address so let's search for the
documentation of it first so this is the
class if you search it it will just show
you the exact class which is present
with the method and this method
provides basically a check to see if the
inet address is a link to a local
address within the domain of the website
so the result again will be a boolean if
it says true it means there is a link to
the local address and if it returns
false it means the address is not a link
local unicast address so let's see the
output of this in with respect to the
simply learned website so if i run this
program now i again get false so there
is no wildcard address attached or
associated with the website and it does
not point to a local unicast address
either is there a loopback mechanism now
these all are networking concepts and uh
since this is not a networking session
so i will not go deeper into what what a
loopback address
means in detail but to get to give you
an understanding of where it present and
how you can use this in java is what we
are going to focus on so if you want you
can always read about what is a loopback
address but if you want to know if the
url which you are pointing to is uh the
address which is returned by that
website has a loopback address or not
then you can use the is loopback address
method and this again returns true or
false based on whether it has a loopback
address or it does not have a loopback
address so if i run this particular
program we get the output false again so
no it the simplyland website does not
even also have a loopback address the
last one or the second last one which i
want to explore is the site local
address method so let's see what does
this method do let me just remove this
extra commented lines
so let's look at the documentation of
this method so this is a utility routine
to check if the init address is a site
local address the result is a boolean
indicating if the init address is a site
local address or false if the address is
not a cyclical site local unicast
address again this concept is again
a networking special concept for similar
to the loopback address so this is just
basically
showing if the site also has a
basically a local unicast address
associated with it or not so if you want
to see the site local address output i
have enabled that code and if you run
this particular program we get false for
that as well yes that means that the the
simple website is built with pretty good
practices there is no loopback address
there is no site local address which we
don't need for for this particular
website in this case
the last one is just a simple thing just
to see the code it's not much of a
relevance mostly the programs but just
to tell you that this is also available
so you can also see the hash code which
is contained by the inet address object
so we covered bunch of functionality in
this particular example we had a look at
the java.net package it has an inet 4
address class and i net 6 address class
lot of networking exceptions and
interfaces support as well and the
simple way to use it is to you point it
to a website call the get by name call
the get host address and you will get
the ip address in the exact format in
which the networking world deals with it
similarly you can call the get address
to just get an array of it just as we
saw here and then there are a lot of
utility functions available in the inet
address class like is any local is link
local is loop back is site local and
there are actually more if you look at
this class you will find more methods
here in terms of what like for example
it also has multicast address this is
basically to check if the init address
is an ip multicast address so there are
a lot of different methods here there
are some mc methods as well which will
check which are specially created for
the multicast address scenarios so a
utility routine to check if the
multicast address has a global scope if
it has a local scope or sorry it has a
node scope basically or it has a link
scope or it has a side scope so there
are a lot of different methods available
for the multicast as well which you can
have a look at and we already covered
the get address the get host address and
the hash code address classes there are
some url classes as well like i
mentioned url ui classes are also very
important classes which you might need
to use whenever you are you are building
a connection with a particular
application based on their url if you
are doing socket programming there are
socket classes available which you can
also use while using the networking
concepts in java so you can build a
pretty decent and robust application
using the networking classes and the
networking support provided by java to
build a
networking application let's get started
with image handling in java so we deal
with images on a daily basis and you
will often be required to deal with
image handling in java programs as well
where you might need to re read an image
or write an image or load an image into
memory and do other kind of
manipulations on the images so java does
provide support for image handling as
well and uh
you can pretty much load up any type of
image be it a gif image a beta png or be
it a jpeg image basically it converts
into a java 2d image to render it and it
basically creates a byte representation
of the image to serve and save the
contents so in this section we are going
to talk about the image handling aspects
of java and to do that uh there are
broadly two classes which java provides
as you can see in this official
documentation the first one is
java.awt.image class and the second one
is java.awt.image.bufferedimageclass
which extends the image class so this is
basically the superclass as you can see
here which you can use to represent any
kind of graphical image as a 2d array of
pixels and buffered image is a concrete
implementation of the image class which
you can use to construct instances of
the class and buffered images is sort of
the i would say the de facto standard or
the go-to class whenever you are dealing
with any kind of image rendering uh
tasks in a java program and we will also
have a look at how we can use the
buffered image class to basically read
and a sample image and also write a
sample image to a file system so
you can read more about this in the
documentation and
these are there are also bunch of
documentations available in terms of how
you can read it how you can load it into
the program how you can draw an image
how you can create and save the image
etc and like i mentioned we will be
covering some aspects of it in today's
demo as well so this was a very brief
theoretical introduction about image
handling and like i always mention if
you want to know more about this do
check out the official documentation of
of java where you can learn more about
the image handling classes and utilities
so with that let's move to the
demonstration part so i have prepared a
demo here which talks about image
handling so i have created a class
called image handling demo which has a
public static void main method and i'm
just giving some some sample
dimensions for the image in terms of
width and height here and then as i
mentioned that we will be using the
buffered image class so i'm creating an
a reference for the buffered image it's
currently assigned to null so basically
there's nothing and then i am calling
the method read from file so like i
mentioned you can you mostly will be
dealing with reading from an image or
writing to an image so here we will look
at both of the aspects as to how you can
load an image from your file system into
a java program and then write it back to
the file system from your java program
so let's first look at the read from
file method which will tell us how we
can read a java file so i provide some
sample dimensions these dimensions will
vary based on your use case and i supply
the buffered image object inside that i
have created a try block and in the try
block the first thing you need to do for
image handling is to basically create a
file object because image is also
technically just a file right so you
provide the file image path here at this
particular location so let's go to the
sample image part this is the
destination path and let me open the uh
sample image path as well which is
somewhere in the c drive so this is the
image which we are loading this is the
path which i have mentioned which is c
sample dot jpg so let's first have a
look at the image as well as to what
this image contains so this image is
basically from a from a clinical trial
and
showing some blood sample or some
vaccine bottles which is probably the
very uh popular image nowadays because
we are living in this pandemic world so
this is the sample image which i have
chosen to read and then i will load this
into the java program and then we'll try
to write it back to the file system to a
destination location so this is where my
image is present in the c drive named
with sample.jpg and this is what i've
supplied here so you just need to supply
it in double quotes remember when you're
dealing with windows file system you
always have to use double forward
slashes which is different if you're
working with a on a mac machine or
you're working on a linux system where
only
this will work fine so that's a bit
awkward thing which which windows has
and you have to respect the operating
systems restrictions or way of doing
things so once you have loaded the file
or created the
sample.jpg file object then the next
thing we are going to do is we are going
to create an object of the buffered
image remember we just created a
reference we did not create an object
yet of the buffered image class and now
is the time to do that so we supply the
width we supply the height and then we
supply the type of the image let's go to
the constructor of this image to see
what this image type means so this image
type can be basically the type of the
created image which comes from the color
space so whether it's an rgb image or a
rgb image or bgr image or a byte gray
image there are multiple different types
of images in the media space and
whatever type of image you have you need
to basically supply that image type in
this particular argument so in my case
it was an argb image so i supplied that
particular if you click on this you will
see that currently it's inside java an
8-bit rgba image basically has a static
constant which is denoted by two you can
read more about this inside the buffered
image class documentation is as well so
once i've supplied that my buffered
image object is ready which has all the
details dimensions and the types of the
image now the next thing is that you
need to fill this image object with the
file so you basically need to read the
file and store the output of this read
operation into the buffered image object
then what will happen that along with
this information whatever is present
here will also be added to the same
buffered image object so to read a
image or simple a file java provides an
i o utility which is called image i o
and there is a read method available
which is a static method on this
particular class as you can see i'm
calling the class dot method name here
and then you supply the sample file name
once you have done that then it will
basically be reading the whole image
into a 2d byte array and copying that
over into this buffered image object
once that is done if this particular
line is successfully executed then you
will get this message which will say
reading complete and it will try to
print some hash code of the image object
and after that if if there's any
exception in this block for example this
particular line may raise an exception
or this particular line may raise an
exception if the file does not exist
then you need to have the i o exception
caught remember i o is a checked
exception so if you are using these
operations file new file and
imageio.read you need to catch the i o
exception because it's a checked
exception so either you need to catch it
or you need to re-throw it these are the
only two options you have with the
checked exception so once we have done
all of that if everything goes fine if
everything is happy till line 35 then we
just return the image object and our
read from file operation will be done
going back to the main method once the
read operation is done the next thing
i'm going to do is writing this image
object to a new destination file so
let's see what is happening in this
write to file method because this is the
method which is responsible for writing
this image to a new destination location
so i've created a public static void
void method inside the same class where
the public static void main method is
present as you know that static methods
can only call other static methods
that's why this has this had to be
static and i'm supplying the same image
object which was returned from the read
operation that goes in as the argument
of this particular method and again i'm
using a file object and this time i'm
providing a destination location where i
would like to write this image so this
is the destination location i've chosen
which is f drive java tutorials folder
and the image should be stored with the
name out dot jpg so this is the location
there's already already an out.jpg here
so let me just remove it so that we can
observe the output so we create the file
object after that we again use the image
i o utility
we call our static method static utility
method called write we supply the whole
image object we supply the image type
extension and we supply the output
location again if i take you to the
signature of this you take the rendered
image you take the format name which is
jpg and the output location so these are
the three things which you need to
supply once you call the right method on
the image io utility class image io is a
very handy class and do remember this
class whenever you are dealing with uh
the image handling operations it will
provide lot of static convenience
methods so we write this file uh write
this image object to a file to a
destination location and if everything
goes fine in these two lines we will get
this message which will say writing
complete if anything goes wrong we again
catch the i exception and the exception
will be printed here that's all is
happening in this particular program
where we are reading from file and we
are writing to the file reading it from
here and writing it on this particular
location so let's run this program and
see if we are able to read from file
successfully and also write it to the
specified location so run as java
application it's a slightly memory heavy
operation so it takes a bit of time
because the whole image needs to be
loaded into memory be very careful about
that it might eat up your large portion
of your ram if the image is too heavy so
here it says reading complete and then
it prints the hash code details of this
particular object and then it also
executed the write to file method and it
said writing complete so just to
show you the reference back again this
is what we read sample.jpg and c drive
and if i go to the f drive java
tutorials where i provided the output
location i do see an outdoor jpg here
which which was not there earlier and if
i double click on this it's exactly the
same image so java was able to read the
image and render the exact same image by
converting that 2d byte array
representation back to an image exactly
the same for there's no change in this
image so this was a very short
enlightening tutorial for you to show
you how you can use image handling
classes for example the image io class
and the buffered image class to do basic
image handling operations obviously you
can do more complex operations with it
as well but for the demonstration
purpose i've just kept it simple let's
get started with concurrency utilities
in java now concurrency is a huge topic
and it's not possible to cover this into
a 10 or 15 minutes tutorials so treat
this particular session as an
introductory session where i will talk
about some of the most relevant classes
which you need to know when you talk
about concurrency we have been talking
about this whole concept of concurrency
programming throughout the thread
tutorials as well and the basic idea is
that you would like to do multiple
things at the same time that's the basic
idea now in that context java does
provide lot of utilities and packages
especially the
java.util.concurrent package is one of
the most popular package which you need
to use whenever you are dealing with
concurrency programming paradigms in
java so with that let's have a look at
what does this
java.util.concurrent package contains so
broadly it contains lot of utility
classes which can be very useful for you
when you are writing the concurrent
programming code apart from that it will
also provide some basic ideas around the
locking functionality and the atomic
packages as well when we talk about
locks again we discussed about locks
when we talked about the whole sync
thread synchronization concept as well
and it basically marries very well with
the whole concept of locks and atomic
packages as well atomic is again a
different topic which is used for thread
safe types basically but whenever you
will hear about concurrency utilities be
it in your discussions or be it in your
interviews you will be seeing a
discussion happening around executors
you will hear these terms like executors
executor service future completable
future callable all of these you will
hear the name of all of these classes
quite frequently so we these classes
were first introduced in java 8 and have
been there since then to support the
concurrency programming paradigm so i
will talk about these three classes
broadly in today's session and we'll
have a look at a demonstration of these
three classes as well uh let's first
talk about executor technically it's an
it's an interface it's not a class
though i said that it's a class but it's
basically an interface an executor is
basically a very simple interface which
will help you define the sub systems
which you want to which you would like
to create with the help of threads may
be including thread pools or if you want
to do a disk reading and writing
operation in an insynchronous way or you
want to create some sequence of task
frameworks as well so executor will
provide you a very lightweight framework
to do all of that especially around
thread pooling and asynchronous io is is
where it shines most because in your
computer you have limited resources and
you would like to uh dedicate a certain
pool of threads for a particular task or
for a particular executor object so with
that and the second class which we would
like to know about is executor service
an executor service will provide a more
asynchronous task execution framework
and this is probably the class which you
will be using whenever you're dealing
with asynchronous programming in java
asynchronous programming basically means
that you submitted a particular task but
you did not wait for it to be completed
you did not hang your process or your
thread for that particular task to be
completed it's very simple it's very uh
easy to relate this to a real life for
example if you are
you know there are times when you do two
things at the same time for example uh
let's take a very very simple example if
you're just boiling milk on on your gas
stove so you put the milk on the gas
stove and then you move out for a couple
of minutes to do some something else for
example maybe checking your mobile for
new emails or or doing some other work
doing maybe just doing some laundry so
uh you are doing you you submitted the
milk boiling task then you moved away
from that task because you know that
this particular task is going to take
some time and you utilize your time
somewhere else that's what we mean by
asynchronous programming and executor
service will provide you with constructs
to create a similar behavior in your
java program as well so remember about
executor and executor service we will
look at the implementations later where
we can talk about that another
interesting class which i would not
which i would like to talk about is
future if we have it here yeah so future
is another class which we will be
looking at and future is basically uh to
fetch the result of the submitted task
again taking the same knife example of
the milk milk boiling example so
it would be great right if if there is
some mechanism or some alarm which just
sets off the moment the milk is is is
boiling and it's about to be spilled out
it would be great to know that in that
in advance via some alarm or something
so future provides that kind of a
carrier or that kind of a holder where
you submitted a particular task you
moved your threads to something else you
did something else and then you can
check with the future object and future
object will tell the status of their
submitted task whether it is completed
or whether it's still in progress once
it is complete then you can fetch the
result of that submitted task based on
with the future object so that's the
concept of future so remember executor
service and future they will work quite
hand in hand because executor service
will be used to submit the task and
future will be able to fetch the result
of that particular task asynchronously
so that was about a quick theory you can
read more about it in the documentation
you can see an executable service future
class what does what does this basically
in this class do uh but to have a look
at or or get a greater sense of this
let's have a look at our demonstration
of it to understand these classes better
so let's move to uh the eclipse ide to
look at an example let me close all the
classes and just open a relevant one so
yeah so let's first deal with the
executor interface itself so if i just
minimize this one here i've created a
main class and i've created a public
static void main method and you see two
static methods here executor invoke and
executed service invoke i'm basically
showing you how you can use executor and
executor service so if you're just using
executor then how you would do that is
basically you are going to create a
reference of the executor and then the
executor needs a basically an executor
object because it's an executor
reference so you need to supply an
executor object so either you can supply
an inner class right here or you can
call you can create a executor type of
class which i've created here which is
called caller class so i've created a
class called caller which implements the
executor type and execu the moment you
write implements executed it will force
you to override the execute method and
inside the execute method you are going
to run your own thread so this is how
the current thread or the executor's own
thread will be running so once you have
done the initialization then you can
call the execute method on the executor
class remember you got this object so
you can call the executor execute method
on the executor object here and inside
this you can provide this particular
lambda function implementation which is
going to ask you what exactly you want
to do when i run this particular thread
so when i run this thread when java runs
this particular thread what do you want
java to do that's something which you
will provide here so this is how you can
use it's a very simple example like i
said uh
this if i build a more complex example
it will take a lot of time and lot of
other concepts to cover so treat this as
an introductory session and if you can
basically try to run a very simple
example of this writing whatever complex
logic you want to write while the thread
is running and put that into this
execute similarly if you if you want to
use executor service for doing the
asynchronous operations then it will
follow the same way but there are some
differences along the way as well so
this is the method which is showing the
executor service implementation or the
way of using executor service so again i
create a reference of executor service
and then here you see i'm saying
executors dot new fixed thread pool with
a size of 10. so that's the power of
executor service it is going to create a
pool of threads dedicated to itself to
do the tasks whichever are written
inside here so whatever you write here
these thread pool will be utilized to
execute that particular task you can
assign the size of the thread pool based
on how many threads you need there are
multiple static utility methods like
there is one new fixed thread pull which
i've used but if you just do control
enter you will see cached thread pool a
single thread execution a new work
stealing pool so like i mentioned there
are a lot of classes interesting classes
here which you can use for simplicity
i've just used a fixed thread pool here
once you get the executor service object
then here you call execute but here you
will be calling the submit method and
then the drill goes exactly the same way
that you write the lambda function
implementation inside here basically the
functional interface implementation and
you provide your own implementation code
which you would like to run whenever you
call the run method whenever this
executor service calls the run method on
that particular thread you can actually
go to the submit method and you will see
it accepts a runnable it basically
accepts a thread object so whatever you
write inside this particular code will
be the public void run implementation of
that particular thread class if you
don't
if you don't remember how threnable
works please go back to my threading
tutorial and watch that where i
explained the runnable interface and the
run method in detail so that's what we
are doing here so this is for executor
and this is for executor service so
let's run this program and yes i mean
nothing because i'm not doing anything
much apart from just doing sis outs here
and that's what you see here the
executor's example and the executor
service exam so this was about executor
and executor service now let's deal with
another interesting uh class of
of called future which i said that i
will also talk about so for that i have
created a separate demo because it
deserves a separate demo it's a very
interesting class so let me just make it
full screen yeah so i've created a class
called future demo which has a public
static void main method and again i'm
doing this
executor service initialization but this
time i'm using a new single thread
executor now what does this does this
this will basically create an executor
which will use a single worker thread
operating from an unbounded queue
remember even if this single thread
terminates due to let's say a failure
during the execution before the before
the graceful shutdown a new one will
automatically be spawned and will take
its place if the execution is still
pending so that's the power of single
worker thread from an unbounded queue
that's what i've used here based on your
use case you can use other ones as well
like i mentioned earlier then uh i have
the executor service object with me and
similar to the previous example i'm
going to call the submit method and
inside the submit method i need to
provide the runnable class runnable
interfaces implementation and that
implementation will basically be of the
public void run method and this is what
i want to do in my run method where i'm
sleeping the thread for 10 seconds
thread.sleep method takes milliseconds
values as the parameter so this is 10
000 which means 10 seconds so i'm
sleeping this thread or pausing this
thread for 10 seconds and then returning
a string called completed this is what i
am doing in the executor service dot
submit implementation the result of it
is going to be a future object remember
the result of the submit task is going
to be a future object so i store that
future reference here and then at line
20 i'm using the same feature or future
object to ask java to check if this task
is done and the way you do that is just
by calling is done so till the time
there's a negation condition till the
time the task is still in progress
because this mean future is not done
because i've put a negation then just
print this out where you say the task is
still in progress it's still not
complete and you pause this particular
thread remember this was a different
thread if you you pause this particular
thread for 500 millisecond or basically
half a second and you again check this
condition if it's still not done you
print this again pause for half a second
again check this till the time feature
dot is done becomes true when future dot
is done becomes true that means that
this particular task is completed now
you see i mean generally when we execute
the programs the execution happens
sequently sequentially that after line
17 the control will automatically flow
to line 20 and before the control can
reach line 20 everything above line 17
has to be completed that's that's
basically synchronous programming for
you but when you talk about asynchronous
programming using the power of executor
service and future objects we can do
something here which will go into a
separate thread and then you can
continue your execution here so this can
be in a different method altogether
where you submit something and this is
basically checking the status of this
task understand this very well this is
very important concept that it's not a
it's though it's a sequential execution
after line 17 line 20 is getting
executed but line 20 is not waiting for
everything above line 17 to be finished
it will continue that's the power of
asynchronous programming so here we are
checking this and once the feature the
future dot is done says true then we say
task completed we and then you probably
would like to fetch the result of this
particular task right and for that
future provides a method called future
dot get this is going to pick the future
object state and whatever you are
returning from here will be returned
here and then i'm printing the result so
if everything went fine this result
should say completed because that's what
i'm returning from this future object
and always remember to shut down your
executor service to release the thread
pool which you created here i've also
put a catch block here because i'm using
the thread.sleep method which will ask
you to handle an interrupted exception
and then there is an executor service
exception which is execution and a
timeout exception as well there are
other interesting methods as well on the
future class future object sorry which
is like future.cancel where you can
cancel explicitly a future task which is
currently in progress you can check the
status of it by calling is done which
i've used here you can also call is
cancel to check if the user or some
other process explicitly canceled the
execution of the submission of the
executor service task so hope this is
you are able to understand the flow of
it that these block and these block will
program will execute them but they will
run in different threads so let's see
what happens now i'm going to run this
particular program and if i bring this
here you see the task still in progress
keeps getting called so we submitted the
task here and now this block is getting
executed this block kept getting
executed so this task did not finish
right the thread.sleep was this this
thread this whole thread was sleeping
for 10 second but line 20 did not wait
for 10 seconds it continued execution
and it kept checking the future object
10 times at least or till the whole 10
second sleep was taken away and one once
that once this thread woke up it
returned completed feature dot is done
became true and it came out and it said
task completed so that's what we get
here and at the end in the result you
get completed which is which is what you
returned from here so this is the power
of asynchronous programming please like
i mentioned please do read about more
about these classes and how they work
and what is the paradigm of asynchronous
programming it does make debugging a bit
hard at times but it's a very
interesting concept to be used in
concurrent applications let's get
started with regular expressions or
regex in java you may hear people
calling it as as regex or regex doesn't
matter you can call it anything as as
you want till the time you have the
concept understood in the right way i'll
just call it as regex so when we talk
about regex let's understand why do we
need them and what are how java actually
provides support for that so the basic
idea behind regular expressions is is to
find a pattern in a in a text corpus if
you have lot of strings available if you
have any kind of text any kind of string
and if you would like to find a
particular pattern saying okay does this
whole text paragraph contains any
character or contains any number or
contains any special characters or
contains characters after numbers or
numbers after characters so if you would
like to find those kind of patterns in
in your text corpus then you can then
that concept is called regular
expression finding and java provides the
support for that particular regular
expression finding through a package
called java dot util dot regex package
so this is the package which you would
need to use when you want to do any kind
of regular expression finding in that
text now you may want you may be
thinking that why do i need to use this
i already have the string handling
methods right you can do substring you
can find a particular character in the
string etc but that is limited because
it only and only provides string methods
ways to manipulate and find and replace
strings but regex is generic you can
literally find any kind of character in
your string it can be a special
character it can be a square bracket it
can be a multiply sign it can be a
divide sign it can be like i said
integer uh capital letters small case
letters so any kind of pattern you would
like to find
java.util.x can be used to find that
kind of pattern now this package is very
interesting and it provides lots of
classes and again this is a very very
very big topic and very complex topic so
we will just scratch the surface of it
and like i always say whenever you would
like to read more about it go back and
read the documentation currently the
documentation i've opened is for version
8 but when you are reading it you can go
for the latest java edition uh
documentation so with that let's talk
about some of the interesting classes
which we will be dealing with and we
must know when we talk about regex in
java so i already explained what are
regular expressions uh let's go to the
interesting classes the first class
which we need to know about is the
pattern class so pattern class or an
object of the pattern class will
basically be representing a compiled
regular expression so you write your
regular expression in a certain way
regular expression has its own language
i would say to write the pattern for
example if you would like to write a
pattern saying that find a
check if this particular text paragraph
has the characters first then the
integers then the characters then this
particular special character so that is
your pattern you write that pattern then
you need to compile that pattern to
compile that pattern you can use the
pattern class this this class generally
does not provide any kind of public
constructors to you so you cannot
initialize the pattern object explicitly
but to create a pattern you first you
need to basically call the static
methods a static method named as compile
so compile is the method which you need
to use to compile your regular
expression which will then return the
pattern object once you have compiled
your written your pattern and you
compile your pattern the next class
which you need to know about is the
matcher class matcher class will provide
that particular engine framework which
will understand and interpret the
pattern and then will try to find that
pattern on the text paragraph which
you're supplying and it will result in
true or false if it finds that pattern
it will say true if it's not finding the
pattern it will say false so that's the
basic idea so you need to you need to
know about the pattern class and you
need to know about the matcher class so
it also does not the matcher class also
does not provide any kind of public
constructors and you obtain a matcher
object by calling the matcher method on
the pattern option so once you created a
pattern object just call the matcher on
that particular object and that will get
you a matcher object and it then you can
use that object to find the patterns in
that particular text corpus there is
also a dedicated exception which is
called pattern syntax exception which
will be
thrown whenever you have written the
regular expression syntax incorrectly
like i said it has it has its own
language so you need to write the
expression in a way regular expressions
are supposed to be written and supposed
to be understood i will touch upon that
in a while but that's that's the basic
idea about the three classes now when
when you would like to find a pattern it
can be a string pattern it can be some
characters it can be some predefined
characters some quantifiers you can also
create sub groups within the regular
expression so there is a like i said
there is a tons of functionality which
is available in this particular concept
and we will just cover some of the
relevant ones or just just run through
some of these concepts and then i will
switch to a demonstration for example if
you talk about the string literals then
you can do the string matching for
example if you want to find this
particular word or this pattern this is
just a text pattern right so if you
would like to find this particular text
pattern in the text string then you can
write this particular text pattern as a
string pattern inside the pattern object
so that's that's about the string
literals now let's move to some
interesting ones like like meta
characters and the meta characters are
very interesting because they have a
special meaning for example if you write
your regular expression like this where
you say cat and then you say dot then
when you are applying this particular
regular expression to find the match
into a string it is only going to find
the match for c a t it is not going to
find a match for c a t dot because dot
is a meta character in regular
expression it has a special meaning it
does not mean dot but it has a special
meaning and that special meaning
basically means that even though the dot
is not present it will basically mean
that after cat it can be any character
so the meta character dot means any
character which is why you see this
snatch succeeds because it will search
for this pattern which it matches and
after that it can be any character it
doesn't care so even if it's s or d or
whatever it will say true because c80
was found a match so dot means any
character after the pattern you have
specified similarly there are a lot of
other characters special characters or
meta characters like the ones which have
been listed here question mark star plus
dot on and all of these have their own
dedicated special meaning they are not
your your normal uh arithmetic operators
or other operators they have their
special meaning when you are dealing
with meta characters so do read about
them in detail and i will be using a bit
of meta characters in the example as
well then the character classes are also
very interesting uh similar to the
example which i told you before if you
want to find a particular string or a
particular integer into a into a text
corpus then you can use the character
class patterns for example you just put
a square brackets and you write abc this
means that it will try to find exactly
abc in the string if you put a cap in
front of abc then it will try to match
any character or find any character
except a b or c so it's a negation
similarly if you specify small a to z
and capital a to z it means any
character can be there between small
case a to z and capital case a to z a to
z inclusive similarly you can provide
specific ranges like a through d or m
through p so only the characters which
will match the union of this condition
will be returning true and rest of the
uh if that if this particular uh pattern
is violated then you will get false so
similarly there are you can build lot of
complex combinations and permutations
with these uh special meta characters
and character classes do read about
these in detail if you are curious to
know about it and there is tons of
materials available on this on internet
which you can read about to learn more
about similarly there are predefined
character classes as well dot is
something which i already explained
which means any character then you can
use slash d to find a digit in a
particular string or a particular text
corpus slash capital d is for non-digit
or you can use the classic negation
condition as well slash s is for a white
space character slash capital s is for a
non-white space character word non-word
so there are a lot of different examples
so i think by now you would have built a
decent understanding of what i'm trying
to tell you is that you can specify
these patterns compile them and then use
the matcher so let's move to a very
simple demonstration it's not a complex
example but very simple example just to
get the point across so i'm creating a
regex string here and this is the
pattern i've specified i'm saying any
character star means any number of
characters so it can be anything here
then the string the the pattern expects
an alphabetical uh string or
alphabetical section after that the
alphabetical section should be followed
by a numerical section and after the
numerical section again it can be any
character so this is my pattern i create
a simple string with this regex pattern
and like i mentioned in the
documentation you call pattern.compile
to compile the regular expression so i
compile the regular expression i get the
pattern object and after again as for
the documentation it said that you can
call the matcher method on the pattern
object to get a matcher object so i say
pattern dot matcher and i provide my
string on which i want to test it so
i've just put a random string where
there are some integers then there is
some alphabets and then again there are
some integers once you have got the
matcher object just call matcher.find
this will return a boolean where you can
test whether the uh the matcher
found a hit in the text corpus or not if
it found a match the match found will be
true and if it didn't found find the
match you will get a false value in this
result so with that understanding let's
run this program so i get the output
match found why did i get that because i
said that start with anything so it
started with anything i don't care what
it is it's an integer or any special
character i don't care after that there
should be some alphabets so there are
some alphabets and right after alphabets
there should be some numbers so again
there are some numbers and after that
there can be any character 0 or more
characters so there is nothing here
that's why you see a match found let's
do an interesting test here let me do
this i put a to z again here so now i'm
saying start with anything have
alphabets have numbers and again after
numbers you should have some alphabet
which is not the case here because you
start with something you have alphabets
you have numbers and after numbers the
string ends there is nothing after that
so let's see what happens now you get a
match not found because this particular
pattern when got compiled and got
applied on this particular string did
not find the string following the regex
pattern which you have specified so this
is a very simple example to show you how
you can build patterns you can use
groups concepts as well to group the
patterns it can get very very complex
and very very nasty so use them very
wisely very carefully
and do read about the documentation and
other examples which i talked about to
get more understanding and more
comfortable with regex let's get started
with nio packages in java now let's
first understand why why do we need this
package and where will be using this
package let's talk about the ware first
you can use the nio package to read from
a file or write to a file now let's talk
about the why because the obvious
question will be that we already have
the i o package in java right where you
can where you can use the classes from
that particular package to read from a
file or write to a file then why do we
need an
another package doing exactly the same
thing as nio so the basic reason for
launching the java.nio package was
providing the multi-threading
capabilities to the io library and we
could not do this in the existing io
library because we had to probably
rewrite and change the functionality of
it that's why java created a new library
called new package called java.nio
package and this package is basically uh
i mean if you if you understand what nio
means here generally as per the popular
perception it means non-blocking io that
you don't want to block your threads
while you're reading to a file or
writing to a file classically niu meant
networking i o but as per the popular
perception people know is that know it
as non-blocking i o so the basic idea is
because whenever you are read reading a
file or writing to a file the thread
gets blocked until the whole file is
written or until the whole file is read
so the nio package provides an
improvement over that it provides an
improvement in a way that you can read
the file into a different thread but at
the same time move on to another thread
and right to a file so you get this
multi-threading capabilities and
non-blocking capabilities out of the box
from the classes provided by java.nio
package so that's the brief about this
package now some of the popular classes
which you will be dealing with and some
of the concepts which you need to know
about niu package are buffers and
channels these this is probably the core
concept of the whole nio package of how
channels and buffers work so let's say
you are trying to read something then
the read operation will be happening
from the channel into the buffer and
similarly the write operation will be
happening in the reverse way which means
to the channel from the buffer so that's
how the buffer and channel work together
that whenever you are trying to write
something you have to first open a
channel create a buffer and then you can
read from the channel into the buffer
and similarly when you're writing to the
buffer you again have to go via the
channel route so channel is that route
basically buffer is basically just a
plain container for the data and channel
is basically representing the connection
to the entities which are capable of
performing the iu operation so think of
channels as as a pipe a
channel literally basically if you if
you understand the english meaning of
channel that's exactly what we mean by
here that it provides just a means to an
end it provides sort of a wire to the
buffer and then you also have selectors
and selection keys classes which
together with selection channels work to
provide the non-blocking i o
functionality there are some other apis
interesting apis as well like car set
and some more but i will not go into the
detail of that because if you know about
buffers and channels and selectors then
we will be able to figure out what
exactly we would like to do with this i
would also like to talk a bit more about
the buffer class so if you go to the
buffer classes operations the popular
operations you will see there will be
the read operation which is for reading
the files basically or reading the
content of the file this works on the
byte stream concept first of all so to
read the bytes from the file you will
call the read method there's also a very
interesting method called flip which i
will be using which makes a buffer ready
for the new sequence of operations so
once you have done something and you
want to let's say you read a particular
file and you have come to the end of the
file now you would like to reset the
buffer and go back to the beginning of
the file then you can use the flip
method for that particular piece to
bring the current position back to the
position to the zero index or to the
starting of the file so
that's about read and flip and we will
have a look at some of the other methods
and there are a lot of interesting
classes in this nio package do read
read about the documentation and check
out the other methods as well to learn
more about this package but the basics
are like i said channels buffers some
methods of the buffers and there's also
a path class which is used to basically
provide a particular path to a directory
which i will not be covering in this
example but something good to know so
with that understanding let's move to an
example and understand how we can work
around with this nio package so for that
i have prepared an example where i will
be writing a reading from a file and
then writing to a file so i have a main
method here the first section here
basically is about reading from a file
and the second section is about writing
to a file so let's go through all of
both of these sections one by one to
understand what is happening so in the
read section i use the file input stream
class from the i o package i'm still not
using the paths class here just to show
you that both to both of them still can
work together if you want to use the old
constructs so use the same file input
construct to read a file called
source.txt which is present at this
particular location in my directory and
this source.txt has has just a one line
of text nothing more so i i basically
create the file input stream object and
then i create a channel because we are
dealing with files so you create a file
channel if you're dealing with network
socket then you might have a socket
channel so that's also something which
you need to know about that this nio
package is is generic it can be used for
any kind of communication of reading and
writing not specifically to file
handling so we create a file channel
object here by calling file input stream
dot get channel it's that simple once
you call that you will get a reference
or the object basically of the file
channel then the next thing is to create
the buffer like i mentioned that
channels and the buffer are the two main
tools through which you work with an nio
library so we create a byte buffer and
we allocate some starting size to it
just some some threshold size so you can
put it any number which you think is
practical for your file and your further
use case here i've put just one zero two
four bytes or one megabyte because my
file is pretty small so i just put that
and initialize the red read buffer and
then i call read channel dot read
operation so the file channel object you
created you just call the read method on
this particular channel and supply the
buffer and then it is going to read the
file wire the channel into the buffer
and this read method is going to return
a result to denote if the file was
written successfully or not i'm just
putting printing assist out here just a
bare bones is out nothing new here so
this section will be used to read a file
so let's see if i can read the file
successfully and then we'll move to the
right section so i go to run as java
application yeah it says file read
successfully and it read 27 bytes it
means that there were total of 27 bytes
in my in my file which had a single line
of text so it read all of that and it it
completed the execution now let's move
to the right section and i can comment
the read section because we have covered
that so here i'm again creating a file
output stream object because i need to
write something so again using the same
construct of the i o package i have
covered previously in the previous
sessions once you have the file output
stream object created the next thing is
to create a channel so i i again create
a file channel but this time it's the
right channel i again create a buffer
which is the right buffer allocates some
size to it then this is the string which
i want to write to this particular file
so my file my destination file will be
called dest.txt will be present in this
particular location and this file should
have this string written if this whole
operation goes successfully that's my
end goal so to do that i say right
buffer dot put and whatever string you
have created just call get bytes on it
and you get a bytes representation of
the whole string so that's what i've
done here because this put method x
expects byte because if you go inside
this it expects a byte array so that's
what i'm supplying here i'm providing
the uh the byte array by on the string
by calling message.getbyte or any string
object dot get bytes will get your byte
array once you've done that then i'm
calling the flip method remember i
talked about this flip method to
basically reset the index that's
something which you need to do in this
particular case so that the index goes
back to the initial position and the
buffer can be written successfully to a
file uh to a channel basically so once
the buffer is is comp has completed its
operation then i can write the buffer to
the channel and once that is done then
if those if these operations went
successfully then i will see a file
called dest.txt in this particular
directory currently there is no desk.txt
in this directory you can see there are
just three files but there is no
test.txt so let's run this program so it
says file written successfully which was
the last sis out at line 28 but let's
also see what is happening in the
directory so now i see a desk.txt
popping up here it's a 1kb file and if i
double click on this i see the same
string which is which say this is a test
string which is the same string which i
supplied here so you can see you can use
the nio packages to do the file read and
write and much much more than just read
and write using the nio package but this
is just to get get the point across that
this can be done using the nio or the
non blocking io package as well so that
you get maximum performance on your
machine while you deal with file i o
operations let's get started with java
beans so we have been creating java
classes and creating objects of those
java classes to work and manipulate
transfer data call methods create
properties etc and java beans just use
that as the groundwork to create a
specification first of all let's
understand that java beans is just a
standard it is just a specification
which has been provided by by java to be
followed while you are implementing
production grade or enterprise grade
applications so it's just a pure
specification set of standards if you
want to read more about this please go
to this particular link which is written
here i mean if you just google java bean
spec oracle then you will be able to
find this particular link you will see a
download option here if you go here you
will get these two specification
documents option so you can just accept
the license agreement and click on this
particular beans 0 1 1 0 1 pdf and you
can read about the whole java bean
specification i've already downloaded
this particular pdf which is opened in
this tab and if you go to the toc here
it's an official sun micro system white
paper basically and if you read about
this this this is going to explain the
whole java beans api specifications it's
going to specify the core components of
the java beans component architecture so
it's a specification let's understand
that very well if you go to the table of
contents let's go to the interesting one
which says what is exactly a bean or a
java bean so a java bean is basically a
reusable software component that can be
manipulated in any visual ide like
eclipse or intellij or netbeans etc so
technically a java bean is just a java
class but that java class should follow
three main properties the first property
is that that java class should have
getters and setters to access the
properties second property is that that
java class should have a public no
argument constructor so that anybody can
create an object of it and third is that
the java class should implement
serializable the reason in java being
specified these three conditions which i
said so let's talk about the third one
where we are talking we are saying that
it should be implementing serializable
interface why is that it's because a
java bean would be required to be
exported between applications may be
required to be written to a database or
to a file system or to be converted into
an xml or a json document sent over the
network again being deserialized so this
will be moving across a lot because
that's what we mean by reusable multiple
different software components and
applications might be reusing that bean
again and again and that beat needs to
travel across and to enable that that
being has to be serializable because if
you can't serialize it you just cannot
transport that object to another
application it's just not possible this
is how java has been so that's why you
need to implement serializable you need
to have a public no argument constructor
and you need to have getters and setters
to access your properties you can
actually read more about this if you
scroll down it will also talk about the
difference between beans and class
libraries remember not class but class
libraries and here it explains what i
just said that a java bean can have
properties it can have events and it can
have methods so properties are nothing
but the normal attributes which you
create inside a java class nothing fancy
the same attributes are named as
properties for example you may have a
foreground property and then you can
have a method which is just a normal
java method which can be called from
other applications or from an
environment and by default all of the
beans public methods will be exported by
exported i meant when you export this
when you serialize and export this
object all the beans public methods will
be exported by default but then a bean
can choose to export only a subset of
its methods if it wants to a bean can
also have events and events basically
provide a way for one object to notify
other objects that something has
happened so something similar to the uh
to the producer consumer example or the
producer consumer pattern where uh you
can notify other objects threads also
have this particular pattern where the
thread can notify other threads that it
has completed its task and other threads
can start so uh so this is so that's the
property behind event where something
has occurred and then the object can
tell other objects that's that that
something has occurred so that they can
react to that particular event so these
are the three main uh
traits which are properties events and
methods uh you can read more about this
particular white paper i will not go
into the details because it's a long
white paper but it's a very well written
white paper which will give you a very
good understanding of how java bean
specification was written what was the
thought process behind it so coming back
to the code if you want to just write it
it can be very simple to write just
write any class and say implements
serializable so it will ask you to
provide a cl version uid so you can
write this here then you can create your
attributes as normal private attributes
you can create public methods to access
and manipulate these attributes in the
forms of getters and setters so these
are the public methods to to access and
manipulate these attributes here we have
a parameterized constructor which will
not be required or which should not be
there when you're creating a java bean
it should just be like this because when
we talk about the public know arcs
constructor as we discussed in the very
first lectures that
you do not need to provide the default
constructor java will automatically
provide a default constructor for every
class so you don't need to write
something like this it's just not needed
because you can write it but it has no
value attached it has no meaning because
this is something exact this kind of
code is already generated by java
compiler when it compiles this
particular class so a public default no
argument constructor implementing
serializable private properties and
public methods and you can have
additional event methods as well which i
talked about just when we were going
through the white paper and that's all
pretty much what a java bean is so you
can see it's it's just a java class but
some additional
specifications which a java class has to
follow to be called as ajava bean let's
get started with spring framework so
spring framework is the most popular web
application framework available out
there today and all of the big companies
from netflix to whatnot use spring
framework to build the modern day java
applications so before we go any further
let's understand why do we need a
framework so let's understand this with
the help of a diagram so let me just
open a blank paint page and let me show
you what i mean by a framework and why
do we need this so we built simple
applications so far but if you have to
build a enterprise grade web application
you will have a front end probably where
you will have what you see in the
browser so you will have the html the
javascript or or any other
java enterprise edition classes like gsp
servlet etc then you will have a back
end where your java classes are present
which contains the business logic so the
business logic and then you have a
database where you have the you store
the basic basically the whole data so
you have these three different layers we
also call this a three tier architecture
so you cannot build all of this by just
using the core java classes which we
talked about you need to
do more integrations you need to use
more different programming languages and
concepts to build a complete enterprise
grid application and if you try to build
all of this by yourself then it's going
to take a lot of time and lot of effort
that's why we have frameworks which
basically create provide the structure
to create these three layers so that's
why we have this frameworks and in the
frameworks spring is the most popular
framework it provides the structure to
write all these these three layers one
of the reasons i did not talk about the
the java enterprise edition technologies
like servlets and gsps because nobody
works on them today even if you learn
about servlet it's good to know the
conceptual overview of servlets but
nobody today builds applications on jsps
and servlets that's the reason i did not
talk about it because today we have
sophisticated front-end frameworks like
angularjs or react.js or amber.js and
whatnot and it is iterating at a very
faster speed so there is literally
practically no need for a java developer
today to learn about gsp because i can
bet you on that you can take it in
written for me nobody is going to build
the jsp app based applications in 2021
everybody is going to use some sort of
front-end framework to build that and
then you have a back-end in the back end
you have the exact core java classes
like i just explained so you will be
using the java beans and you will be
basically using the pure java concepts
of collections and and etc to write the
backend logic using the java classes and
then you will need a jdbc connection to
write to a database as well so you would
need a database as well and spring
provides connectors and
specifications to support all of these
three layers that's the reason so
generally when you talk about a web
application let's talk about web
application because java primarily is
used in web applications so in a web
application you basically see a browser
window where you load a particular page
but what happens behind the scene this
browser has some html and some js maybe
and this code is basically calling some
end point this end point is present in
the back end layer so this endpoint is
present in the backend layer that end
point transfers the control to the
business layer where you have your core
business logic written and then the
business layer
transfers the control to the
data layer or some people also call it
dow layer this dow layer then talks to
the database that's how a web
application works and that's what that's
the architecture you will mostly be
following whenever you are building any
enterprise grid application in any
organization so spring provides support
for all of these parts this obviously is
written by angular and react and other
frameworks but this is this whole
section is basically presented or
supported by spring so with that let's
understand a bit more about spring
framework so if you go to the spring
official website it talks about some of
the value propositions spring is used
heavily like i said it's used everywhere
it's very flexible framework there are a
couple of concepts which string provides
which is around inversion of control and
dependency injection and i will talk
about these concepts in a while uh when
we'll talk more about the springs
components it makes uh it's quite
productive and quite fast as well so
it's very fast to build application on
on spring it has a whole dedicated
security module as well so it's quite
secure by design and the spring
community is huge so you can find lot of
support on internet let's learn bit more
about the springs core components or
core technologies so if you talk about
the spring score components these are
the springs core components so you have
a testing module you have you have a
core module first of all inside the
techno in the core components you have a
core module which has ioc containers
resources events i'll talk a bit about
that it has a it has its own testing
component so it provides very good
support for testing applications it has
a data access component the data access
component is used to provide connections
utilities to the database because like i
mentioned your application will be
talking to the database and spring
provides a
complete dedicated component to be used
whenever you are dealing whenever you're
talking to the database it also provides
a web servlet component uh to uh provide
support for spring mvc which i will be
covering in the next session web sockets
and stomp and messaging frameworks etc
it also supports reactive or
asynchronous programming if you want to
do that it provides a lot of integration
capabilities in the integration modules
if you want to do jms or jmx or email or
task scheduling etc and it also provides
language support to support
international internationalization of
the applications so
it has a lot of different components but
we will focus on this core component
which is of the interest here so let's
talk about that the first thing which
you need to know about spring is its
support for inversion of control and it
provides that support by creating an
inversion of control container what do
we mean by inversion of control the
basic idea is let me take any random
example and i will be able to
communicate the idea behind this so
let's go to any simple example which i
have already covered let's go to method
calling for example so we had a student
class we created a student class simple
student class three properties
constructor and public getters and
setters and then i created a main class
and i initialized the student object so
to the responsibility of creating the
student object lies with the student
class itself student class have to be
explicitly initialized to be having an
object of the student so this creates a
problem because when you're dealing with
uh enterprise grade frameworks you might
need to create a lot of objects on the
fly whenever the
end point is talking to the business
layer
if i take the reference of this
architecture if the endpoint is talking
to the business layer classes business
layer classes are talking to the data
access layer classes so when the
business layer classes needs to talk to
the data access layer classes the data
access layer classes needs to have an
object because that communication
happens between objects only so who
creates those objects if every time the
data access object has been has been
called and if we provide if we pass that
responsibility to the dao class to
create the object or every time the end
point talks to the business class we ask
the business layer to create the objects
it becomes a lot of painful process
because every time you will be doing
this new student everywhere you need a
student object which is very painful
process so what spring says it says okay
involved the control of creating the
object so let's not give the
responsibility of creating the object to
the class let's give that responsibility
to the framework so the framework will
be responsible for creating the objects
of a class and it's not the class who
will be responsible for creating its own
objects so generally outside the
framework a class is responsible for
getting its object but with spring
spring inverts this responsibility
that's why we call it inversion of
control the control is inverted it's
reversed and now it's the frameworks
responsibility to create the objects you
will also hear about a concept called
dependency injection a lot in context of
ioc and dependency injection is an
implementation of the ioc concept so
using springs dependency injection
mechanism you can inject the object of
any class into any class once you do
that spring dependency is going to use
the inversion of control concept and
create the object that's about ioc and
di or dependency injection then the
other modules like resources will
provide a way to refer different files
and properties if you want to then you
have a validation module as well which
will provide different validation
constructs because once you receive the
data you might need to run a lot of
validation right and writing the
validation by yourself can be very
painful so it provides a validation
framework as well by providing the
validator interface you can use this
particular framework to write the
validation rules checking the name not
empty etc similarly it also supports an
expression language if you want to use
that so the expression language support
is wide very wide in fact you can create
an expression parser and you can do the
expression language evaluation using the
a spring expression language similarly
it also provides support for
aspect-oriented programming now again
all these concepts of validation and
spring expression language and resource
support the you probably would need
hours of reading to learn about these
concepts and i'm just running through
them just to tell you about these
concepts and do read about why do you
need resources why do you want to do
validation why do you need an expression
language what is aspect oriented
programming read about all of those
concepts because they are not related to
java they are generic concepts which
will be applicable to any programming
language so any enterprise application
you build in any programming language
you would need to do the validation you
would need to do the resource reference
management you would need to have an
expression language you would need to
have aspect oriented programming support
so this is just to tell you that that
java does provide an aop or aspect
oriented programming support as well and
it has a lot of
apis available for that along with that
it also provides very good logging
capabilities because you definitely need
to log all the actions which the
framework or your objects are taking so
this was a very quick lightning overview
about spring i understand it's not
possible to cover all the concept of a
framework as sophisticated and as smart
as spring in in 10 to 15 minutes lecture
so treat this as an introduction session
and like i said read more about all of
these components i just explained the
core because this is this is sort of the
main building block of spring framework
and then you have other supporting uh
components as well so do check out the
documentation there are tons of examples
available in fact in the springs
official website itself if you go to the
spring guide section if you go to the uh
learn and you go to the guide section
there are awesome getting started and
topical guides and tutorials available
so for example how to build a restful
web service how to schedule tasks how to
consume a restful web service how to
build a simple java project with maven
how to upload files with string how to
do messaging with radius which is a
basically a caching framework how to do
messaging using spring to rabbit mq
rabbit mq is a messaging framework so
there are tons of examples available
here very good documentation and very
robust documentation do check out the
examples to learn more about this let's
get started with mvc and the
implementation of mvc using spring so
before we go any further let's first
understand what do we mean by an mvc
application so in the previous lectures
i discussed about the three tier
application where you had a presentation
layer you had a business layer and then
you had a database layer which is
talking to the database and that's how
we built a three-tier application which
can also evolve into an n-tier
application but when when the web
development started the most popular
concept which came out was
m v c m stands for model v stands for
view and c stands for controller so the
idea was that these three components
together can render a web application
and how they render the web application
is basically that the controller is
going to receive the request which is
coming from the web browser then the
controller will have the knowledge of
where the business logic for that
particular request will be residing so
the controller is going to invoke the
model the corresponding model which is
required to execute the business logic
of the request and the controller will
also have the knowledge of what response
page to be sent back to the user so we
are talking about the response page here
not response remember that because it's
a web application so the model view
controller architecture basically was
designed
to keep in mind that you have a web
application where a request is coming
from and you need to process some
business logic and then you need to
return back with a page response which
is going to be displayed on the web
browser of the client machine so that's
why we had these three components as
model view and controller controller
taking up the request then
finding the right model for it which can
execute the business logic and then also
finding the right view for it which can
render
the business logic processed by the
model so that's a quick overview about
model view controller or mvc
architecture do read about it in detail
to understand how this works but like i
mentioned that mvc the most popular mvc
implementation is provided by spring
spring is the most popular mvc framework
and the way spring
implements it is something which i have
drawn already here so let's understand
how this works so first the request
comes from the web browser and spring
has uh the a very first welcome servlet
which is called dispatcher servlet any
request which is coming to the spring
enabled web application will first hit
dispatcher servlet and once the request
comes to the dispatcher servlet the
dispatcher servlet has all the knowledge
of all the controllers of all the view
resolvers which i will talk about in a
while and of all the views as well it
also has knowledge about handler
mappings which again i will just discuss
now so the basic premise is that
dispatcher servlet is the component
which has knowledge about literally
everything happening in your application
and that's why dispatcher servlet is the
first servlet or the first component
which receives your web request so once
the request comes here first of all it
looks at the path and finds out the
right handler for it the right
controller for it and the way it does
that by using the handler mapping
component or handler mapping logic which
is provided out of the box by spring
framework so the handler mapping logic
will tell the dispatcher servlet which
particular controller is going to
process the request which is coming
because every request will have a
different controller return so whatever
the type of request is whatever the path
of the request is based on that the
dispatcher servlet is going to find a
particular controller once the
controller is found like i mentioned
earlier the controller will have
knowledge about the right model to
invoke for that particular request model
is nothing
but basically a java class holding the
business logic for this particular
request so it will invoke that java
class and get all the business logic
processed and then it is going to return
a model and view object view is here
simply pointing to the ui response which
you are going to send back to the user
it can be a jsp page it can be an html
page it can be any other view technology
so anything which is
which is used to render a web
application on a web page is view and
controller is going to send both the
model and view information back to the
dispatcher servlet the dispatcher
servlet will take the view part of it
and go to another component which is
again provided by spring which is called
view resolver the view resolver will
have the knowledge to see which
particular actual jsp or template to
invoke for
the view value coming from the
controller so based on the value which
is returned by the controller a view
resolver is going to return the right
page mapping and once the dispatcher
servlet knows the page mapping it is
just going to invoke that page by
calling the view component so dispatcher
servlet handler mapping controller view
resolver and view these five components
together help render a web mvc
application in the spring framework so
that was about the theory of how spring
works now let's move on to a example to
understand how this works in action so
here i have already built a spring mvc
application and if you're wondering how
to build that there's an easy way to do
that using spring initializer and that's
also the recommended way actually if you
go to the documentation of spring you
will see that it recommends creating a
new project from
scratch using the spring initializer
utility which is provided by spring out
of the box so just go to web a web
browser and
type start dot spring dot io you will
get this page where you can specify what
type of project you want to create so it
is going to create the basic skeleton
for any spring application automatically
for you it's probably like i said it's
probably the fastest way to get started
with spring so we will choose a maven
project maven is again a dependency
management tool which is used to
download any kind of jars for your
application so we are going to use a
maven project and we want to create a
skeleton for a java application we are
going to use the latest released version
of spring or spring boot which is 2.4.2
it says spring boot here but don't get
confused with it we are going to use
just the mvc classes and not the spring
boot specific logic yet then you provide
your group artifact id and the name for
your jar you provide a description you
can provide a welcome package name
whatever suits you and then how you
would like to run your application
whether you would like to package your
application as a jar file which is a
java archive or you would like to run it
as a web archive which is a var file so
you can choose either packaging mode and
it is going to add appropriate
dependencies inside the project to
support the packaging of jar or the
packaging of var then you can also
choose the java version so you can see
there are three java versions listed
here which are 8 11 and 15 so whichever
java version you are working on you can
choose that particular version and once
you have set all with everything just
hit generate once you do that it is
going to create a project here and then
you can import this project just as a
normal project inside the eclipse ide
and that's exactly what i've done for
this initial project which is showing a
very basic hello world sort of example
for how spring mvc will work so this
whole structure will automatically be
created for you and like i said it was a
maven project and in every maven project
you will have a palm.xml if i double
click on this it is going to open this
xml and it will list down all the
dependencies which my project needs to
have let's understand the dependencies
as well so this project is currently
using the properties of 1.8 but that's
and that's fine you can obviously
definitely change this value i just kept
it as 1.8 for now because i'm not using
any new functionality yet in the
dependencies section you will see all
the dependencies or all the jars which
are required by the spring application
to run successfully the first dependency
we see here is about daimy leaf and
daimy leaf basically is a view
technology similar to jsp or similar to
servlets
technically where you can supply use
this daimy leaf templates which are
basically just htmls with some dynamic
values and you can use this dime lift
templates to render web pages for your
spring mvc application if you want to
use some other view technology you need
to include the dependency of that view
technology here instead of dye my life
so that's about that then you need to
include the spring boot starter web the
spring boot starter web is going to
enable your application to become a web
application then this is this is a this
is basically a good to have dependency
which you can have in your project which
will help you deploy the project at
runtime automatically without restarting
the server because the web application
will be running on a server on a web
server basically or an application
server technically because it needs to
run somewhere so that it so that clients
can access it that's how a web client
architecture works or the server client
architecture works so this dependency
will allow you to deploy changes
dynamically at runtime without
restarting the server then this
dependency is for tests if you're
writing any unit tests and then you have
a plugin which will allow to run this
particular project with a single command
which we will see in a while so that's
about the dependency tour now let's look
at what is in the src main java in the
src main java i just have two classes
one is the main class which will have a
public static void main method and this
is the entry point of the spring
application and then i have a controller
class i already talked about what
controller is but i will come back to
that in a while let's understand the
rest of the files as well the next one
is src main resources where you will
have your view technology data available
like i mentioned it is using diamy leaf
templates currently and basically like i
said they are technically htmls with
some dynamic data so i've created a
templates folder under src main
resources which will automatically be
generated by spring initializer and then
under templates i have placed an html
file it's a pure html file with the only
difference is this value so this is what
the dynamic value means which which is
supported by dimer leaf templates
otherwise this is pure html it's just a
paragraph with a header and this is the
dynamic value which i am populating it
also has application.properties which
has nothing but you can use this
particular file to supply environment
specific properties for the development
environment or the testing environment
or the real production environment if
you have any unit tests those will go
here under src test java and this is the
system library already provided
supported by eclipse itself and i
already talked about the palm.xml you
also see couple of more files created by
springboard if you want to use that you
can use that to run the run the program
from the command line as a utility
otherwise you can just use ambient
spring boot command which i will show
you in a while there's also a gradle
folder which you can ignore probably we
don't need this because we are just
using maven and we are not using gradle
gradle is another dependency management
tool very very similar to maven so you
can ignore this folder right now so
that's the structure and now let's come
back to the controllers remember i told
you that controllers are the ones which
receive the request so from the
dispatcher servlet which i talked about
here after the dispatcher servlet the
request comes to the controller so once
you hit a particular url then you need
to create a controller for that url
mapping remember that you need to create
a controller for almost every url
mapping you are having in your
application there should be some mapping
to some controller somewhere so i've
created a greeting controller and the
way you specify or you make a simple
class as a controller is by putting the
add the red controller annotation this
is the annotation which is supported by
spring and you can put this annotation
on top of any class and that class will
be treated as controller by spring and
the moment the moment you put this this
class will also be registered with the
dispatcher servlet and like i mentioned
the controller's main purpose is to
receive the requests the web requests
which are coming from the client and the
way you can receive the requests to a
controller by providing the exact url
mapping so if somebody runs this web
application and says
slash greeting then this particular
method should get invoked and how you
define that is with the get mapping
annotation use the get mapping
annotation to provide the url path
whenever somebody invokes this url path
this method would be getting called and
when this method is getting called at
that same time
this url can also accept some query
parameters we call that as the request
parameters in in the spring language so
you can use the request parameters as an
annotation to provide a placeholder for
the variable for which the value will be
supplied in the url so slash greeting if
if you call this url something like this
then it will work because you have a
variable called name which is which is
being parsed as a query string because
we have used the request paramentation
so we'll see an example of that when
once we run this application and how we
can supply the query string but you use
the request param annotation to supply
the query string parameters to the url
you can mention if the parameter is
mandatory or non-mandatory if the
required equal to true was there then
this parameter would be mandatory you
can also supply a default value if
somebody is if the client is not
providing this query parameter at all
would you like to set any default value
if yes you can supply the default value
here and then you just give a
placeholder name like i said then the
second argument which your your methods
which are intercepting the request
should have is the model argument and
remember i told you that the controller
will have or should have the knowledge
about the model and from here that
knowledge comes you this particular
method will expect you to provide a
model argument as well so if somebody
calls this application and provides the
urls with slash greeting this particular
method will get invoked and then the
code inside this method will be getting
executed so it's a very simple code
right now but this is where your whole
logic will go remember that but here i'm
just saying model dot add attribute name
with the value which is coming from the
query string parameter that's all i'm
doing here and
remember i told you that the model will
hold the business logic so here this is
the business logic where whatever query
string parameter which is coming from
the request param i'm capturing that and
i'm adding that value with the variable
name in the attributes of the model so
my model is set and after that i need to
return the view so that this particular
file name will be intercepted by the
view resolver here if you remember we
talked about the view resolver so when
we return
greetings as a string that string goes
here and then dispatcher servlet looks
out asks the view resolver to find a
particular html matching with this
particular text so view resolver is
going to look at under src main
resources
templates to see if there is a file with
the name greeting available or not since
we have that file available the spring
is going to render this particular file
supplying the model attribute value name
now remember the greeting.html had the
exact same variable name so this
variable name should exactly match with
this variable name here if you do if you
make a mistake here this is not going to
work because the model is holding the
business logic and i'm printing that
business logic inside the view using the
dye my lift template syntax which is
dollar curly braces so whenever you have
to print any variable or a model
attribute or any runtime value inside a
dhammalife template then you need to use
the dollar curly braces syntax to do
that so that was about a quick overview
of how this application is is written
right now and that's all the code is
here now it's time to run this
application
so one of the simplest way to run this
application would be to provide a spring
at the run configuration here for the
spring application or you can choose
another way which is to first have a
look at the spring web content
application which is the entry point so
once your application boots up this is
the first line of code which is going to
get executed and to make sure that this
code works make sure that you have the
add the red spring boot application
annotation on top of the entry point
class so this is this is sort of the
mandate which spring will force you to
put in front of the or on top of the
entry point class to to treat this class
as the first entry point when you run
the project so to run the project what
we will do that we will just go to the
command line and we will say mvn spring
boot run so let's do that and let me
open the terminal for that so i have
opened a git bash prompt here you can
also open the classic windows terminal
but this is something which git installs
by default if you install git on your
system it's pretty much exactly the same
it's just more unix-like but it's also
just a simple terminal shell utility to
access your file system so i have gone
to the project which we were working
with in the eclipse ide and this is the
path of the project so once you reach to
the path what you would like to run is
just say mvn
spring hyphen boot colon run that's it
and you hit enter once you write mvn
sprinkle hyphen boot call and run you
will see lot of code lot of logs here
where it is going to run all the compile
all the java classes run any tests if
there are any and then it is going to
start the web content application you
can see and once the application is
started you will get this message that
everything is run one of the interesting
thing which you can see here is that it
is also spinning up an application
server automatically for you and that
application server here which is being
used by spring is apache tomcat
technically apache tomcat is a servlet
container and it's not a full-fledged
application server but just to get the
point across you can use apache tomcat
as an application server which is being
used here
out of the box by spring if you don't
want to use apache tomcat and you want
to use something else you can do that as
well so now everything is ready and we
can now execute the application to
observe the output so for that let me
open a fresh browser window so that we
don't get any cash response and now i
can just type localhost 8080 and if i
hit entry enter i i get a white level
error page because there is no home page
for tomcat defined but there is a home
page for my application defined in fact
let's try to access the url which we
wrote in the greeting controller the url
was slash greeting so let's copy this
and let's put this here so localhost
greeting and if i hit enter i get the
message hello world let me just zoom
this in a bit so that you can see so you
will see this hello world message here
by putting this url why do we see hello
world let's go back to the controller so
when you call this url this greeting
controller got invoked since we did not
provide any query string parameter the
default value which was world was picked
up and this world value was stored in
the name variable and the name variable
was added as an attribute to the model
and then we were using the greeting.html
and we were printing the name variable
since the name variable was holding the
value world so the message came as hello
world
with an exclamation and that's the
output which we see here now let's try
to supply the query query string
parameter the way you do that is provide
a question mark provide the key of the
query string parameter and the value you
want to put here so let's put simply
code as a value and hit enter so now the
message got changed and now it says
hello simply code so what happened here
is that whatever con query string
parameter is supplied that got passed
here at par as part of the request param
and the value of simply code got stored
in this name key and in turn in this
name variable and then i added the same
value into another name attribute and
added that attribute to the model so now
this name here is storing the value
simply code and then the all the things
work exactly is the same as i just
described it goes to greeting.html and
it prints whatever is stored in the name
attribute coming from the model let's
get started with spring boot and how we
can build a simple application using
spring boot before we go further let's
understand why we need spring boot and
the basic idea of spring boot is to
build restful web services if you want
to know more about what are restful
services please you can read about the
restful concept as a concept what does
rest stand for but the basic idea is
that if you are accessing anything over
http then that particular component can
be built as a restful component and
spring boot is the most popular choice
for building restful web services today
and even in fact micro services which
you might have heard about so you can
build micro services which also run on
https using spring boot so what i'm
showing you right now is the official
guide of spring which you can use to
build an application with spring boot it
will list down all the requisites which
you need in terms of the uh jdk
installations maven on and how to
complete this guide etc etc you can
again use the same springs initializer
which i talked about in the previous
session you can use this to generate a
spring boot project for you specifically
so all those options are available here
so i've already done that and i'm not
going to repeat what i just did in the
previous session and will directly jump
to an ide where i have created a sample
spring boot application and the
structure here you can see the structure
would look very similar with one change
that in the previous example when we
were dealing with mbc we had an src main
resources folder and that src main
resources folder was having all the web
components or the htmls but since in
restful web services you do not render
the html but you just send back the
response the response can be the
response body can be pure xml or it can
be pure json but you do not send back
and view and that's the main difference
between spring mvc and spring boot that
in spring mvc it will you are required
to return a view technology like in the
in the previous session we sent a dye my
life template which is basically in html
you can also written a gsp but with
spring boot you do not deal with the
view technology and that's the world we
are living in today when you write
spring boot you do not have to worry
about how this is going to be rendered
on the web page whether it is going to
be rendered using html or whatnot what
you need to take care of using spring
boot is to return the right response
body the exact text of the response and
that's it so with that in mind the
spring boot was born and the structure
apart from that the structure would look
very similar this palm.xml here which
will provide all the list of jars and
dependencies which are required for this
particular project so you can see all
the dependencies here pretty much the
similar ones we have a starter web we
have a starters test and we have a
springboot maven plugin and we have an
application file which is the entry
point again having a public static void
main method so you need to put the at
the red spring boot application at the
top of the class to make it an entry
point if you don't do this spring boot
will not run this class and spring boot
will
even not run your application so what we
are doing as part of this example that
we are just printing all the beans which
are provided by spring that's all we are
doing like i said it's a very
lightweight and the introductory session
so we will keep the logics to minimum
and i'm just getting all the bean
definitions sorting the bean definitions
and just printing them one by one how do
you get the bean definition you get that
with this application context class
which is returned when you run the
application and how you run the
application is basically using this line
where you say string application dot run
and you supply application dot class
with any command line arguments which
you might want to use once you do this
it is going to return an application
context object to you and the
application context object can be used
to get all the bean definitions by
calling this method which says get bean
definition names so that's the basic
logic which is being run in the main
class now we also have a controller but
this time it's not a web controller but
it's a rest controller so you see in the
previous example we just had written
something like this it was just a pure
controller but here we have become more
specific we are saying that hey this is
not a simple mvc controller but this is
a spring boot controller or technically
a rest controller so spring provides a
separate annotation for that which is at
the rate rest controller so you write
that particular annotation or that on
the top of the controller class which
you're creating and then you provide a
request mapping similar to what we did
in spring mvc but while you return it
you do not return a view technology you
just return the raw response here i'm
just returning a string but you can
return a json object you can return an
xml object or whatever you want to but
not a view technology that's what i'm
doing like like you can see there's
literally nothing i'm doing in this it's
just a simple
string return statement which i have
printed here and that's all the code i
have right now here i just have these
two classes okay so that was all about
what i have written in the project and
now it's time to run the project so i
have just reached to the location on
inside my terminal where the project
bomb.xml was present and if i just do an
ls you will see that there is a pom.xml
available here and all the code
directory is also available here so now
i will just run this application and to
run this application i'm just going to
type mvn spring hyphen boot colon run
and hit enter once i do that the spring
application is going to spring boot
application is going to get started and
let's go back to uh the controller and
actually the main app main endpoint and
see what we were doing there i did a cis
out here which said let's inspect the
beans provided by spring boot and then i
was printing all the bean names and if i
go back to the output i will see the
same line being written here which was
around let's inspect the beans so you
can see that message which says let's
inspect the beans provided by spring
boot and then all the beans which are
available in the application context are
printed here so that's that's the basic
idea which i want to give you that you
can actually build a spring boot
application and you can write your rest
controllers return a string body from it
and once this is run then you can also
run your application for from the web
browser as well so let's try to hit that
particular url which i wrote here so the
url of hello so for that let me just
open a new cognito window and our
application is already running so if i
just say http localhost 8080 slash i get
this message here which says greetings
from spring boot and this is the message
which we were sending from the rest
controller so this validates our
understanding that we can invoke a crest
controller which is a spring boot rest
controller via the same method but this
time we are not getting an html but we
are just returning this particular
string now you can use the string in any
ways you want so it depends upon the
consumer so that's all i want to cover
as part of the spring boot now spring
boot is a huge huge topic and we can
spend hours and hours talking about
spring boot but since this is more of an
introductory session so i just wanted
the concept to get introduced and
remember the value proposition of why
you would need spring boot the basic
idea is to build restful web services or
build restful micro services that's the
basic idea behind using spring boot in
your applications and also remember the
difference between web mvc spring mvc
application and spring boot application
spring mvc is for building web
application spring boot is for building
restful applications which might not
have a web interface integrated with
them at that moment so that's all i want
to cover for this particular session and
in the next session we are going to have
a look at an advanced java project using
some of the concepts which we might have
learned during this whole journey and
that would be the last session of this
particular tutorial series let's get
started with our demo of a project which
is using spring boot to build a restful
web service so a restful web service is
nothing but any end point which you can
access or you can consume the data from
via an http layer or via a simply a web
layer because most of the web traffic
which we deal with is built on http so
to take an example if you go to any
website where you sometimes see on the
top right corner you see today's weather
so how is that today's weather coming in
it's coming in via a rest web service
the website which you are accessing is
basically hitting an http endpoint uh
which is uh where the where the weather
application is sitting and it asks for
the weather data and the dressed web
application just returns the data and
that's how the website is able to show
you the current weather so restful web
services are everywhere and they are the
most popular way to build applications
today where you just build your restful
web service and you expose an http url
and then the consumers need to just
access that http url to consume the data
from your application and you see this
makes it very easy because there is no
data type restrictions there is no tight
coupling here it's just an http endpoint
so that's the basic idea and we will
look at a project where we will be using
spring boot to build a restful web
service and then we will try to run that
web service to save some data and also
to return some data so here on the on
the package explorer you see i have
created a project called rest service
and let's just walk through the
structure of it and then we'll go into
the details of it so we have an src main
java where i have a package and i have
bunch of classes here and before we go
to the classes let's first also access
the dependency file because every
project needs some dependencies some
jars to execute it for example spring
itself is basically a jar so you need to
include the spring jar in your project
so that your project can become a spring
project and there are generally two
dependency tools one is maven and one is
gradle in this particular project i am
using maven
dependency tool for downloading and
managing the dependencies which are
needed to run this project successfully
and the way you will find if it's a
maven project or if it's a gradle
project for a maven project you will see
a file called
pom.xml pom.xml and if it's a gradle
project you will see a dot gradle file
that's how you can spot whether the
project is using maven for dependency
management or it is using gradle for
dependency management so let's open the
palm.xml since it's an xml file it will
be a bit verbose but
if you just read it piece by piece it
will become easier to understand first
of all since this is a spring project i
need to include the parent dependency
which brings lot of good defaults
sensible defaults from spring boot
automatically and this is the jar name
this is the artifact id which is spring
boot starter parent so any spring boot
project you are starting do include this
parent this parent is basically bringing
all the dependencies from some other jar
and you can make your project as a as a
child of this particular parent so all
these spring
board projects have this as a parent as
a standard practice after that you
provide your own details in terms of
what is the package name uh how do you
want to see the jar name on what is the
actual name what is the jar version etc
etc you also set the minimum required
java version to run this application and
then you in the dependency sections you
provide all the jars which you need to
run your project successfully both
compile and run your project
successfully so we added the spring boot
starter web on dependency which
basically brings all the dependencies
around making a controller or making a
repository count context component scan
all the interesting features which
spring provides get wrapped up inside
the spring boot starter jar and you can
actually go to the mvn repository and
and have a look at what all classes it
provides it's a lot of classes so i'm
just telling you in a brief that it
provides all the restful functionality
then you have the next dependency as
spring boot starter data jpa which is
going to enable this project to also
have a database and if it has a database
then you need java to talk to the
database and the way spring suggests to
talk to the database is via using the
spring boot data jpa library we will see
this how this library can be used but
basically this provides ways to
represent your java object in the
database and then you need to also add
the actual dependency of the database
and in this case we are using an in
memory h2 database so i'm not using an
external database like mysql or oracle
or post resql because that will just
make more configurations more
complicated i just wanted to keep it
simple and generally you in this h2
database you can easily access by adding
this dependency and it will be an
in-memory database created for you then
i've also added a spring boot starter
test here which will be used whenever
you are writing unit tests and you must
write unit test for your project and
then we need to add the plugin so that
springboot can run this project that's
all i have in the bomb.xml now let's
move to the interesting part the java
section part let's start from the main
class
so this is how the main class looks like
where you have you just create uh any
any name with the class and then you add
a public static void main method inside
the public static void main method you
call spring application dot run and this
run method is basically going to run
your application and you just provide
the same class name which you just wrote
here so just say dot class and if you're
supplying any command line arguments it
can interpret that command line
arguments as well if you want so you'd
always need an entry point in an
application and this is the entry point
which spring boot supports and this is
if you see this code this is just normal
code to make spring be aware about this
class being treated as an entry point
you need to add add the red spring boot
application annotation on top of the
class this is one of the annotation
which is coming directly from the spring
boot library you can see this import so
once you add this then only spring will
be able to treat this class as an entry
point otherwise spring doesn't know
where to start from so when you run
spring it will fi it will try to find a
class with an annotation spring boot
application and then inside the class it
will try to find a public start a static
void main method and once it has found
both of them then it will just run the
application so very simple nothing fancy
here and what we are dealing with here
is a student object so we will try to
insert the student object and we will
try to retrieve the student object so
if you ignore these annotations which
i've added it's just a pure pojo it's
just a plain old java object you create
a student class let's ignore this field
as well for now i'll just come back to
this annotation in this field but this
is just a student class it has three
fields as name age and address an empty
constructor and a parameterized
constructor and some getters
intentionally i have removed the setters
because generally whenever you are
building any enterprise grade
application you would like to keep your
objects immutable means once they have
been created you would not like somebody
to allow to change the values of the
object this just makes programming much
much more easy if you treat all the
objects in your application as immutable
that's why i have not added setters here
it's just considered a good practice so
apart from the standard things which we
have already seen there are two things
here which i want to talk about let's
first talk about this one so accurate
entity is the annotation which is coming
from java x persistent entity
persistence entity and this makes
spring boot save this particular object
into the database this is the annotation
which you need to put on your class so
that springboot knows that this class
represents a table in the database so
you need to add this to make sure that
this represents a table second thing a
table will have a id it will have sort
of a primary key so i've created a new
column called id which is basically
representing the student's role number
or something or maybe a registration
number and here i'm using couple of more
annotations if you see these annotations
are also coming from java x persistence
library and these annotations will
basically allow the a new id to be
created every time you create a student
object so you don't have to specify the
value of this id variable springboot
will automatically generate a new id
value every time you create a new
student object and how does it generate
you you can provide the generation type
as well so currently i've just said that
set it as automatic but you can set it
as identity sequence or rate or control
by table you can also see the
explanation of each of these here but
i've just kept it as auto which
basically uh let the persistence
provider pick any appropriate strategy
for the particular database in our case
the database is h2 so that's about the
entity class let's call this as entity
class now let's move to the repository
so you need a repository class
like i explained in dots in that three
tier architecture you always need a dow
layer or a repository layer to store
your student object into the database so
we have enabled the student object to be
saved but we need a handler which can
save this particular file this
particular object into the database and
the repository classes are the classes
which will allow you to do that so you
create a very simple interface you what
you name whatever you want to name your
interface as and then you say extends
jpa repository the type of the object
and the unique identifier of the object
so the type of the object is student
here and the unique identifier of the
student object is the id which is of
type long so you need to just supply the
types type of the object type of the
primary key or the type of the unique
identifier and this annotation is coming
from spring boot you can see
specifically spring boot data library
which we added so you just need to
create an interface extend it from jp
repository and make sure that you add
this annotation as well spring heavily
uses the concept of annotations and this
will help spring understand that this is
a repository layer class and it will
apply some more metadata to this class
while this class is running in the jvm
so what happens here you just created an
interface you did not provide any method
to create or any method to delete or any
method to get a student object because
all of that is automatically provided by
springboot via the jpa repository class
if we go inside this class and if you
scroll down you'll see the find all
method find all find all by id save all
flush save and flush delete etc and if
you go further up this also extends the
paging and sorting repository which
provides pagination and sorting
facilities but the interesting one is
that pages and sorting repository again
extends a crud repository and if you go
to the crud repository you will find all
the basic methods to save an entity save
multiple entities find an entity by the
id that's why it needed that long type
to make sure this that it can execute
this method you can check the existence
of an object find all the entries find
all by id count them delete them so all
the basic crud functionality so we call
them as crud because the reason it is
called crud because create read update
delete that's the basically the
generic acronym so because uh this cred
repository provides all the methods and
their implementations automatically we
do not need to write any code at all so
that's why spring boot is so awesome and
that's why spring boot is very popular
because it's zero code in the repository
and you still get all the crud
functionality so that's about repository
now we have covered the entity class we
have covered the repository class we
have covered the entry point class now
the only thing which is remaining is the
is the
end point the http endpoint which i
talked about and that you can create by
creating any class generally try to
suffix it with the controller so that
your core developers can easily find
this class and make sure that you put
add the red rest controller annotation
on top of it this annotation will allow
spring to treat this particular class as
an endpoint class then you can auto wire
the student repository so if you
remember i talked about the whole
dependency injection and inversion of
control so here dependency injection is
in action so here you are just telling
student controller to auto wire the
student repository and now what will
happen that at run time student
controller or actually spring will
automatically create an object of the
student repository and supply that
object of student repository to student
controller so you as developer do not
have to create an object of student
repository explicitly that's the benefit
and that's how the dependency injection
is working because you inverted the
dependencies now the dependency is just
injected into the class and as a
developer you don't have to take control
of creating the objects it's the spring
which will automatically read the auto
word annotation and will automatically
supply an object whenever it is required
then i have two methods here since we
are talking about http endpoints so i
have represented a post method here and
a get method here the way you will write
a post method is via the ratepost
mapping annotation and then you can
provide the url path on which somebody
should call your endpoint to save
something so for example somebody can
call it http localhost 8080
student slash create whenever they hit
that url the control or that request
will directly hit this particular method
why because you have provided the url
mapping here in the post mapping
annotation so since it's a post method
there would be request body what is the
actual request body which the client is
sending and you can represent its uh
request body with the add direct request
body annotation and you can provide the
type of the request body and here i'm
saying that hey if you want to access
this particular url yes all good but you
need to supply me with a
text representation of the student
object or a json representation of the
student object and then i inside the
method i'm calling student repository
dot save which is going to save the
student object which is coming in so you
see there's a lot going on here i will i
will show you how the student is
represented in the request body as well
and then i will come back to how it got
converted from json to java but this is
how you can store this particular
student object you can hit this api as
many times as you want and keep
inserting a new student object every
time then if you want to fetch a
particular student then you can do that
by supplying the slash student and then
in the curly braces there's an id
written here so basically you can supply
the value of the id of the student so
generally there would be another method
here which would be find all to see all
the students
and with their id and then you can pick
a particular student's id supply that
student id value here dynamically that's
why at the curly braces curly braces
supports dynamic value so here it can
insert 1 2 3 or whatever the student id
you want to fetch the value for you
provide that value in the student slash
id and all good then some if somebody is
hitting the url with saying localhost
student slash 1 then student with the id
1 will be returned from the request
and you need to put admitted get mapping
to make sure that this method is treated
as an http get method and you can
provide the type you can set say get
student and here this dynamic value is
captured with the add the rate path
variable because you need to know the id
right whatever id somebody has supplied
it in the url you need to capture that
ide and then use that ide for calling
the repository so that's you can do that
by using the add variate path variable
so here i'm just saying whatever id is
coming in i will store that value inside
this ide once i've done that then i can
again call student repository dot find
by id which is again a built-in method
provided to me by the crud repository i
can supply the id and this actually is
going to return an optional object which
is uh which is an object which may or
may not contain a value so it said just
a types of defensive programming style
so this will return an optional and you
can call a get method to return the
actual student object this will return
an optional of student so option of
student means that this optional object
may have a student or may not have a
student why did string do that because
the id somebody is supplying that id can
be invalid also right so optional object
takes care of that that if there is no
student found then you will not get a
null pointer exception and if there's a
student found you can return that so
it's just a defensive programming style
which spring has adopted by returning an
optional of the student object rather
than directly the student object but if
you're confident that this particular
option of student object does contain a
student object then just call
optional.get which i've called here
which will return the actual student
object sitting inside the optional
object you can read more about the
optional object and its usage uh from
the official java docs and there are
tons of examples available on it on
internet so this is about the controller
uh we have covered all the classes now
it's time to run the application so you
go to the command prompt you go to the
particular uh file folder location and
there
you just say mvn spring hyphen boot
colon run so i just hit enter and this
is going to
run the application it's going to split
some logs here and if everything is fine
you will not get an error and you will
just be getting a message saying that
application got started and it's running
on tomcat localhost 8080 with no context
url so this is not a web application
this is a rest full web service right
this is a restful service this is not a
web application so there is no web
interface so how do you access this you
just have an http url so you can use any
of the rest client available on the
internet there are probably hundreds of
different rest clients available on the
internet you can choose any one of them
i am using advanced rest client which
you can also install as an extension
from the chrome browser itself so if you
just if i just open the chrome browser
and i just say rest client if you just
write this and hit enter you will get
many different options and the first
option you get is from google play
stores app store so you can go to the
app store that's basically the chrome
web store not the play store but the
chrome web store and you can just
install this since this is already
installed you can click on launch app
and it will open this interface for you
so this is pretty uh this is not a
tutorial for advanced rest client so
i'll just be quick here you can choose
the method type which you want to hit so
let's say you want to do a post and then
you can provide the url here so remember
the url which we put here in the
controller method this has to exactly
match so http localhost
student create should be the url so let
me just copy paste this one here okay so
the url is good here it's a post type of
method which i want to do and i want to
hit this particular url now i need to
supply the content type and the body so
in the content type you can choose
application json because i'm going to
supply a json object and in the body
this is how the json object looks like
advanced risk client also provides a
nice visual interface to basically
create this json if you are thinking
that json creation is very tough it's
not actually tough it's just curly
braces and then you put key and value
key value comma let me just put an enter
here so that it's more readable so you
just put curly braces starting an end
and then you just put key value you put
a key which is the variable name and the
variables value variable name variable
value and these keys have to exactly
match the students properties so the
student.java had this name page and
address right so it has to exactly match
otherwise this will request will fail so
this is all good now i can send this
particular request when you click send
it is going to hit my springboot
application which is running on
localhost 8080 it is going to call the
student slash create method it is also
going to convert this json into a java
object because here i am supplying a
java object so it will convert the json
which i am sending from here to java
object automatically and it is going to
automatically save it here because i've
called the repository.save method so
let's hit send here once i hit send i
get a 200 okay it means everything went
fine and in the response header i get
the object back because i have returned
the object here you see this save method
is going to return the same student
object which you created
so everything is good here my object has
been stored here and now it's time to
fetch the object so it has already been
saved into the h2 in memory database and
you can obviously go and connect to the
in memory h2 database and have a look at
it but for simplicity i'm just going to
do this here and let's say the first
object is generally
added as the id one by default by the h2
database so let's hit this particular
url when i hit this url it is going to
hit the student controller here and in
the student controller it is going to
hit the get student method which is
having a student id url and it is going
to find the database with that id and if
it finds a student object with that id
it is going to return that so let's
confirm that now let's hit this
particular send button and it's going to
hit a get request with this particular
url springboard is going to find if a
student with the id 1 exists in its
database
so once i hit send i get a 200 okay and
you see in the response headers i get
the same student object back which i
added let's try with 2 now let's see
what happens i see 2 and i get 500
internal server error because there is
no object stored in the h2 database of
the spring application with the id 2 yet
because we only inserted one object
that's why only one student object is
there and the first id which h2 database
created for it automatically was one so
when you hit for get request with a
student id 1 you get the object when you
put any invalid value and you hit this
you get a 500 internal server error you
can also make it look nice by not
sending the 500 internal server error
and sending a nice exception from the
back end so from here you can also send
a nice exception that if this object is
not found you can say something like
that or else throw which is again an
optional object and here you can supply
a particular type of exception which you
want to supply instead of just throwing
500 internal server error but that's
just additional thing additional
defensive programming you can do you can
add more and more validations and
constraints into this project as you
build this project in a more complex
paradigm so this is basically what i
wanted to show you that and that we have
created a spring up boot application we
have connected it to a database we
haven't created also an http endpoint
with student controller we ran that
application we used any random rest
client in my case i used advanced stress
client and we first did a post request
we provided the exact url the url has to
exactly match with the controller url
and then the body the request body also
has to exactly match with the student
objects property especially the case of
the names have to exactly match so if
this all this matches then you will get
a response back that the object has been
created if you want to fetch the value
of the object you're going to use the
http get method and you again provide a
url which has to exactly match to some
method in some controller in the spring
boot application which is running on
localhost and if you provide the right
id you are going to return get a valid
result if you provide an invalid id you
are going to get a 500 internal server
error and from here on you can make this
controller as robust and as mature as
you want you can add find all method you
can add update student method you can
add a delete student method you can have
all different kinds of filters like for
example return to me all the students
starting with the name a or return all
the first
students uh with the role number one and
hundred or between one and hundred so
you can write as many endpoints as you
want and build this application in
as with as much maturity and as much
complexity as you want if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
skill up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
the ultimate goal of engineering has
always been not just to learn but in
fact to build something extraordinary
that seemed impossible
your personal project is the one thing
that makes your resume stand out and
your skills sharper than the rest today
we will be going through some of the
project ideas related to java
programming language
so the first project that we will deal
today is the online career management
system
so this particular project motto is to
deal with the career management system
the system will be used for day-to-day
activities like buy written booking
delivery and non-delivery and
self-pickup etc
it is not easy to build this particular
project all alone as the technicality of
the project is a little complex for a
single programmer i would suggest you
that you get a team with you and also
look out for some automation in the
process by developing the relevant
software
robotic process automation is the new
normal in today's life the web enabled
interface allows the user to log in from
anywhere in the world and track their
career and also view the customer rating
the system is designed to integrate with
financial accounting to eliminate
duplication of data entry and is also
scalable to grow along with your company
the system needs to be built with
user-friendly screens rich in
functionality and features and finally
the major part it should maintain a high
level of data integrity
so with that abstract discussed now
let's look into the features offered by
this particular online courier service
as discussed in the abstract this
particular project should be providing
the features of order and dispatch of
the product information regarding the
customer delivery executive and followed
by the delivery executor we should be
also having a payment window which
manages the accounts and bill reports
so having said that let's now move into
the software requirements
so the software used in this particular
project is the programming language that
is java database is the microsoft access
and some convenient rpa tools and
finally the ide the id for this can be
any one which has a good support for
java the most preferable one would be
the eclipse and then comes the intellij
netbeans and many more now creating this
kind of a project will give you a
valuable experience based on building a
fully fledged e-commerce website or an
application
i mean this is how the worst leading
applications like amazon flip cards or
matteo etc are basically planned and
have reached greater heights today this
kind of project on your resume could
make a huge difference and who knows
tomorrow you might even get into one of
those companies and start working on
their projects or build a company of
your own
followed by the online career system we
have the online voting system
now thinking apart from getting a job or
starting a new company of your own this
is something that we all need today in
this pandemic situation especially in
the current scenario the internet has
brought all the east to our living room
it has replaced physical banking to
internet banking ordering food online
buying movie tickets
buying clothes and household items to
consult your doctor for minor issues
bill payments and many more
yet for quite a long time going to
polling booth and standing in a long
queue to cast a vote has been persistent
and it has been challenging for the
government to motivate common people to
participate in the election system and
cast their vote just because there is no
other way to do such thing as such an
online voting system but all the credit
can be achieved by software engineers
who can make it possible soon for
everyone to cast their vote to their
respective candidate as their own choice
with an unmatchable ease
this can be done just by click on their
fingers
this is an advanced java project
developed to show online voting
functionality followed by the abstract
we will get into the technicality of
this particular project so the first
phase of this particular project has the
admin phase where the admin has the
right to manage the candidates manage
the voters and their profiles and
passwords and finally election results
followed by the admin we have the voter
or the user of this particular
application the voter or the user gets
to
register himself or herself into the
application followed by that he can use
the login and logout options and next we
have the profile and password
managements so followed by that we have
the option to choose the positions to
vote and finally to cast the vote now
this particular project is an advanced
level java project developed to show
online voting functionality it showcases
the use of java servlets html and css
again coming into the ide the ide for
this can be anyone who has good support
for java the most preferable one would
be eclipse and intellij
followed by the online voting system we
will now continue with the online
healthcare management
named as the corporate medicare
management this e-healthcare management
system is a web-based project developed
in java
the main aim of this particular project
is to provide effective management of
data related to staff and patients in
hospitals or clinics
the features offered by this particular
project should be as follows it should
optimize bed occupation the project
should improve the use of operation
theaters avoiding the cancellation of
operations to know how much emergencies
affect the administration of the
hospital departments or services which
include cancellation of operations
to optimize the allocation of human and
material resources to warts and shifts
to detect the influence of certain
diseases in the hospital services and
finally to find clusters of patients
the software requirement for this
particular project are as follows
we need dhtml for the front end
and java as the programming language
and data mining tool which is weka
and oracle for the database
javascript for the scripting language
and finally tomcat as our server the
e-health care management system is a
web-based application that assists the
management of staff doctors and patients
in an easy comfortable and effective way
here the concept of data mining plays a
vital role to develop an effective
health care management system
the proposed application aims to create
a friendly working environment for any
healthcare centers to overcome the
drawbacks in the existing system of
healthcare management this system is
very reliable and flexible from all
aspects so new features and modules can
be easily integrated into the system in
the future
followed by the e-healthcare management
system we have a new normal online
banking
not interesting and arousing for a
normal person but for a hardcore
programmer it is as exciting as a
rollercoaster ride in an amusement park
because this is how the major national
and multinational banks implement their
banking facilities in a wide range so
that their customers could experience
the ease of banking at their fingertips
one such type of project on your resume
could bring major highlight to the
recruiter especially if the recruiter is
from a banking or financial based
company
online banking system project is a model
internet banking site this project
should enable the customers to perform
basic bank transactions by sitting at a
corner of their home or office through a
phone or laptop the customers can access
bank's website for viewing their account
details and perform the transactions on
account as per the requirement bank
employees can login and add customer and
account information to perform
transactions with internet banking with
internet banking the break and mode
structure of the traditional bank gets
converted into a click and portal mode
thereby giving the concept of virtual
banking a real shape thus today's
banking is no longer confined to
branches
e-banking facilities banking
transactions by
customers round the clock globally the
features you can offer through this
particular project are
home page for online banking site
creation of new accounts login and log
out
manage profiles and passwords view the
balance of the account deposit the
amount into the selected account whether
amount from the selected account
transfer the amount from one account to
another close the account so the
software requirements for this
particular project are java programming
language and and javascript for
scripting language and oracle for
database and tomcat for server
so followed by the online banking
project we have the online examination
project
online exams are normal for us nowadays
but this is totally limited to high-end
exams like cet gre cad etc the
requirement for this particular project
is increasing day by day because of the
current scenarios
many schools and colleges have now
turned towards the online education
system and are looking forward to
hosting online exams for student safety
online examination is a simple project
developed to provide an online platform
for faculty and students to conduct
online examinations and their
evaluations
this particular project has two parts
first is the admin part
admin has the right to add students
create one-time login adding questions
receive answers and finally to evaluate
followed by the first part we have the
second part which belongs to the
students
so the students can login update their
profile and password select answers for
the mcqs write answers to questions and
finally closing the session and log out
this particular project can be made a
grand success by making use of simple
java servlets and java programming
languages and server like apache tomcat
followed by the online examinations we
have the smart city smart city java
project can be a web-based software
developed to store the details of a
particular city the main purpose of the
project is to help tourists and other
visitors to a city by providing
information about hotels transportation
facilities air ticket booking shopping
details city news etc the smart city
java project serves the visitors as a
guide of the city and hence the project
is called as city guide project in java
using this project the details of the
city can be accessed from anywhere at
any time the implementation of the city
project promotes tourism and business
effectively
hotels can be searched more easily from
anywhere
with the help of this online software
students can look out for academic
institutes located in the city you can
view the complete map of the city using
this project
followed by the abstract we have the
features of this particular project the
features offered in this particular
project are login update profile and
password search for the options select
an option like booking a ticket or hotel
or anything like
transportation etc and finally selecting
that particular option
booking that option and payment window
finally the confirmation of the order
this particular project can be fulfilled
by using the following software tools as
mentioned below
they are the java programming language
tomcat server scripting languages like
javascript etc and database
as oracle for interactive data storage
this could be escalated to another level
by following
design drones that can act like a cop
act as a tourist guide for the people
touring the city a drone that has
capability to take pictures videos of
suspected activities and store it for
future reference a drone can intimidate
a cop if any suspected activities are
detected
there can be many drones in the city
with different functionalities and
finally you are required to implement
the functionality of the drone
to the users to interact with the drone
users could be travelers or comps or
travel agents or cab agents the code for
all these projects are provided in the
description box below followed by the
smart city we have
the bug tracking system
the bug tracking system is a web-based
application developed by java
programming language for software
companies
the main aim of this project is to
manage the errors or bugs that occur
during the software development phase
and cycle after the implementation of
this project the employees can update
the issue details solve the issues and
update the system for any location with
internet access
below are the features of this project
and source code of this project is
linked in the description box below
coming into features the software is
applicable in managing the bugs that
occur during the development of software
and tracking the older issues it
facilitates searching the facility to
bug history and solution the system is
fully secured and authentication method
is adopted
to manage security it stores the old bug
reports so that they can easily be
solved when they reappear the
application helps the project manager in
evaluating the works of the employees
and finally the proposed software is
capable of auto update when the latest
version is
available so the software requirements
for this particular project are
programming language which is java
web-based applications such as jdbc jndi
servlets jsp and oracle database or
access database as the database
followed by that the server deployment
is red hat jboss es etc and the client
side scripting as the javascript and the
id for this particular project would be
eclipse with all the my eclipse plugins
and finally the user interface can be
designed using html and css
so with this we can move ahead into the
next project which is the facial
recognition
the face recognition with opencv is an
open source computer vision library that
has tons of modules like object
detection face detection and augmented
reality
the major features that this particular
project office are managing the user
faces facilitate face identification
easy login and log out store face ids
identify suspects with just images
enhanced way to find cyber criminals so
followed by the features now we should
look into the software requirements to
build this particular project so the
programming language we need for this
particular project is java and followed
by the programming language we need the
apache and framework
mingw64 and finally the cmake framework
so followed by the facial recognition
project we have the next project which
is the vehicle recognition
so java anpr is a number plate
recognition software which implements
algorithmic and mathematical principles
from artificial intelligence machine
vision and neural networks
so the features offered by this
particular project are high level
language for numerical computation
interactive environment for iterative
exploration mathematical functions
built-in graphics functions for
integrating matlab and many more so this
particular project can be fulfilled by
using opencv and java programming
language along with some natural
language processing
algorithms so followed by vehicle
recognition project we have a last
project which is the speech recognition
system so speech recognizer converts
audio to text java x dot speech dot
recognition package defines the
recognizer interface to build speech
recognition plus a set of supporting
classes and interfaces
so the features or stages in this
particular project are to create a
speech recognizer allocate resources
load and enable grammar attach result
listener comment changes and finally
provide the process results
so this particular library is readily
available in java and you can code this
project using the java programming
language and an id such as eclipse
let's begin with our interview questions
at first we will start with the beginner
level interview questions
so in the beginner level interview
questions the first question we have is
what is jit
so the answer for this question is
jit is an abbreviation for java in time
compiler it increases efficiency of the
interpreter by compiling the bytecode in
the runtime
jit or just in time compiler compiles
code to machine level directly for
higher speeds of code execution
so basically just in time compilation is
a feature added to the interpreter of
java so this involves conversion of the
code directly to machine level during
the compilation stage this improvises
the speed of execution of a java program
now after the first question the second
question in the docket is
what is a class loader
now let's discuss the answer for this
particular question
so basically class loader is the first
file to load when you execute any java
program so the java class loader is the
integrated part of java virtual machine
so the functionality of class loader is
to load the class to the java virtual
machine while it is demanded to execute
a class
java has both strap extension and
application type of class loaders so the
third question in the docket is
what are the memory allocations
available in java
so the answer for this particular
question is java provides multiple types
of memory allocations but the five major
types of memory allocations which are
most frequently used are class memory
heap memory stack memory program counter
memory native method stack memory
so the next question in the list is
will the program run if i write static
public void main so basically we write
public static word main but in case
imagine if i write the program as static
public void main will the program
execute properly so the answer for this
question is yes because java does not
follow any specific rule for the order
of specifiers you place in your program
so when you execute the program with
such pattern in your specifiers then the
program will compile successfully also
it will run successfully
so the next question we have is
what is the default value stored in
local variables
so in c programming language when you
declare a local variable or a global
variable or any type of variable
then the first value which is stored
inside that variable will be a garbage
value unless you initialize the variable
with a personalized value for example if
you declare a variable i equal to 0 then
you are storing a value in that variable
i that is 0. if you just declare it as
int i then the value stored inside that
i variable will be a garbage value so
similarly when you declare some kind of
local variable in java then what will be
the default value stored inside it
so the answer for this question is
neither the local variables or the
global variables or any primitives or
any object references do not have any
kind of default value stored in them
so followed by the fifth question we
have the sixth question so what would be
the output of the following code segment
is the sixth question so this might
happen sometimes so basically what
happens is your interviewer will throw a
question at you which has a code segment
so all you need to do is decode that
code in your mind and provide the output
so this would be the code that we will
be dealing with
so you can see
our question has two printf statements
the first one has hundred plus hundred
plus a string which is simply learn and
in the second printf statement we have a
string that is e-learning company plus
hundred plus hundred so what will be the
output of these two printf statements
so the answer for this question is
really simple
so we'll be having 200 simply learn as
the first output and e-learning company
1 0 0 1 0 0 as the second output why
let's check out the code segment once
again
so when you see the code segment once
again so the first printf statement has
100 plus 100 plus simply learn so jvm
here understands hundred as an integer
value and the plus symbol as an addition
operator here so followed by the
addition operator we have another
integer value so what jvm does is it
adds the two numbers hundred plus
hundred so followed by that we have
another plus symbol here so followed by
the plus symbol we have a string value
so here the jvm considers the plus
symbol as
a concatenating operator but not as an
addition operator so that's why the
first two numbers got added and the
result was 200 and the next two values
were concatenated so it became as 200
simply learn similarly in the second
printf statement the jvm encountered
with a string value
so it considered the plus symbol as a
concatenating operator similarly it
happened with the second plus symbol as
well so that's the reason we had
e-learning one zero zero one zero zero
as the second output
now followed by the sixth question we
have the seventh question
what is an association
so the answer for this question is an
association can be defined as a
relationship that has no ownership over
the other so to understand this
definition we can consider a simple
example
consider a person associated with
multiple banks so consider person x who
has got accounts in bank a bank b and
bank c
and similarly a bank is associated with
person x
that is a bank a bank b and banksy are
associated with the person x but no one
has ownership over the other a person x
who is an account holder with all the
three banks that is a b and c does not
possess any kind of ownership over the
three banks similarly
banks a b and c who has the customer
which is the person x
but the banks do not possess any kind of
ownership over the customer
so the relationship between the person x
and the banks abc can be considered as
an association
now followed by the seventh question we
have the next question that is the
eighth question
define copy constructor and java so the
answer for this question is as follows
a copy constructor in java is a
constructor that initializes an object
through another object of the same class
a copy constructor in java is really
helpful because when you want to copy a
complex object that has several fields
or when we want to make a deep copy of
an existing object then the copy
constructor is the one which will help
you out in this situation
so followed by the eighth question we
have the ninth question
what is a marker interface
so the answer for this question is
an empty interface in java is referred
as a marker interface
serializable and cloneable are some of
the popular examples of marker interface
so basically a marker interface is just
another interface but normally in
interface we provide some signatures so
these signatures belong to particular
methods so
in normal interface we just have method
signatures but not the complete
implementation or at least we'll be
having some variables but in a marker
interface we do not have any kind of
data manipulating method signatures any
data members nothing they have special
functionality unlike a normal interface
so followed by the ninth question we
have the tenth question
what is object cloning
i guess the word object learning is
completely self-explanatory yet the
answer for this question is it is an
ability to recreate an object completely
similar to the existing object this
process is known as object cloning in
java
java provides a built-in function or
method that is the clone method to clone
an existing object offering the same
functionality that of the original
object
so followed by the 10th question we have
our 11th question
why is java not completely object
oriented so this question might be a
little confusing but it's true java is
not completely object oriented but
what's the reason yes i'll explain you
why java is not completely object
oriented
so the answer for this question is java
is not considered as 100 object-oriented
programming language because of the data
types it
it still makes use of eight or more
primitive data types which are end flow
double and few others so this is the
only reason why java is not considered
as completely 100 percent object
oriented programming language so the
next question is
define wrapper classes in java
so the answer for this question is
in java when you declare primitive data
types that is the end float double etc
then the wrapper classes are responsible
for converting them into objects or
reference types just as we discussed
before
java is not 100 object oriented
programming language just because of the
primitive data types it uses so when you
include such primitive data types then
wrapper classes are the ones which
convert them into objects or reference
types for the ease of compilation and
execution of programs without any issues
so followed by this question we have the
next question
define singleton classes in java so the
answer for this question is in java when
you make the constructor of a class as
private then the particular class can
generate only one single object this is
the reason why such type of classes are
called as singleton classes
so followed by that we have our next
question that says define package in
java so if you use some of the popular
ides that is the integrated development
enterprises such as intellij or eclipse
then you might be familiar with projects
packages source files and then the class
file so basically you create a project
first and inside the project you will be
having your source folder and then you
will be creating your own package using
the source folder and inside the package
you will create a class file and inside
the class file is where you write your
java program so here the question is
define package in java
so the answer for this question is as
follows
package is a collective bundle of
classes and interfaces along with
necessary libraries and jar files the
use of packages helps in code
reusability so basically when you create
a specific package inside that package
you will store all the class files that
you will be using in your java program
so not only class files in case if you
use any kind of connectors or any kind
of jar files or any kind of dependencies
for your java program you will include
all those inside the package so that the
requirements and the class files are
bundled together and
this helps out in code reusability
making sure that the
program files or the java files or any
dependencies are not juggling between
one package to the other or one file to
the other so using a package is
basically a good practice
so followed by this we have our next
question
can you implement pointers in java
program
so if you remember
c programming language we had pointers
there
so we use pointers to directly access
the memory
so similarly can you use pointers in a
java program this is a little tricky
question for beginners but basically
it's really simple
now the answer for this question is
no
because java virtual machine
personally takes care of memory
management implicitly so java's major
motive was to keep programming simple so
accessing memory directly through
pointers is not a recommended action so
the answer is a big no you cannot
implement pointers in java program
so followed by that we have our next
question
differentiate between instance and local
variables
so the answer for this question is
really simple instance variables are
declared inside a class and the scope is
limited to only a specific object inside
which an instance variable is created so
followed by the instance variable we
have the local variable so the local
variable can be anywhere inside a method
or a specific block of code also the
scope is limited to the block of code
where the variable that is the local
variable is declared
now followed by the 16th question we
have our next question
explain java string pool so the answer
for this question is a collection of
strings in java's heap memory is
referred as java's string pool so for
example you wanted to create a new
string
consider your name so your name might be
some xyz so if you wanted to create xyz
string then you provide that particular
code to your jvm so what does jvm do it
will not directly create that particular
string first it will search for the xyz
string in your string pool if that is
already existing in your string pool
then it will provide a reference to that
particular string in case if xyz is not
there then the jvm will create a new
string that is the xyz string
so followed by this we have our next
question that is
what is an exception
so the answer for this question is an
exception in java is considered as an
unexpected event that can disrupt the
normal flow of the program
so for example just consider that you
are going to write a program for
division operator
so after you finish your program your
evaluator might want to test your code
to the extreme levels so instead of
providing a proper number imagine that
your evaluator is providing a wrong
input such as special symbols sometimes
0 or any other sort of input so if this
kind of input is provided to your
program then your program might crash so
you can avoid this kind of crash by
using exception handling so basically
you can use try and catch blocks so you
can embed your code inside the try block
and say to your program that if any kind
of wrong input such as special symbol or
zero is provided by the evaluator then
send a message saying wrong input or
divide by zero exception so this kind of
approach will provide an output but this
kind of approach will avoid your program
from crashing so this is how exceptions
are handled in real time so followed by
this we have our next question
what is final keyword in java
so the answer for this question is the
term final is a predefined word in java
that is used while declaring values to
variables when a value is declared using
the final keyword then that particular
value of that particular variable will
remain constant throughout the execution
of program so sometimes if you include a
normal variable and
provide an operation on that particular
variable then the value of that
particular variable will change after
the execution of program but when you
declare the same variable using final
keyword then no number of operations or
any kind of manipulations applied onto
that variable will not change the value
of that particular variable so that's
the speciality of final keyword in java
so followed by that we'll dive into the
next question that is
what happens when the main method is not
declared as static
so the answer for this question is
when the main method is not declared a
static then the program may be compiled
perfectly but ends up with a serious
ambiguity and throws a runtime error
that says
no such method error
so when you basically declare a main
method don't forget to specify the
static keyword
so with this we finish the beginner
segment of questions followed by the
beginners segment we have the next
segment that is the intermediate level
segment
so the first question in the
intermediate level is
what is jdk and mention the variance of
jdk
so the answer for this question is
so jdk is basically an abbreviation for
java development kit
this is a combined package of jre that
is the java runtime environment and
developer tools used for designing java
applications and applets
oracle has the following variants for
java development kit
so the first one is the jdk standard
edition which is normally used by
beginners and intermediate developers
next after the jdk standard edition we
have the java development kit for
enterprise
so this particular enterprise edition is
used by professional java developers for
developing java based applications and
frameworks
now the last one is the java development
kit micro edition
now followed by 21st question we will
dive into the next question that says
brief access specifiers and types of
access specifiers in java so the answer
for this question is as follows
basically access specifiers are
predefined keywords used to help a java
virtual machine to understand the scope
of a particular data member or data
manipulating method within a class or
outside the class so in java we have
four types of access specifiers the
first one is public access specifier so
when you declare a data member or a data
manipulating method as public then that
particular data member or method can be
accessible by any class or object
throughout the package
followed by that we have the private
access specifier so unlike the public
access specifier when you provide the
private access specifier then the
accessibility of that particular private
data member or the data manipulating
method will be provided to specific
classes and specific objects only
and finally we have the protected access
specifier so the protected access
specifier is a bit more secure than the
private access specifier so the access
for this particular protected data
member or protected data manipulating
method could be a little more difficult
to access unless you are going to
implement everything which is present in
that particular package
so basically if you are trying to access
the protected data member or protected
data manipulating method
of a different package then you need to
first import the package into your
existing package so that's how the
protected access specifier works
practically
so finally after the major three axis
specifiers we have the default access
specifier so default access specifier
will be provided by the java virtual
machine so in case if you declare a
variable or a data manipulating method
without using any specific access
specifiers that are public private and
protected then jvm implicitly considers
the default access specifier so there is
no much of a difference between the
public access specifier and the default
access specifier both have the same
functionality and accessibility so
followed by this question we enter into
the next question that is
can a constructor return a value
so the answer for this question is as
follows yes
a constructor can written a value it
basically returns the current instance
of a class implicitly you cannot make a
constructor written a value explicitly
but
automatically it returns the instance of
a class
so the next question is explain this
keyword in java so in java we do have a
keyword which is called as this so what
does the keyword this mean in java is a
question
so the answer for this question is the
term this is a special keyword
designated as a reference variable so
the term this keyword is used to refer
to the current class properties like
data manipulating method instance data
member and constructors so followed by
the 24th question we have our next
question that says
explain super keyword in java so the
answer for this question is as follows
the term super is a special keyboard
designated as a reference variable so
similar to this keyword even super
keyword acts as a reference variable but
the difference is super keyword is used
to refer to the immediate parent class
object
so followed by the 25th question we have
our next question
that is explain
method overloading in java so basically
method overloading and method overriding
etc are the concepts of polymorphism so
now let's have a correct answer here
so the process of creating multiple
method signatures using one method name
is called as method overloading
so for example consider that you wanted
to include an addition operation in your
program that performs addition operation
so the first method will be having the
name add and inside the method
parameters you will be having two
integer types of parameters similarly
you wanted to perform another addition
operation with the same name at so here
you will provide the method name
completely same to the first method but
inside the parameters there is a
difference
you are adding
three parameters here
so when you pass the values to the add
method then which method to be
overloaded that's the confusion right so
should i overload or should i execute
the first add method or the second
method so this completely depends on the
number of parameters you pass if you are
passing two parameters then the first
method will be executed if you are
passing three parameters then the second
method will be executed so this is how
the method overloading happens in java
so
the process of method overloading can be
achieved by using two different ways the
first way is to change the number of
arguments so that's what exactly i've
discussed before now the second way is
varying the written type of the method
so with this let's enter into the next
question
can we overload a static method
so as discussed before
the values of the variables or data
manipulating methods will not be changed
when we have used the keyword static in
front of it so the question is can we
overload a static method
now let's discuss the answer for this
the answer is no java does not support
overloading of static method the process
worked through an error reading static
method cannot be referenced
so followed by this we have our next
question
so the next question is define
late binding
the answer for this question is
binding is a process of unifying the
method call with the methods code
segment
late binding happens when the methods
code segment is unknown till the method
is called during the runtime
so followed by this we have our next
question define dynamic method dispatch
so the answer is the dynamic method
dispatch is a process where the method
call is executed during the run time the
overridden method is called through a
reference variable of superclass so this
process is called as runtime
polymorphism
now we have our next question
why is delete function faster in
linkedlist than an array
so basically linkedlist and array are
the java collections or in other words
it's also considered as data structure
so to answer this question you need to
understand the analogy of linked list
and array so basically an array is um
complete memory block of consecutive
memory locations
so consider that your memory location
starts from 100 and your array has 10
locations so it's a complete reserved
block of from 100 101 102 to 1.9
so you have 10 memory blocks so in case
if you wanted to add a number or a
delete a number then you had to make
changes to the complete memory block but
when you come into linked list
you have
the memory blocks used from the memory
heap so basically what you do here is
you basically connect the nodes through
addresses
so in case if you wanted to eliminate a
number then what you do is just to
manipulate the addresses so the address
of the consecutive node will be changed
so that's the only change what you make
so now
this is the reason why the
delete function or any kind of
manipulation function is faster in
linked list compared to array
so now let's have a brief answer on this
delete function is faster in linked list
as the user needs to make a minor update
to the pointer value so that the node
can point to the next successor in the
list now followed by this we have our
next question
give a briefing on the life cycle of a
thread
so the life cycle of a thread includes
five stages which are as mentioned below
newly bound state runnable state that is
it provides the jvm with a feedback that
i'm ready to run now followed by that
the running stage where the threat is
actually running followed by that the
block stage so basically the thread will
be blocked for some reasons for some
intermediate output or something if the
thread is waiting for an input from
another source or
something similar so that's where the
blocked state comes to existence and
finally the dead state once after
everything is processed the threat is
eliminated by gvm
now followed by this we have our next
question that says
explain the differences between
the operators provided here
so the operators might look similar but
they are different now let's understand
about these operators in a much better
way through the answer so the answer for
this question is although they look
similar but there's a huge difference
between them so the first operator which
looks like two greater than symbols
perform the operation of right shifting
so when you provide a binary number or
binary value then the bits will be
shifted towards the right and the second
symbol or the second operator
which is having three greater than
symbols is used to shift out the zero
filled bits so this is the functionality
of these two operators now followed by
that let's have the 33rd question
brief the life cycle of an applet
so the answer for this question is the
life cycle of an applet basically
involves the following stages the first
stage is the initialization stage next
is the start stage third is the stop
stage fourth is destroy and finally we
have paint
now the next question is
why are generics used in java
so the answer for this question is
compile time type safety is provided by
using generics in java so this approach
allows the users to catch unnecessary
invalid inputs at the time of
compilation
generic methods and classes help
programmers to specify a single method
declaration a set of related methods or
with a single class declaration a set of
related types
so followed by this we have our next
question
explain
externalizable interface
so the answer for this question is the
externalizable interface helps with the
control over the process of
serialization the externalization
interface incorporates read external and
right external methods so we have
listened to a new term here which is
serialization so what exactly is
serialization
serialization is a process of sending
your java code or java project from one
computer system to a different computer
system so basically if you wanted to
execute some kind of java program from a
different location then you serialize
this particular code to a different
location where you actually want to
execute and this particular process of
transferring your code is called as
serialization
now the next question is explain daemon
thread so the answer for this question
is the daemon thread can be defined as a
thread with least responsibility the
demon thread is designed to run in a
background during the process of garbage
collection in java
the set daemon method is used to create
the demon thread in java programming
language
so we have our next question now explain
the term enumeration in java
so the answer for this question is
enumeration or enum is an interface in
java enum allows the sequential access
of elements stored in a collection in
java now the next question is why is
java considered as a dynamic programming
language
so the answer for this question is java
was designed to adapt to an evolving
environment java programs include large
amount of runtime information that is
actually used to resolve access to the
objects in real time so this is a reason
why java is considered as dynamic
programming language
now followed by this we have our next
question
can you run a code before executing the
main method
so the answer for this question is
yes we can execute any code even before
the main method
we will be using the static block of
code in the class when creating the
objects at low time of the class any
statements within the static block of
the code will execute it once while
loading the class even before the
creation of objects in the main method
now the last question in the
intermediate section is how many times
the finalized method is called so the
answer for this question is the
finalized method is called by the
garbage collector so for every object
the garbage collector calls the
finalized method just
for
once
now with this let's enter the advanced
segment of interview questions based on
java
so the first question in the advanced
segment is can the keywords this
and super
be used together
so the answer for this question is
no
this and super keywords should be used
in the first statement in the class
constructor so the following code
segment will give you a better idea
so you can see that we have used the
keyword super and this in the class
constructor that is the first class
constructor now this is how you can use
super keyword and this keyword together
in case if you wanted to use so with
this let's continue with the next
question in the advanced level
so the next question says explain jsp
page so the answer for this question is
jsp is basically an abbreviation for
java servlet page so the java servlet
page consists of two types of text the
first is the static data and the second
one is java servlet page elements
now the next question is
explain
jdbc so the answer is jdbc is an
abbreviation for java database connector
jdbc is an abstract layer used to
establish connectivity between any
existing database and to a java
application
next question is
explain the various directives of jsp
so the directives are instructions
processed by jsp engine after the jsp
page is compiled into a servlet
directives are used to set page level
instructions
insert data from external files and
specify custom tag libraries directives
are defined between the following
symbols
so these are the symbols that are used
to specify the directives in a jsp page
the different types of directives are
shown as below there are three types of
directives they are include directive
page directive and tagleb directive
so include directive includes a file and
merges the content of the file with the
current page the page directive is used
to define specific attributes in the jsp
page like error page and buffer
the taglib directory is used to declare
a custom tag library which is used in
the jsp page
followed by that we have the next
question
what are observer and observable classes
so the answer for this question is
objects that subclass the observable
class maintain a list of observers
when an observable object is updated it
invokes the update method of each of the
observers to notify that the observers
that it has changed its state
the observer interface is implemented by
objects that observe observable objects
might be a little confusing but you need
to read this answer once again you can
pause it and you can read this answer
once again so that you can get a brief
understanding of this
followed by that we have the next
question
what is session management in java so
the answer for this question is
a session is essentially defined as the
dynamic stage of a random conversation
between the client and the server the
essential communication channel includes
the string of responses and requests
from both sides typically the most
popular way of implementing session
management is the employment of a
session id in the communicative
discourse of the client and the server
the next question is brief about spring
framework spring framework is basically
the framework of frameworks now the
answer for this question is spring is
essentially defined as the application
framework and inversion of control
container for java basically the chief
purpose of spring framework is to create
enterprise applications in java
also it is especially useful to keep in
mind that the central features of the
spring framework are essentially
conductive to any java application
so the next question is explain jca in
java so the answer for this question is
jca is basically an abbreviation for
java cryptography architecture
so jca provides a platform that gives
architecture and apis for encryption as
well as decryption
jc is used by the developer to combine
the application with the security
measure it also helps in performing the
third party security rules it uses the
hash table encryption message digest etc
to implement the security
so the next question is
explain jpa in java so the answer for
this question is jpa stands as an
abbreviation for java persistence api
the jpa is enabling us to create the
persistence layer for desktop and web
applications
jpa deals with the following java
persistence api query language java
persistence criteria api object mapping
metadata etc
so the last question in our list is
explain the different authentications in
java servlets
so the answer for this question is
authentication options available in
servlets are as follows the first one is
basic authentication so the basic
authentication consists of username and
password provided by the client to
authenticate as the user
the second one is form based
authentication
in this particular type of
authentication the login form is made by
the programmer by using
html
followed by that we have the third type
of authentication that is digest
authentication
digest authentication is similar to
basic authentication but in this the
passwords are encrypted using hash
formula
this makes digest more secured and
lastly we have the client certificate
authentication the client certificate
authentication requires that each client
accessing the resource has a certificate
that it sends to authenticate itself
this requires ssl protocol and with that
we have come to an end of this full
course on how to become a java developer
i hope this session was interesting and
informative if you have any queries
regarding the concepts covered in this
session then please feel free to let us
know in the comment sections below our
team of experts will be really happy to
solve all your queries until next time
thank you stay safe and keep learning
you